GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ORDER. LET'S START
BY CALLING THE ROLE. PLAYING
HERE FONG. AMULET BENNETT WE'RE-
A. L. CHIU COOPER FRAZIER
GALLAGHER. CRISTINA GARCIA
JONES SAWYER KILEY LACKEY LEAVE.
MATHIS MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN
VARIAN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
RAMOS RARES. RIVAS THREE OF US.
RUBIO YES. STONE. BIOTERRORIST.
WEBER WOOD. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
WAR. YES WE DO A GREAT WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU TODAY WE ARE
HOLDING OUR FIRST ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING LET ME
JUST MAKE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS
WE ARE AGAIN HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING- EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
THE LARGEST ROOM IN THE CAPITOL
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AT A MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF WHICH IS WHY WE ARE.
SEPARATED IN FOLLOWING STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE AND ALLOW TO ENTER
AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL BECAUSE
THEY CAN FEEL FREE TO LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AFTER OR I LEAVE THE
ROOM AFTER THEY HAVE MADE
THEIR- PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL
RESTATE THIS AGAIN ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT- BEGINS AND EVERYBODY
WILL HAVE A CHANCE FOR ONE
MINUTE OF PUBLIC COMMENT. WILL
ALSO HAVE THE PUBLIC FOR TO
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS AND TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE IN AGAIN THE PUBLIC
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
THEY'VE MADE THEIR COMMENTS.
FOR PANELIST WERE ON THE AGENDA
THEY WILL A- REMOTELY THERE
WILL BE VOTES IN COMMITTEE
EXTRA FOR THE- OF THE- RULES.
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
HAVE A PHONE NUMBER. TO THE
QUESTION. WHAT DO I KNOW
PERFORMANCE. YOUR AND
AFFORDABLE. CAN YOU TELL TO.
WILL BE ANNOUNCED ON THE PHONE
NUMBER ONE SECOND SORRY. GO
AHEAD CHRISTIAN. 1-877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. AND THEN THIS WILL BE
APPEARING ON YOUR TELEVISION
SCREEN OR YOUR COMPUTER SCREEN
AS WELL. IF ANY PROBLEMS
GETTING INTO THE LINE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMIC FEEL FREE TO CALL
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO OH NINE NINE- AND
AGAIN THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL ON FRIDAY.
WE WANTED TO GET RIGHT TO WORK
TO HEAR THE PROPOSED BUDGET AS
WELL AS DISCUSS ALL THE
POTENTIAL ACTIONS THAT WE MAY
NEED TO BE TAKING THAT OUR
EARLY AS WELL AS OF WHAT MIGHT
BE IN RESPONSE TO WHAT IS GOING
ON REGARDING COVERT. AS WELL
AS- A POTENTIAL FEDERAL
STIMULUS DOLLARS WHICH COULD BE
COMING. AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
CONTINUE TO FACE ONGOING
CHALLENGES WITH COVERED
NINETEEN AND EVEN AS WE ARE
ABLE TO- START OUR VACCINATION
PROCESS- WE STILL FACE MANY
CHALLENGES IN THE MONTHS TO
COME. ONE GOOD NEWS THAT WHAT
DO YOU. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
MISTER COOPER IF YOU COULD PUT
OUR TURN DAY PLEASE. EXACTLY OF.
AGAIN WE GOT GOOD NEWS A OUR
STATE BUDGET WE DO HAVE.
ADDITIONAL ONE TO. READ THAT
HAS COME. PRIMARILY DUE TO THE-
DEPENDENCE IN TAXES AND HIGH
INCOME EARNERS IT DOES APPEAR
THAT THE HIGH INCOME EARNERS IN
OUR STATE CONTIUE TO HAVE DONE
WELL GIVEN THE- STOCK MARKET
CONTINUED TO DO WELL SO WE'RE
WE HAVE THE STATE. OF THE
BENEFICIARIES. WHAT WE DO KNOW
IS THAT EVEN THOUGH THIS YEAR
THIS CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR NEXT BUDGET YEAR ARE
DOING OKAY AND NOW YEARS WE
ANTICIPATE POTENTIAL FURTHER
DEFICITS. SO THIS MONEY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ONLY
SPENT THE TEXTUALLY ONE TIME
AND NOT SPENT ON ON GOING.
PROGRAMS WE ALSO WANTED WE WERE
ALSO VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT
THE GOVERNOR INCORPORATED. MANY
OF OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
BLUEPRINT PRINCIPLES WE HAVE
FOUR MAJOR PRINCIPLES TO
PRESERVE TO RESPOND TO PROTECT
AND TO RECOVER. AND ONE WAS TO
REALLY PRESERVE. MUCH OF THE
GOOD IN TERMS OF REPAIRING OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. AS WELL AS
TO PRESERVE MUCH OF THE
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATION THAT WE
MADE OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
SINCE THE LAST GREAT RECESSION.
WE ALSO WANTED TO HAVE AN
ADEQUATE RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN DOING SURE THAT THERE
WERE INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE FAXING
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL AS SAFE RE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS. WANT TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE. BUT
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE VERGE OF HOMELESSNESS
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING. AS THEY TRY TO STAY
OPEN OR BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE.
THE WE CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO
SUPPORT ALL THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE AND AT THE SAME TIME
RECOVERY. WE KNOW THAT COVERED
NINETEEN HAS CREATED ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE EVICTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
PREVENT. WE HAVE- MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS THAT ARE. STRUGGLING
ON THE POT BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN. WE
NEED TO INVEST. IN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS AND WE
NEED TO CHANGE CAREERS. SO
THESE ARE VERY CRITICAL KEY
POINTS WERE GLAD THE GOVERNOR
INCORPORATED. MANY OF THESE
THEMES IN HIS JANUARY. WE LOOK
VERY MUCH FORWARD TO THE HOURS
OF DELIBERATION EACH OF THE SUB
COMMITTEES. AND WE LOOK VERY
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO PASS
A BALANCED BUDGET BY OUR JUNE
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE. WITHOUT I'D
LIKE TO TURN OVERSEE A FOR OUR
NEW VICE CHAIR. MISTER FALL
BECAUSE IT COMMENTS. I THANK
YOU FOR TAKING A LOOK FOR TO
SERVING WORKING WITH YOU ON THE
UPPER BUDGET PROCESS WE'VE HAD
MANY. THIS IN THE ON PUSH FOR
MORE CAN. NO STATE AGENCIES AND
BY SOLUTION. AND SO YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN OPEN- INPUT INTO
PER. AND SO I LOOKED TO
CONTINUE THAT WORK WITH- ISN'T
TIME OUR STAY AS WE TO SOLVE.
CRISES FACING. AND I'M ALL. TO
SERVE THE VICE OF THE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR I GET OUR
STATE ON TRACK. WE MUST GET TO
THE BAY. I'M PLEASE TO SEE THE
GUY. PHIL ON. OUR BUDGET
RESERVE WHICH WILL HOPEFULLY
LESS THE IMPACT PROJECTED. I
COMING YEAR BUT I'M- THE
GOVERNOR. BUDGET REVEALS A OF.
GOING PROPHECY HERE SECOND.
INSTEAD OF. MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS OUR FOR. CRISIS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FACE HOMELESSNESS.
THAT COULD BE AT HOME WITH THIS
CRISIS POWER SHUT OFF IN A
COMPETENT EDP ACTUALLY. THEY
WERE ALL VERY FAMILIAR WITH.
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT-
ESPECIALLY IS THE VULNERABILITY
OF OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE CANNOT
COMMIT TO SIGNIFICANT RELIEF.
OR BUSINESS COMMUNITY OR FALL
SHORT OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
SAFELY OPEN SCHOOLS. THEN EVERY
DAY CALIFORNIANS WILL CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE. OUR PRIORITIES AS
I'M I THAT I BELIEVE AND I'VE
OUTLINED. IS TO GET
CALIFORNIANS. SAFELY BACK TO
WORK BY PROVIDING REGULATORY
AND TAX RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. AFTER MANY OF THEM
PERMANENTLY CLOSED. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WE NEED TO FOCUS. ON
GETTING CALIFORNIA'S BACK TO
WORK AND SUPPORTING OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. SECOND WE NEED TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS
REDUCE AND LEARNING LOSS.
CAUSED BY THE SHUTDOWN- THAT
WE'VE SEEN. THIRD WE NEED TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE BY INVESTING IN
HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. WHILE
REDUCING FRUSTRATING
PROPERTIES. AND LASTLY TO BUT
WE NEED TO PROTECT. EVERY
CALIFORNIAN FROM RISING CRIME
SCENE ACROSS OUR STATE AND WHEN
YOU SUPPORT A PUBLIC SAFETY. I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE. THAT
WE ARE IN A RESULTS ORIENTED
BUSINESS NOW MORE THAN EVER.
THE BUDGET WE CREATE WILL
REFLECT OUR PRIORITIES AND TO
PRODUCE THE RESULTS. FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
SUFFERING. WE CANNOT ACCEPT.
MORE PROGRAMS MORE TASK FORCES
THAT ARE NOT ACTUALLY SOLVING
PROBLEMS. IN PRODUCING RESULTS
FOR CALIFORNIANS LAKE FOREST
THE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR THE
MINISTRATION OF MY COLLEAGUES.
ON THIS. COMMITTEE OVER THE
COMING MONTHS AND I. A THIRD
BACK OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU MR
VICE ARE VERY OF THE THIS CALL
MAY AND MUCH LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU- I'D LIKE TO
START THE ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SESSION.
DRIVE EMOTION. THE MTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU- WE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THANK HAI FONG HI
ARAMBULA SENATE- ROOM ARE
CORREO. Q. COOPER FRAZIER
GALLAGHER. CRISTINA GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER. KILEY BLACKIE
LEAVE MATHIS PARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN THIS AREA OF DONALD.
PATTERSON RAMOS. RAYOS
THREE OF US RUBIO. LET DAHLE.
BIOTERRORIST WEBER WHAT. MOTION
PASSES THANK YOU SO FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE- OUR NEW DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FROM THE PART OF
FINANCE MISS AMERICA LEAD
PERCENT FOLLOWED BY OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST MR. PADDOCK
MISLI. CAN I BELIEVE MISTER
TERRY HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES SO MISSY IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO COME TO THE CHAMBER
PRESENT A PERSON OKAY IS ON HER
WAY HERE SO DO WE NEED TO WE
PROMISE WE ARE WITH WITH MISTER.
OKAY THEN WE GONNA WAIT ON WELL
MISS COMES THE CHAMBER.
WE'RE
GONNA START WITH A MISS AMERICA
LEAD TO BE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE TANG VICE CHAIR
FONG. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER PATTON- I AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP DEPUTY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO
SPEAK. ON THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND- YOU KNOW THESE ARE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES I DON'T
THINK I HAVE TO SAY THAT- BUT
THAT THE TEAM THAT RUNS ACROSS
MANY OF THE PROPOSALS IN OUR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IS ONE OF
BROAD BASED ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
WE HAVE A LASER FOCUS ON JOB
CREATION. AND EXPANDING
PROVIDING AND EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED.
HARD AT HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC SO I'D LIKE TO START
WITH THE STATE'S UPDATED
ECONOMIC PICTURE AND THE
OVERALL BUDGET STRUCTURE MUCH
OF WHICH YOU MAY HAVE ALREADY
HEARD THAT SAGA QUICKLY THROUGH
THE SLIDES- MOVING ON THE FLY
TO. THE RED HAVE DRAMATICALLY.
WE HAVE OUR FORECAST HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION THIS IS UP TO
NINE BILLION THE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWENTY
TWENTY. AND- THAT'S 22% SURE
SUBAHDAR GREAT OKAY.
CALIFORNIA'S GDP TOOK A BIG
HEAD IN QUARTER TO- A THIRTY
ONE POINT 5% DROP. HOWEVER BY
QUARTER THREE THE GDP WAS GOING
BACK UP AND IT WAS BACK UP TO
TWENTY NINETEEN LEVELS.
UNEMPLOYMENT HAD PEAKED AT
SIXTEEN POINT 4% BACK IN APRIL
AND MAY. AND IS NOW BACK IS NOW
DOWN TO EIGHT POINT 2% NOW ALL
THAT'S HAVE. THREE POINT 9% WAS
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE PRIOR TO
THE RECESSION- ADDITIONALLY I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE POINT
THAT THERE ARE FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS STILL RECEIVING
YOUR BENEFITS- AND THEY'RE LESS
THAN HALF OF THE JOBS THAT WERE
LOST AS OF FEBRUARY OF LAST
YEAR HAVE BEEN RECOVERED. CHECK
FLIGHT. SO THE OTHER THE GROWTH
HERE REALLY JUST DISPLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP THAT HAPPENED
IN GDP- THIS WAS EXPERIENCE NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA AS YOU CAN
SEE BUT AROUND THE COUNTRY. AND
THEN. THE MOVE TO RECOVERY. SO
THE OVERALL BUDGET STRUCTURE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ROPOSES
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
BILLION IN TOTAL EXPENDITURES
THAT'S A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
BILLION GENERAL FUND. I'M SURE
THE BUDGET MAINTAINS RESILIENCY
AND BUILD A STRONG REVENUE
ATARI STRONG RESERVE OF TWENTY
TWO BILLION. WE HAVE A ONE TIME
SURPLUS AT FIFTEEN BILLION. AND
WE ALSO PROPOSE PAYING DOWN ON
ADDITIONAL RETIREMENT
LIABILITIES THREE BILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. WE ALSO DUE TO THE
IMPROVED REVENUE. ARE PROPOSING
THAT SCHEDULE PROGRAM
SUSPENSIONS BE DELAYED BY A
YEAR. SO MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
SLIDE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT-
CHARGING MENTIONED EARLIER THE
IMPROVE REVENUE PICTURE IS
LARGELY DUE TO THREE FACTORS
THE FIRST BEING THAT THE-
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WASN'T AS
SEVERE AS WAS IT AS AS WAS
EXPECTED. AND THIS IS LARGELY
DUE TO THE FEDERAL. SALARS THAT
WERE PROVIDED EARLY ON IN THE
SPRING OF LAST YEAR. HOWEVER
THERE THAT THE SECOND ONE IS
PERHAPS THE MOST SURPRISING AN
EQUAL SPREAD OF WAGE LOSS THIS
IS SIGNIFICANT- WE HAD A LOT OF
HIGHWAYS WORKERS THAT WERE ABLE
TO HAVE IT AND MOVED TO
TELEWORK AND- OTHER JOBS. BUT
WE HAD A LOT OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO DO
THAT. I'M THE HIGHWAY TO WORK.
TEND TO PAY MORE INTO. AND SO
THAT REALLY BUFFERED THE
REVENUE LOSS. TO THE STATE. AND
THEIR EARLY WE HAD. A RECORD
HIGH STOCK MARKET- PERFORMANCE.
AND THAT LED TO INCREASES IN
CAPITAL GAINS. THE DIFFERENT
POINTS TO DRAW FROM THIS IS
THAT THE IMPROVER REVENUE
RECESSION. VERY IMPROVED
REVENUE. YOU'RE REALLY
UNDERSCORES THAT THERE ARE TWO
STORIES GOING ON HERE.
BASICALLY IT AT OF TWO CONNOR-
AND THE BUDGET THAT BUDGET
REALLY WORK TO- PRO.
INVESTMENTS TO HELP THE MOST
IMPACTED. SO WHILE THE
FORECASTING REVENUES IN THE
BUDGET HERE WE ARE LOOKING AT
OPERATING DEFICITS IN THE OUT
YEARS YOU GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE
AND- ON. PAGE SIX. YOU CAN SEE
I'M THE REVENUE SURPLUS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO-
IS IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED BY
OPERATING DEFICIT IN THE OUT
YEARS STARTING AT SEVEN POINT
SIX BILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND GROWING TO
OVER ELEVEN BILLION BY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. SO ONE THING
I WANNA POINT OUT HERE IS-
BEGAN LIMIT IS CURRENTLY
PROJECTED TO BE EXCEEDED BY
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- HOWEVER IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT AT THIS
POINT. THAT THESE ARE
PROJECTIONS AND FINAL REVENUES
AND EXPENDITURES WILL BE KNOWN
IT'S NOT UNTIL THE SPRING. AND
AT THAT POINT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- ESTIMATES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND WE'LL DO
THAT AT THE MAY REVISION. SO
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE. SO
WHAT THE LARGER BUDGET
STRUCTURE BEHIND US AS A
BACKDROP I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
JUST A FEW OF THE BUDGET
SIGNIFICANT AND IMMEDIATE
ACTION PROPOSALS THERE ARE MANY
AND THE SLIDE DECK- ACTUALLY
HAD MORE THAN I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON TODAY. THE FIRST
THE STATE CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE ITS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IN THE BUDGET INCLUDES
OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AN
ADDITIONAL ESTIMATED
EXPENDITURES SINCE THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. AND THESE
INCLUDE- EFFORTS AROUND TESTING
CONTACT TRACING. VACCINES
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS AND FOOD BANKS.
NEXT SLIDE. SO I REALLY WANT TO
BRING YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
THIS NEXT SLIDE AND THIS NEXT
SET OF PROPOSALS OF WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD THIS IS OUR- IMMEDIATE
BUDGET ACTION REQUEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE- THERE ARE FIVE
ISSUES HERE AND I JUST WANNA
PRESENT QUICKLY ON ON. ON EACH
OF THEM SO THAT WE HAVE TWO
BILLION ARM PROPOSED FOR SAFELY
REOPENING SCHOOLS AND THIS IS
REALLY TO PRIORITIZE INS IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION- TO MITIGATE
SOME OF THE IMPACTS. ON
STUDENTS OF THE PANDEMIC HAS
CAUSED. ANOTHER ONE IS THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS IS AT A
COST OF TWO POINT FOUR BILLION.
AND THAT THIS IS BASICALLY ONE
TIME SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WERE
LOOKING AT THE TWENTY NINETEEN
E. I. T. C. POPULATION. AS WELL
AS THE TWENTY TWENTY- I TEND
YETI'S. BUT WE OFFER A SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS THE TABLE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
THAT'S FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL AS CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS.
AND THEN- FEE WAIVERS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL ENTITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED. BY HEALTH AND SAFETY
RESTRICTIONS DURING THIS TIME.
AND LASTLY I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WE HAVE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION. FEDERAL RELIEF COMING
FROM. THE GOVERNOR OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND THIS
NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED IN TERMS
OF THE BUT IMPLEMENTATION HOW
TO GET THOSE DOLLARS OUT. OF
ALONG WITH THE AFFECTION
MORATORIUM EXTENSION AND- THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM FOR BOTH
THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
MORATORIUM ENDS AT THE END OF
THIS MONTH SO THIS IS. AN
URGENT MATTER- SEVERAL TIMES
I'M GOING TO STOP WITH THAT.
AND JUST. PRESS YEAR THE
IMPORTANCE URGENCY THAT THE-
HAS TO. A THOSE ISSUES ON THAT
SIDE. OF THE REMAIN OF THE FIVE
REALLY HIGHLY OTHER PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET. OF ISSUES-
BOTH THE COST OF HEALTH DOWN SO
THAT WE CAN. PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE TO MORE PEOPLE. AND THE
COST OF HOUSING. THERE ARE
PROPOSALS THAT ADVANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. A
ROBUST HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE-
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND INVESTING ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION IN LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN SHORT
TERM FIXES. AT AND LASTLY
BUDGETING FOR RECORD LOW THE
SCHOOL FUNDING TO THE PA NINETY
A GUARANTEE. PROPOSES TAX HEAD
ON THE IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND IN INCLUDE MATH HEALTH
INVESTMENTS. SEVEN SUMMER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTS IN
JOBS AND A BROAD BASED RECOVERY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC THANK YOU AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ONLINE I'M I'M
HERE BECAUSE I WAS HAVING SOME
WEBEX ISSUES BUT HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS AT THE
RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER LEE WE ARE WAITING
FOR THE L. A. O. WHO IS ON HIS
WAY OVER HERE. SO LET ME JUST-
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY ANY
MEMBERS WHO WANT TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS- DR WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR I JUST SAW SOMECOMMENTS AND JUST SOME
OBSERVATIONS- IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR IS GOING TO BE VERY VERY
CHALLENGING FOR US THE TRAGIC
LOSS OF LIVES AND THE ECONOMIC
HARM AT THE CORPORATE BUYERS
HAS BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIANS AND
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMY- HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING.
AND TO BRING THESE THINGS BACK
TO THE WAY THEY WERE AND
ADDRESS INADEQUACIES THAT HAVE
LONG EXISTED EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC MAKE THIS YEAR VERY
DIFFICULT. GOVERNOR'S LAID OUT
A WIDE RANGING BUDGET AS AS WE
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO DO WITH
FUNDING FOR HUNDREDS OF
IMPORTANT ISSUES ALL WORTHWHILE.
OVER THE PAST DECADE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GIVE SOMETHING TO MOST.
BUT THIS YEAR IS DIFFERENT AS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY
TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER. AND
ENSURE THAT OUR PRIORITIES- ARE
TARGETED ENOUGH. IN ADEQUATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE A CASCADING OR A
WATERFALL EFFECT. AND BY THAT I
MEAN WHATEVER WE CHOOSE TO
pTHAN JUST THAT. AND BE CLEAR
ENOUGH TO ME MEANS LESS ABOUT
ADDING MORE MONEY TO THE BUDGET
BUT MORE ABOUT WHERE WE PUT IT.
ADDRESSING THE PANDEMIC IS
PARAMOUNT PREVENTING SPREAD AND
SPEEDING UP DISTRIBUTION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF VACCINE WILL
HELP SAVE LIVES. SAFE WE
OPENING SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES
AND PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HURT
FINANCIALLY CAN HELP US ALL TO
GET TO A BETTER PLACE ALLOW
LOCAL BUSINESS OWNERS A CHANCE
TO REBUILD. AND PROVIDE US WITH
THE SERVICES WE NEED WE'VE ALL
ENJOYED. ARE WE GIVING ENOUGH.
EDUCATION TO MAKE IT SAFE FOR
ALL CHILDREN WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
HEARING THAT TWO BILLION ISN'T
ENOUGH. WHAT IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER IS IT FOR BILLION IS IT
THREE BILLION. WE'VE GOT TO BE
SURE THAT WERE GIVEN ENOUGH. TO
GET THE JOB DONE AND NOT ENOUGH
JUST TO KIND OF KEEP THINGS
GOING. WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING THE VIRUS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT ARE WE PROVIDING
ENOUGH FOR A WHILE BUT WILDFIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS IN ORDER TO
REDUCE THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS
FOR THESE FIRES- ON AND- THE
CARBON EMISSIONS TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT. I NOTICED THAT. AND
I'LL PREFACE THIS BY SAYING. I
THINK MY BAR MENTAL RECORD IS.
PRETTY STRONG IN THIS BUILDING.
I OWN AN ELECTRIC CAR I LOVE MY
ELECTRIC CAR. WE HAVE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET FOR ELECTRIC CAR
INFRASTRUCTURE INCENTIVES. WE
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GOING TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. I WONDER IS THAT
THE RIGHT NUMBER. THOSE
BUSINESSES THE PEOPLE THE
RESTAURANTS THE BARS THAT THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE THE
ECONOMIC DRIVER FOR THIS
COUNTRY FOR THIS STATE AND THIS
COUNTRY OVER FOUR MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THIS STATE. THOSE
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING
TO BUY THE ELECTRIC CARS THAT
ARE GOING TO USE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. I JUST WONDER
IF THOSE ARE THE RIGHT NUMBERS
I REALLY DO. I DON'T THINK I
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS I HOPE OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND DEBATE. WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP US TO KNOW WHAT IS
ENOUGH. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO THE MONEY WE PUT
IN PLACE AS- DOES THE JOB. NOT
JUST KIND OF DOING THE JOB NOT
JUST KIND OF HOPING TO SLIP
ALONG. BUT HE'S BE TARGETED SO
WE GET THE JOB DONE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS.
JUST WHEN GIVING IDEA WALMART
WHERE MY MIND IS GOING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD-
I'M GONNA COME BACK TO YOU
MISTER COOPER R. L. A. L. IS
HERE I'M GONNA LET. R. L. A. L.
SPEAK THEN GO GO BACK TO
MEMBERS. YEP THANKS OKAY-
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WE CLOSER CLOSER TO THE MIKE
OKAY. THANK YOU- MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING OUR OFFICE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
MY NAME IS GAY PANIC
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND YOUR
STAFF ASKED ME TO PROVIDE A FEW
BRIEF OVERVIEW COMMENTS. ON OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL SO I
WILL DO THAT AND THEN FOLLOWING
THAT- IT SOME OF MY I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AND I HAVE
SOME OF MY- STAFF COLLEAGUES
AVAILABLE AS WELL. SO THE
REMARKS I WILL MAKER OUTLINED
BY THE HAND OUT WHICH YOU
SHOULD HAVE IN YOUR MATERIALS.
BUT IT'S ALSO FOR ANYONE ELSE
AVAILABLE ELADIO DOT CA DOT GOV.
AND- JUST MENTION THAT ALSO WE
RELEASED OUR REPORT- ON OUR
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL
AND THAT'S AVAILABLE- THAT WAS
RELEASED LAST NIGHT. OKAY O.
MOVING TO PAGE ONE OF THE HAND
OUT- WE CALCULATED THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
REFLECTS A FIFTEEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
REVENUE- URGE. THIS SURPLUS IS
LOWER NOTICEABLY LOWER THAN THE
TWENTY SIX BILLION DOLLAR
WINDFALL WE REFER TO- WE
ESTIMATED IN OUR NOVEMBER
FISCAL OUTLOOK. WE DESCRIBED IT
AS A WINDFALL BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THAT HELPED EMPHASIZE
THE ONE TIME NATURE OF THIS- A
SURPLUS AND ALSO BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS THE RESULT OF THE
FACT THAT REVENUES DIDN'T
PLUNGE IN THE WAY THAT THE
BUDGET ACT ASSUME SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT SO MUCH AS THEY HELD
CONSTANT AND FOLLOWED THE
HISTORIC TREND. THEY DIDN'T
ACTUALLY KNOW SURGE HIGHER THAN
THE HISTORIC. IN WITH THAT SAID
THE REVENUES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OUR NUMBERS ARE
VERY SIMILAR OVER THE THREE
YEAR BUDGET WINDOW WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF ONLY ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE STATE BUDGET
IS QUITE SMALL FOR A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. GIVEN THAT THE REVENUES
ARE FAIRLY SIMILAR YOU MAY.
WONDER HOW COULD OUR- ESTIMATE
OF THE SURPLUS BE SO DIFFERENT.
AND THERE ARE THREE MAIN
REASONS FOR THAT. THE FIRST IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS A DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION
OF THE RULES GOVERNING WHEN A
DEPOSIT OR A TRUE UP DEPOSIT TO
THE STATE'S. RAINY DAY FUND AND
DEBT REPAYMENT PROVISIONS OF
PROPOSITION TWO IS REQUIRED.
UNDER THEIR INTERPRETATION FIVE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS COMES
OUT OF THE SURPLUS FOR THAT
PURPOSE. AND IT'S NOT THE WAY
WE INTERPRET IT ALTHOUGH WE
THINK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTERPRETATION IS CERTAINLY
REASONABLE. SECOND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION IN HIGHER-
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE EXPENSES
THAN WE HAVE. IN OUR- IN OUR
FISCAL OUTLOOK. AND THEN THIRD
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE- TRENDS IN
EXPENDITURES FOR THE STATE'S
MAJOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
PROGRAMS BASICALLY THE CASELOAD
DRIVEN PROGRAMS. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABOUT TWO
BILLION HIGHER THAN OUR OFFICES.
SO THOSE ARE THE MAIN. DRIVERS
OF THE DIFFERENCE THE FIGURE AT
THE BOTTOM OF THIS PAGE SHOWS
HOW WE SEE THE GOVERNOR
ALLOCATING THE WINDFALL. THE
DARK BARS ARE- BASICALLY THE
ALLOCATIONS TO ONE TIME
SPENDIG AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THOSE SOME TO- EIGHT POINT
ONE BILLION SO THEY MAKE UP A
LITTLE MORE THAN HALF OF THE
TOTAL- SURPLUS OR WINDFALL- HE
HAS ANOTHER TWO POINT NINE
BILLION WHICH THIS IS NOT
SHOWING ON YOUR SIDE BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
HERE'S ANOTHER TWO POINT NINE
BILLION GOING INTO THE STATE-
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE THE
SPECIAL PLAN FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION OF THE WINDFALL IS USED
FOR. REVENUE REDUCTIONS
ESSENTIALLY THE BOOK OF THAT IS
THE- TAX REFUNDS THAT WOULD GO
TO LOW INCOME TAXPAYERS IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY HAS ONE POINT
THREE BILLION FOR. ONGOING
SPENDING. AND ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL
DEBT AND LIABILITY PAYMENTS.
ABOVE WATER REQUIRED. IN THE
EXISTING LAW. OKAY SO THEN
MOVING TO THE NEXT PAGE I'LL
TALK ABOUT THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- PORTION OF THE
BUDGET. AND HERE DUE TO A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE THROUGH
ACROSS THE BUDGET WINDOW SO
FROM TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY. THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THIS INCREASE
IS SUCH THAT THE STATE HAS
NINETEEN POINT ONE BILLION
AVAILABLE FOR NEW SPENDING ON
K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION. THE WAY
THE GOVERNOR WOULD ALLOCATE
THIS. IS HE WOULD ALLOCATE
EIGHT POINT FOUR BILLION IN ONE
TIME SPENDING TO PAY DOWN
BALLOT. AND ONCE THAT IS DONE
THERE WOULD THERE WOULD STILL
BE ABOUT FOUR BILLION AND
DEFERRALS LEFT ON THE BOOKS
AND- THAT ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT
70% OF THE DIFFERENT OF THE
DEFERRALS THAT WERE ADOPTED IN
THE JUNE- TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
PLAN. THEN IN ADDITION THE
GOVERNOR IS REQUESTING- THE SIX
POINT SIX BILLION IN ONE TIME
GRANT FUNDING FOR FOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TWO BILLION OF THIS
WOULD BE FOR THE INCENTIVE.
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS TO RESUME
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. AND THEN
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION WOULD BE
FOR GRANTS TO PROVIDE AN
EXPANDED ACADEMIC- PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY GEARED FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED OR HIGHER NEED
STUDENTS IN THE STATE. THEN
LAST THERE'S- TWO POINT TWO
BILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING.
THIS WOULD COVER THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
OVERALL WE WOULD SAY THAT THIS
PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE IS.
REALLY REFLECTS A REASONABLE
MIX OF ONE TIME VERSUS ONGOING
SPENDING. YOU WOULD NOTE THAT
WITH THE EIGHT POINT FOUR
BILLION AND SIX POINT SIX
BILLION GOING TOWARD ONE TIME
PURPOSES IT'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT- EMPHASIS ON ONE
TIME WHICH WE THINK IS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE- THAT
PROVIDES A CUSHION FOR THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET GOING
FORWARD IN THE EVENT THERE IS.
VOLATILITY IN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE- ANY FUTURE
REDUCTIONS. WOULD BE LESS
LIKELY TO IMPACT SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. IF THEY'RE NOT BILL
TEN THROUGH NEW ONGOING
SPENDING. AND THEN JUST
SHIFTING TO PAGE THREE. ALL I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
DEVELOPED PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION
OF THE MOST RECENT FEDERAL
RELIEF PACKAGE. AND SO IN LIGHT
OF THIS WE OFFER TWO
OVERARCHING CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. THE FIRST IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
LIKELY WANT TO DETERMINE HOW TO
BEST ALLOCATE STATE RESOURCES
TO THOSE THAT ARE NOT RECEIVING
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. THE
RECEIVING FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
THEN YOU KNOW WE CAN- WE DON'T
WANT TO DUPLICATE THAT EFFORT
WHICH IS REALLY THE SECOND
POINT IS WELL WHICH IS THAT IN
GENERAL WE WILL. WE THINK THAT
YOU WOULD WANT TO EMPHASIZE
STATE INITIATIVE NAY SHOULD IS
THERE A COMPLEMENT RATHER THAN
A DUPLICATION OF THE FEDERAL
EFFORTS- WAIT NOTABLE ASPECT OF
THE PROPOSAL. IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOR NEARLY
THIRTEEN BILLION AND IMMEDIATE
AND FOR EARLY ACTION. RUBLE
I'LL START WITH THE IMMEDIATE
ACTION BY WHICH HE'S ASKING FOR
YOUR APPROVAL WITHIN THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS- THE FIRST SO WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT A
COUPLE OF THESE THE FIRST IS
THIS A PROPOSAL FOR- TWO
BILLION INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS TO. RESUME IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. OUR CONCERN REALLY
IS MORE WITH THE- THE BILITY OF
THE DISTRICT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE FUNDS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY THINK
THEY COULD YOU KNOW MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS IN A SHORT TIME
FRAME. AND I MEAN REALLY WHAT
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO DISSUADE DISTRICTS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONCERNED THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO MEET
THE- REQUIREMENTS SO. THAT IS
THE CONCERN WE HAVE WITH THAT.
AND THEN ON THE- TAX REFUNDS
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS-
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW IN THE
RECENT FEDERAL PACKAGE THERE
WAS- THE APPROVAL OF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR STIMULUS CHECKS
FOR MOST TAXPAYERS. BUT THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED
IN THAT AND SO- WE OFFER SOME
AS ONE ALTERNATIVE WEIGHT IDEAS
IN OUR REPORT. OR HOW THE STATE
MIGHT- BETTER TARGET THE USE OF
THIS TWO POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS TO- TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
NOT. BENEFICIARIES OF THAT
FEDERAL- PROGRAM. AND THEN WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
AND NONPROFITS ASSISTANCE
PROPOSALS AND OF THE VARIOUS
FEE WAIVERS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE
ACTUALLY WE GENERALLY THINK
THESE ARE WORTH CONSIDERING
THEY ARE GENERALLY REASONABLE-
PROPOSALS- THEN WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FRAMEWORK- WHEN IT COMES
TO THE SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN EARLY ACTION
PROPOSALS THIS IS A SLIGHTLY
LONGER TIME FRAME YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER TO CONSIDER
THESE PROPOSALS AND SO. IN
LIGHT OF THAT WHAT WE OFFER
HERE IS WE AS TO BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION REALLY. A
FRAMEWORK FOR HOW TO THINK
ABOUT THESE. I SPECIFICALLY
WERE SUGGESTING THAT YOU KNOW
ASK IS WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING- IS THERE
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OF A DIRECT
PANDEMIC RELATED PROBLEM THAT'S
ONE ONE QUESTION. SECOND IS THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF REALLY THAT
TIME SENSITIVE WORK IS ALL OF
THE FUNDING THAT IS BEING
REQUESTED TIME SENSITIVE MAYBE
PART OF IT COULD BE PROVIDED
IN. PART OF IT LATER. AND THEN
FINALLY IS THERE AT IN PLACE AT
THIS- FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE THE POTENTIAL FOR
SUCCESS OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PUTTING FOR. SO
THAT THAT FIRM HOW WE WOULD
SUGGEST- PROCEEDING ON THOSE.
AT THIS TIME AND THEN- JUST IN
GENERAL LEAVE AT THE CLOSING
THOUGHT ON- THIS SO THE
QUESTION OF BUDGET WAS. AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED- ALTHOUGH THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR HAS TURNED
OUT TO BE IN MUCH BETTER
PHYSICAL CONDITION THAN WE HAD
ANTICIPATED BEFORE THERE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL PRESSURES IN
THE OUT YEARS. AND UP BECAUSE
OF THAT WE THINK THAT YOU WILL
WANT TO CONSIDER- CONTINUE TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND THE GOVERNOR
MAKES AN IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS YOU KNOW TO THE
RAINY DAY FUND AS I SAID. AND
SOME OTHER ELEMENTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL BUT BECAUSE THERE IS
STILL THIS A PRETTY SIZEABLE-
OPERATING DEBT IN THE FUTURE
YEARS I THINK THIS IS JUST
GONNA BE SOMETHING YOU'LL WANT
TO CONSIDER- THROUGHOUT THE-
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS IF YOU
WEIGH THE- THE- VARIOUS
PROPOSALS FROM THE GOVERNOR. SO
YOU WITH THAT WE CAN- MOVED TO
QUESTION IF YOU HAVE AN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PETTIT GOING
TO GO TO MISTER. COOPER IN THE
MYSTERY. I THOUGHT OF ALL OF
MATURITY FIRST OF AS FOR BY DR
WE COMMON IN. IT IS THE- THAT
WRIST ONE POINT BILL. ON THE
FUTURE STATION IN THE SAN. AND
ONLY INTO SEVEN MIL ON GRAY FOR
SOME BUSINESS ACROSS THE- AND
IN BIGGEST IS YOU LOOK AT IT-
WITH ERP MONEY TO GONNA THIS. A
WE'VE BEEN A TON OF MY- OVER
THE YEARS. AND WHEN WE GOT MY
RIGHT. AND THE ONE QUESTION I
DO HAVE FOR FINE. THE
INCENTIVES OF THE FOR THE
PURCHASE OF MORE V. AND I MY
ISSUE IS REPEAT PEOPLE BY
VEHICLE LET YOU. THAT WE HAVE
IN THE- THREE IN THEIR CAR THAT
ARE HOME. THAT HAVE. NO PLACE
TO LIVE. MISLEADING CARS WATER
IS THAT WE YOU'RE PAYING FOR
MONTHLY IN THEIR CAR WE'RE SLIP
IN THE CAR BEING FORCED TO.
THEY WERE PAYING FOR LETTER
VEHICLES THAT THAT'S TOLD
INSANE. THE COST LIVE
CALIFORNIA'S FOR ALL. WILL
ERRORS OR VOTERS AND CAN. AND
IS THIS TOUGH RIGHT NOW NOW YOU
ASK. THE CLIMATE. RIGHT INCOME
CHANGE. YES THE AVERAGE PER.
WHAT OTHER ISSUES RIGHT NOW. A
PAIN THAT MAY. PAYING THAT RATE.
PENNY CHILLED BILL. PUT FOOD IN
THE- AND THIS IS THE CERVI
RIGHT NOW. NO ONE'S THINKING
ABOUT ALLEGED. SO IT UP THAT'S
UP THAT REALLY. CONCERN ME AND
A SOME WAY IT IS TELL DEAF
RIGHT NOW. TO THE CITIZENS OF
CAL- IT. HAS INDICATED MEMBERS
OF APPROVED. THAT PROMOTED BY
THE MINISTRY. MEDIA CHARGES TO
BY EIGHT TIME. WHAT WE HAVE.
JUST A SUPPORT FILE MILLION
ALLEGED. MUCH LESS THE FORTY
NEW NEED TO OUR TO POPULAR.
THINK ABOUT THE AVERAGE VEHICLE
AGE CAL. FORTY YEARS OLD. SO
HALF ALL THE CARS ARE FOURTEEN
OR OLDER. PEOPLE DIE HAVE
CARPET BECAUSE THE AFFORD
CARPET. THE DON'T WANT PAYMENT.
IN HERE WE ARE. GONNA FOR AND
EVEN ON THE NECK FORTY. E. V.
AS MORRIS. SO BOTH GOOD TO
THINK DOING THAT WHAT IS A
REALLY GOOD A IN THE END. OF
THIS YEAR FOR JANUARY FIRST
BECAUSE OF A PASS BY. A LOT OF
ARE A LOT OF FLEETS FOR LIKE
UPS OF. HAD TO GET OF THEIR
THEIR TRUCK BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
A LONG GETTING. PER CAR BROUGH.
BUT YEAH. THOSE TRUCK BE USED
ANYWHERE ELSE. IN THE- IN THE
WORLD. SO I GUESS MIKE IS THE
END. ON KELLER BUSINESS
INTERESTS BECAUSE WE'RE PAYING.
BECAUSE OF THAT. IT'S CRAZY USE
IT. BUT IT CAN BE USED IN THE
ELSE. AND ALSO ARE BEING
SHIPPED RIGHT NOT A- CAN BE
DRIVEN. THERE TO BE SHIPPED.
OTHER CHARGING IT WAS STRUCK
ALSO AN ISSUE- IF IT HAD IS.
THIS YOUR VEHICLE FLEE. AND
COST TENS BILLIONS OF- WE DON'T
A PLAN FOR. ALL THE LETTER J.
REYES THAT WOULD BE NEEDED. TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO- THE L.
A. O. CAN. SPENT TAX SPENT MORE
THAN SEVEN. DURING THE PASS
DECADE. TO PROMOTE THEMSELVES
MILLION. DESPITE THAT WE ONLY
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND REALLY HAVE A MILLION.
THERE WAS ON THE ROAD. THAT
MAKES NO SENSE AND WHEN YOU
REALLY DRILL DOWN TO IT- CVR P.
CASSIDY READ PROGRAM IS THAT IF
FOR OVER TWO YEARS. IF YOU LOOK
AT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE
YOU'RE- PLEASE PROBLEM IS THE
WORST BECAUSE THE- NOT TRAP IT.
THEY'VE GOT THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
REBATES WHERE IS THE WELL
COMMUNITIES ON THE CALL
COMMUNITIES IN BAY AREA HAS
GOTTEN MAJORITY OF THE EV'S THE
REBATES FREEBIES AND WHAT TO
GET IT SO YOU CAN DRIVE THE CAR
PULLING. SO YOU CAN DRIVE THE
CAR PULLING A FEW YEARS AGO WE
PASSED A BILL TO GIVE MORE
STICKERS. FOR FOLKS TO DRIVING
A CAR PULLING WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THE WORKING FAMILIES THE
DOWNTRODDEN. WE'RE **** THEM.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY **** ON NO IF
ANDS OR BUTS ABOUT IT AND JUST
A LOVELY THIS ONE LAST THING
HOPEFULLY FINANCE CONSUMER
QUESTION. WHAT ARE THE
INCENTIVES MEAN WHAT IT INCLUDE-
SWEEPING YOUR CAR AGAIN PAID TO
BUY A CAR. WHO CAN STAND UP AND
JUSTIFY THAT I KNOW I CAN'T.
THANK YOU MR GRUBER- LET ME
JUST SAY THAT ONE REASON THAT
THE PACKAGES IN HERE IS TO
ADDRESS AN IMMEDIATE ISSUE AS I
SAID EARLIER- AN UNDERLYING
THEME OF THE BUDGET IS REALLY
JOB CREATION AND THAT THE
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR
SECURED OF. SECURITIZATION IS
TO CONSTRUCT- YOU STATION. A
NEW FUELING STATIONS SO THAT'S
JUST THAT'S A PARTICULAR REASON
FOR THAT ONE AND ALSO- A
PORTION OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
ASKED FOR THROUGH EARLY ACTION-
IN REGARDS TO THE SUBSIDIES-
FOR UNDER SIXTY FIVE MILLION OF
THAT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
PACKAGE IS GOING TO. PLUS UP OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO GET MORE
PEOPLE- INTO CLEANER VEHICLES
AND- AGREED THAT THERE ARE
THERE ARE MANY THINGS- THAT WE
COULD BE FUNDING A LOT OF. VERY
GOOD THINGS THAT COULD BE
FUNDING AND THIS IS ONE PART OF
THE PLAN TO GET MORE JOBS MORE
PEOPLE ON THE JOB- DURING THE
KANEMI AND I'VE OF WILL PASS.
IT OVER TO- MY COLLEAGUES AT
FINE THEY HAVE ELSE ADD. JUST
WILL BE MISTRESS CONSIDERS-
RIGHT NOW NOT. ON THE TOP LIST.
FIRST FOR CITIZENS THAT PERSON
THAT IS NOT A THERE TALKING FOR
MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE MORE
REBATES. IT'S REALLY ABOUT
SERVICE JUST MAKE IT THROUGH
THIS HOPE TO HAVE A JOB IN A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD. SO I MEAN
IT IS- DISTRICT OR HIS TONE.
BECAUSE SO MANY IN THE HOMELESS
IS OFFICE. AND ENJOY DOWNTOWN I
PEOPLE SLEEPING IN A CARS. A I
JUST I CAN'T JUSTIFY. PAYING
FOR SOMEONE TO INTO THE V.
SIGNAL THE CAR PULLING OUT OKAY
SILVA ADMINISTRATION LOOK AT
SOMEBODY'S WE CAN AND CHANGE
PRIORITY. AND ALL ALL- TO THAT
WE HAVE ONE FOR SEVEN FIVE
BILLION IN THIS BY- AND THAT IS
TO GO TOWARD- WHAT WE WOULD
CALL FAN OF HOME. SO GETTING
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS OR ON
THE VERGE OF HOMELESS INTO-
INTO HOUSE SO IN IN RESPONSE TO
SOME OF YOUR WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW WHAT'S ALSO IN IN THE GO
BUDGET IN ORDER FOR THE BILL
THAT A QUESTION ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS WE'VE PUT-
OBVIOUSLY BUILDINGS DOLLARS. TO
ARE HOMELESS EFFORT- A WE SEE
AN INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS THE
STREETS AND A BIG OF OUR BACK
TO IS MENTAL ILLNESS AND.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IF YOU HAVE A
JOB AND HAVE AG THE HOUSE. IT
HARD AS HELL TO OFF DRAW. OR
DEAL WITH ILL. AND OVER JUST
GOT IMPROVING HERE SO. ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. WHAT
IS THAT MEAN WHEN YOU GO APRIL.
HEALTH NEEDS WHAT WHAT IS THAT
DO SPECIFIC. TO HELP SOMEONE
ELSE. ILL. YES THANK YOU YEAH
SO OF A PART OF THE OF THE
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE THAT. NOT
ERICA WAS JUST DISCUSSING-
WE'VE PROPOSED SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE
TIME CHEN I DON'T FUND.
AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEAR
PERIOD- FOR DH CS TO ACQUIRE OR
REHABILITATE FACILITIES THAT
CAN BE USED. FOR LIKE SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL AND OTHER
SORTS OF- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
SERVICES WE BE WORKING WITH THE
COUNT ME AS ON THE S. WE INVEST.
IN THERE'D BE A MATCHING
INTENDED COUNTIES THE BOND IN A
LONG RUN- BUTTHE CONCEPT BEING
THAT- THIS FACILITY OPPOSITION
TO HAVE MORE SERVE BY THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND I'D ALSO LIKE
THAT- THE- THE EFFORT IS KIND
OF- I. COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
CALENDAR SHOULD HAVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PATIENTS. OR
PROPOSING AGAIN AND IN
PARTICULAR. A SERIOUS OPEN
SLEEPER. OF THE COMPANY IDEAS
TO TRY HELP- MORE IN THE-
COMMUNITY AND MORE. AND MARK
EFFECTIVE SINCE- IS ABLE FOR TO
WORKING WITH. LITTLE SETTLEMENT
PROCESS. YOU WILL HAVE BALCONY
HERE AND I GUESS MY CONCERN
WITH THIS ALL IS- YOU KNOW A
OPPORTUNITY IN FROM IN KEPT FOR
ALL CLOSELY WITH IT'S COLD AS
HELL SEKHEMRE RIGHT NOW IT IS
DURING THE WINTER SOLANO FOLKS
ARE OUT THERE AND YOU KNOW THE
BAREFOOT THERE YOU HAVE IT MUCH
CLOTHING AND YOU KNOW I'VE
NEVER HEARD ANYONE FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION. PARTICIPATION
TALK ABOUT. A POSSIBLE CONCERN
FOR SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE- THEIR LIFE IS A BET ON
THE STREET- BETTER GETTING
THREE MEALS A DAY AND HAVE A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD. AND HAVE
ADEQUATE MEDICAL CARE. AND
HOPEFULLY GETTING OFF THAT AT
SOME POINT. AND I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO DO THAT TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT BUT NO ONE EVER
TALKS ABOUT THAT. BECAUSE THE
FUNDING IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
THAT THIS IS ONE TIME MONEY TO
TRY AND PUT HIM IN HOUSING. BUT
YET A LOT IS FULL TO TURN IT
DOWN IF YOU LOOK ON IN TALKING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT HERE. THEY
DON'T ACCEPT HOUSING BECAUSE OF
ADDICTION PROBLEMS AND IT'S
HARD AS HELL TO BEAT ADDICTION.
WRITTEN DRUGS ALCOHOL VERY
ADDICTIVE AND ALSO THE MENTAL
HEALTH PORTION SO. TO ME WHAT
WE'RE TACKLING IT BUT NOT AT
FOR IS A- HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
IT SO AT SOME POINT WE'VE GOT
TO CHANGE THAT BECAUSE- WE PUT.
A COUPLE OF BILLION DOLLARS
ACTUALLY MORE THAN THAT. THE
PAST THREE OR FOUR YEARS. AND
IT HASN'T PUT A DENT IN THE
PROBLEM SO I WOULD HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE A-
DEEPER DIVE INTO THAT REALLY
CONCENTRATE ON THAT. AND WE'LL
TALK ABOUT SOME THESE PEOPLE-
NEED THE HELP AND THEY CAN'T
HELP. THEMSELVES WE'RE GOING TO
HELP THEM AT SOME POINT. THANK
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
MISTRUST. SHARE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR. I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY APPLAUDING THE
GOVERNOR TACKLING SOME OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES OUR STATE IS
FACING NOW LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR ADMINISTRATION
WE HAVE OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
ALSO TO THEY'LL DEVELOP A FINAL
BUDGET THE RESPONSE TO THE
DEVASTATION THAT HAS HIT SO
MANY COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE DO TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
AND THIS PANDEMIC. AS WE MOVE.
TO VOTE ON EARLY ACTION ITEMS
AND PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WE MUST DO SO THROUGH
THE LENS OF INCLUSION AND
EQUITY. THIS BUDGET RELIES ON
THE RESILIENT NATURE OF
CALIFORNIANS BUT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE DEVIL IS IN THE
DETAILS. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS PROTECTED
ENOUGH LIFTED IN TIMES OF
CRISIS. GIVEN THAT THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PROGRAM LOOKS
BANDIT TO THOSE ELIGIBLE FOR
KELLY I. T. C. INCLUDING OUR
AYE TEMPLE OF FILERS WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THAT VITAL DETAIL
IS NOT REMOVED FROM THE FINAL
BUDGET. THIS BUDGET RECOGNIZES
THE IMPACT OF THE BAND THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THEREFORE WE MUST
CONTINUE TO FIND PATHWAYS FOR
GRANTS LOAN PROGRAMS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO NOT
ONLY A SISTER SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE RECOVERY BUT ALSO TO GET
OUR PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN CLEAN
AIR AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. NOT ONLY
REFLECT THE PRIORITIES OF A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS BUT IT
ALSO PROVIDES ANOTHER AVENUE
FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. INLAND
THEIR LIVES INLAND AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH AS MY DISTRICT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY EMISSIONS AND PARTICULATE
MATTER FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WILL
NEVER GO AWAY UNLESS WE MAKE
BOLD INVESTMENTS IN THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. THE
PROPOSED INCREASES TO ARBS AND
SEE SEIZE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS SEND A SIGNAL TO
POLLUTION POLLUTION RIDDEN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SUCH AS
THE ONES IN MY DISTRICT. THAT
THE DEBT THAT THE STATE IS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING CLEAN
AIR FOR ALL. I'M ESPECIALLY
INTERESTED IN TO SEE THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION OF THE
CECE'S CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AS WELL. THE NEW
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
OPENS UP AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED CHILD CARE
SERVICE LOTS. HISTORICALLY
THERE HAVE BEEN ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ON WAITING
LISTS FOR THE SLOTS. WELL ANY
NEW FUNDING IS WELCOME AND WE
WILL MAKE UP AND WILL MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF FAMILIES THE BENEFIT
WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN STILL ON THE
WAITING LIST. FOR THIS CHILD
CARE. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PROTECT HOUSING POLICIES AS
WELL AS ENSURE OUR EDUCATION
EFFORTS. THE GIVE OUR CHILDREN
THE ADEQUATE RESOURCES NEEDED
TO SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE
INTO OUR CLASSROOMS. AMONG
OTHER EFFORTS. AT THE FOREFRONT
HOWEVER IS THE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE VACCINE I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY THIS
PANDEMIC IS BEHIND US ALL BUT
FOR NOW. MEMBERS WE MUST WORK
TOGETHER TO BRING AN END TO
THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WHILE
PROTECTING ALL CALIFORNIANS WE
NEED TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
WE TO HELP OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
MONEY TO HELP OUR STUDENTS WITH
THEIR EDUCATION. THANK YOU. IF
YOU WERE GONNA GO TO MR
GALLAGHER AND THEN THIS RIVAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
IS IMPORTANT WORK THEY WERE
DOING HERE AND ESPECIALLY WITH
THESE EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS I
THINK THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
REALLY NEED TO TAKE SOME URGENT
ACTION TO LOOK AT THESE AND
REALLY TO MAKE THEM BETTER
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A LOT.
THERE'S A LOT WANTING HERE IN
TERMS OF GETTING SPECIFIC
TARGETED. APPROACHES TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT MOST- I THINK THE
L. A. O. MADE A VERY GREAT
POINT AND THAT. MANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE NOT TARGETED IN
THE WAY THEY SHOULD BE A NEED
TO BE MUCH MORE FOCUSED- I DO
WANT TO START OFF IS LESS
ANYONE SAID DON'T. GIVE ANY
COMPLIMENTS TO THE GOVERNOR I
DO APPRECIATE. IN THIS BUDGET
THAT THERE IS MONEY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES I THINK THE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS. AS THE L. L. L. A.
O. SAID IS VERY MUCH WORTH
CONSIDERING THE FEE WAIVERS. I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY DO WITH MANY OF
THESE BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING. TO HOP HAVE HAVE
THEM BE FORCED TO PAY FEES WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN CLOSED DOWN- SEEMS
PRETTY UNFAIR TO ME AND IT'S
ONLY JUST. I THINK THAT WE DO.
THOSE THINGS. ARE LET ME SAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- I WILL AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES. EARLIER
BOTH- MAKE. MY COLD CALLING
FROM HEALDSBURG IN MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM NOW GROVE. WHO
POINTED OUT THAT THIS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION- FOR ELECTRIC
CHARGING STATIONS. COULD VERY
MUCH BE SPENT IN OTHER PLACES
THEY'RE MUCH MORE PRIORITY- BUT
LET ME ALSO ADD TO THAT- THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS BUDGET IS
SAYING THAT THAT. IS CONSISTENT
WITH A POLICY. THAT HAS BEEN
SET. THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS A
POLICY THAT WAS NOT SET BY THIS
BODY. BUT A POLICY SET BY THE
GOVERNOR THROUGH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER. WE DID NOT ESTABLISH
THAT POLICY AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY. HE IS FUNDING A POLICY
THAT HE HIMSELF ESTABLISHED
THAT'S A PROBLEM. THAT WE ARE
THE LEGISLATURE WE YES WE
ESTABLISH THE POLICY. AND WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE GOING I THINK
IT'S ALREADY BEEN OUTLINED VERY
CLEARLY BY MY COLLEAGUES- THIS
IS THE WRONG PLACE. TO SPEND
THAT MONEY ESPECIALLY WITH
EARLY ACTION MONEY WHERE- WE
NEED TO GET THIS TO THE THOSE
IN MOST NEED- THE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION OF FEDERAL MONEY. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE NOT REAL CLEAR WHERE
THAT'S GOING BUT WE'RE WE'RE
FOCUSING MODE IS LOOKS LIKE A
FOCUS NOT ON RENTERS AND SMALL
LANDLORDS SMALL LANDLORDS NEED
THIS MONEY THE MOST. THEY'RE
THE ONES THEY'VE GOT NOTHING.
SO FAR WE PASSED THE ADDICTION
MORE TWENTY BUT WE DID VERY
LITTLE. TO HELP THE SMALL
LANDLORDS WHO HAVE BEEN GOING
WITHOUT RENT PAYMENTS. MANY ARE
VERY STE ARE STRUGGLING THEY'RE
GOING THEIR MORTGAGES ARE ARE
COMING DUE. OR OR EVEN BEING
FORECLOSED UPON. SO I THINK WE
SHOULD TARGET THAT MONEY MUCH
MORE CLOSELY A SMALL LANDLORDS
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM HAS
HELPED RUNNERS BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T HAD TO PAY RENT. OR
LEASE ONLY A PORTION OF RENT.
SO I THINK WE SHOULD BE REALLY
TARGETED AT TOWARDS THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN MOST HURT BY THIS BY
THAT POLICY OR AT LEAST LEDGE
LET'S SEE THE RESEARCH- LET'S
SEE THE EVIDENCE OF WHERE THAT
MONEY COULD BE. BETTER SPENT
BUT THEN YOU PUT ON TOP OF THAT
WERE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT
DOING ANOTHER TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION. IN A NIGHT THE ITC
REFUND. NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THAT MIGHT NOT BE A GOOD POLICY
TO FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE
LOWEST INCOME BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IS GOING TO
THOSE WHO HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
AFFECTED OR THE OUT OF WORK.
ARE THEY CURRENTLY OUT OF WORK
ET DE. IS WERE OUR BIGGEST
FOCUS NEEDS TO BE. BUT IN THIS
BUDGET. WE ONLY GOT FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION. TO
PAY INTEREST ON UNITY LOANS US
THAT'S ALL OF THE GOVERNOR
THOUGHT WAS IMPORTANT- WITH
REGARD EDIE HOW ABOUT I KNOW
HOW BOUT AN OVERHAUL. AND
MAKING SURE THE ACTUAL PAYMENTS
ARE GETTING OUT TO THOSE WHO
ARE OUT OF WORK RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHERE WE COME INTO THE
PICTURE. HE'S LEAVING THIS YOU
KNOW TOTALLY BROAD TOLD GRAY
AREA WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THIS
MONEY IS GETTING TO THOSE. WHO
NEED IT MOST VACCINES THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THIS PROPOSED BUDGET TO GET
THE VACCINE OUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE. FOR US RIGHT
NOW IS MAKING SURE THAT WE GET
HERD IMMUNITY THROUGH A VACCINE
WE'RE ONLY PUTTING THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION INTO IT
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW.
THE VACCINES THAT HAVE BEEN
GETTING OUT ARE NOT GIVEN THE
ARMS BECAUSE GETTING CAUGHT UP
IN THIS BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS.
AND WE'RE NOT GETTING TO THAT
NEXT PHASE NEXT PHASES TEACHERS
ONE B. WE SHOULD BE GETTING
THAT VACCINE OUT TO TEACHERS
AND STAFF RIGHT NOW SO THAT WE
CAN OPEN UP SCHOOLS. BUT THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING THAT'S WHERE I
THINK WE CAN DO SOME REAL WORK
OF PUSHING THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
HAVE EARLY PROPOSALS. TO GET
THE MOST GOOD LET'S GET IT OUT
TO WHERE IT'S NEEDED THE MOST
WE ALSO WANT TO GET OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN WITH THE BIGGEST THING WE
CAN DO TO GET OUR SCHOOLS OPEN.
IS TO GET OUR TEACHERS. AND
SUPPORT STAFF VACCINATED. SO
THEY CAN OPEN UP SAFELY. AND
THEN I AM WITH EDUCATION- YOU
KNOW THIS PROPOSAL ON A AND I'M
HEARING FROM BOTH LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THIS INCENTIVE GRANT
PROPOSAL IS TO BURDENS AND
EVERYBODY IS SAYING THEY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MEET ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS- THAT ARE BEING
LAID OUT IN HERE. SO YOU GET-
YEAH WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU THIS
EXTRA MONEY BUT NOBODY CAN
ACTUALLY MEET THE CRITERION THE
REQUIREMENTS TO REOPEN THEIR
SCHOOLS AND TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF
THIS ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE
PAYMENT AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE
WE'RE GOING BACK TO CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS. I THOUGHT WE DID AWAY
WITH THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY SCHOOL. IS GETTING
SUPPORT SO THEY CAN STAY OPEN-
SO THERE'S SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WITH HOW THAT IS LAID
OUT AND IF. AGAIN IF THAT'S
GOING TO BE AN EARLY ACTION
PROPOSAL THEN WE SHOULD GET ON
IT RIGHT NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S- ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP.
OUR SCHOOLS GET REOPENED IF
IT'S JUST GOING TO BE OF AN
OBSTACLE THAT NOBODY CAN MEET.
THAT'S NOT HELPING US. DO THE
JOB. UP ONE ONE. HOUR AFTER THE
END OF THE MOST IMPORTANT WILD
FIRES. I WILL GIVE THE GOVERNOR
AGAIN VERY MUCH CREDIT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS IN THIS
BUDGET. OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT THIS THAT IS A
POLICY THAT WE ESTABLISHED.
THANKFULLY WITH- SB NINE A ONE.
HE'S GIVEN US AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE MILLION I THINK THAT'S
GOOD BUT IS IT CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION. IT'S NOT CLEAR
RIGHT NOW IF IT'S NOT
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION HOW
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT'S A REAL
COMMITMENT. AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
FRONT LOADING THAT. THESE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THAT
WERE FACING THEY NEED ATTENTION
NOW. WE NEED TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
OUR CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS GOING
INTO. FORESTRY MANAGEMENT WHICH
REDUCES CARBON. IN WHICH HELPS
BETTER THAN ANYTHING ELSE BY
REDUCING THE FUELS HELPS REDUCE
THESE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
A PLAGUE MY COMMUNITY AND MANY
OF YEARS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WHETHER YOU'VE HAD YOUR
COMMUNITIES BURNED DOWN OR
YOU'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
SMOKE. WE NEED TO GET ON TOP OF
THIS WE NEED TO GET ON TOP OF
THE FUEL ISSUE AND I WOULD SAY
LET'S FRONT LOAD THAT MONEY.
AND GET EVEN MORE BANG OUT OF
OUR BOX. BEGAN TO OUR FORCE IN
REDUCING CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
AND REDUCING CARBON. WE CAN DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS IS THAT
THIS IS THE BEST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK. IN TERMS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICY. SO JUST TO
REALLY WORK ON ALL THESE ITEMS.
PRECIADO TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND I HAVE MY WILL. AND THANK
YOU MR GALLAGHER WE'RE GONNA GO
TO MISS RIVERS CENTER MYSTERONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT
TO START OFF BY ON SOME
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSED
FUNDING ON HOMELESSNESS AND
THEN I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ON
THE SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
PROPOSAL- I'M WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET ON HOMELESSNESS
I WANTED TO BRING UP SOMETHING
FOR CONSIDERATION AS WE GO INTO
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. I THINK THE REASON THAT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS NOT
ADEQUATE IS BECAUSE IT'S ONE
TIME- FUNDING AND THE ONE TIME
FUNDING OF NATURE OF THESE
PROPOSALS RESTRICTS OUR STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS IT
DOESN'T ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND OTHER
PROVIDERS TO PLAN FOR MULTIPLE
YEARS WHICH IS WHAT WE REALLY
NEED- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT NEW ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS OUT. OF WILL
NOT ADVANCE GREATER
COORDINATION OR ADVANCED
LEADERSHIP AROUND HOMELESSNESS
I'M IN FACT IT'S CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS THAT MULTIPLE AGENCIES
AND NO WAY TO COORDINATE THESE
THESE AGENCIES RESPONSES- ONE
TIME FUNDING MEANS THAT THE
MONEY CANNOT BE USED FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS. THERE'S NO
FUNDING FOR SERVICES ANY
HOUSING BASED SERVICES BUT AS
WE ALL KNOW AND HAVE SEEN IN
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES ARE VITAL
TO END HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA- IF WE CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS THAT. WILL POTENTIALLY
ONLY LIVE FOR ONE YEAR. ESPITE
OF WHAT WE KNOW. THAT THERE
WILL BE INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. AND I
REALLY THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON AS YOU REMEMBER LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF
THE STATE FOCUSED ON
HOMELESSNESS. AND WE MUST NOT
FORGET THAT THAT IS STILL AN
ISSUE AND EXACERBATED. BY COVE
IT. AB DE I HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THE SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL. OF
PRO PRO. I WAS CURIOUS IF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE THE- LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT. IN
OUR STATE ABOUT THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY RECENTLY EXPRESSED IN
THE STATEMENTS. AND I'M I'M
GONNA POP THE QUESTION ON TOO
DIFFICULT HOME. THANK YOU. OKAY
HI JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE HAVE READ- THE
SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT'S LETTER- AND WE
HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT YES TO-
THE SUPERINTENDENTS AS WELL AS
THEIR STAFF TO GET BETTER
CLARIFICATION ON- ON WHAT THEY
ARE IDENTIFYING AS BARRIERS.
BECAUSE I'M FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THEY WERE NOT- NO
ONE CONNECTED WITH THEM BEFORE
THIS PROPOSAL WITHOUT I'M VERY
CONCERNED- ABOUT LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ABILITY TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE SAFE SCHOOL
FOR ALL PROPOSAL I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT EQUITY. OF ESPECIALLY IN
LOS ANGELES WHERE THE MAJORITY
OF STUDENTS THAT ATTEND LA
SCHOOLS ARE LOW INCOME- AND
UNDER REPRESENTED IN OUR STATE.
A. N. AND SO I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT BEING
ABLE TO MEET. THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. YES A ONE THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
REACHED OUT TO OTHER
SUPERINTENDENTS AND THEIR STAFF
ON IS THE- THE ASSERTION THAT-
THEY WERE NOT AT. WE DIDN'T
SEEK OUT THERE- AS- INPUT PRIOR
TO CREATING THIS- PROPOSAL
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY DID
RECENTLY DID REACH OUT TO NOT
JUST THE SEVEN SUPERINTENDENTS
THAT WERE ON THE LIST BUT TO
MANY OTHERS AS WELL- SO THAT
WAS A LITTLE BIT SURPRISING-
HOWEVER AND WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT. LIKE L. A. U. S. T. MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FACING
EQUITY ISSUES. AND JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE PROPOSAL
DOES ALLOW FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHO ARE IN COUNTIES. THAT HAVE
HI AND TRY RATES OF CODE NINE.
AND ALLOW THEM TO PART- EVEN IF
THEY ARE BY- THE TWENTY EIGHT
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND RATE- THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO KEEP THEM FROM
REOPENING. I'M SO THOSE FUNDS
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE STUDENTS I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE FUNDS
ARE GENERATED BY ALL EDA BUT
MUST BE SPENT. ONLY ON THOSE OF
PEOPLES WHO ARE RECEIVING
INSTRUCTION IN PERSON AND THOSE
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON HOMELESS
YOUTH FOSTER YOUTH STUDENTS
DISABILITIES AND THE YOUNGEST
CHILDREN IN THE STATE. I'M SO
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF EQUITY
BUILT IN IN THOSE WAYS. WELL I
HOPE THAT. WELL I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONSULT WITH THE SCHOOL
LARGE SCHOOL SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
ON A REVISED PLAN THANK YOU.
YEAH CAN WE ARE LOOK WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DELIBERATE HERE IF
THE PUBLIC COULD. PLEASE THEIR
CAR KEEP THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEMSELVES.
OKAY THANK THANK
YOU MISS REAVIS WAS YOUR WE ARE.
YOU DON'T. THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO A MYSTERON MOST
MYSTICAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THANK YOU TO THE
GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FOR PUTTING ON THIS- BUDGET IN
FRONT OF US IN IDENTIFYING
SURPLUSES THAT ARE THERE. BUT
WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD ALL
BE COMFORTABLE I KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT. AND I THINK IN OTHER
DISTRICTS TO WORK IN A LOT OF
CALLS RECENTLY FROM ET DE. R.
ET DE IN THE BACKLOG THAT IT
CONTINUES TO HAVE. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT JUST HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS IT'S
BEEN GOING ON GOING SO I LIKE
TO SEE WHAT HAS BEEN PUT INTO
THAT AREA TO START TO- FREE UP
THAT BACKLOG. THAT IS THERE-
ALSO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BUSINESSES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
A GREAT THAT WE'RE IDENTIFYING
FUNDING AND GRANTS THAT ARE
GOING OUT THERE. BUT I HAVE TO
ASK WHAT MATRIX IS BEING USED
TO IDENTIFY THE TRUE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE HAVING THE GREATEST
IMPACT. I KNOW IN MY DISTRICT
THE HOSPITALITY ASPECT THE
RESTAURANTS A SMALL MOM AND POP
SHOPS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
GETTING. GREATER IMPACTS SO ARE
WE GONNA HAVE SOME TYPEOF
MATRIX THAT IDENTIFIES THOSE
THAT WITH THE GREATEST IMPACT.
THEY'RE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
AND RECEIVE THE GRANTS ON THEIR
ADEQUATELY COVERING THOSE AREAS
AND I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT ALSO
IN MY DISTRICT. ARE THOSE THAT
ARE IN THAT HOSPITALITY AREA
ARE THOSE AGAIN THAT WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE E. I. T. C.
INCOME THAT'S THERE SO WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT. AS
FAR AS WHAT BUSINESSES ARE
HAVING THE GREATEST IMPACT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR FUNDING-
REACHES THOSE THAT ARE
CERTAINLY GETTING THAT NONSTOP
ON THOSE. TWO QUESTIONS BUT I
HAVE A FEW MORE MISTER CHAIR.
SURE I IN REGARDS TO THE EDT
BACKLOG- AND OBVIOUSLY THEY
WERE INUNDATED WITH THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS EARLY ON AND THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IT. GETTING
GETTING RID OF THAT BACKLOG BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE EXIST A
BACKLOG ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE DONE IS TO
REDIRECT SOME OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES. TO WORK ON YOU WHY
THEY HAVE ALSO HIRED NEW
EMPLOYEES- THEY HAVE EXTENDED
THEIR HOURS FOR CALL CENTERS
EXTENDED THEIR- DAYS AS WELL-
TO JUST GET MANPOWER UP THERE
THIS IS SOME OF THAT IS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME. OF NOT
A SATISFYING ANSWER IF YOU'RE
WAITING AND IF YOU'RE IN THAT
COHORT BUT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT THAT THEY ARE ATTEMPTING
TO DO TO ADDRESS THE MASSIVE
BACKLOG THAT THEY HAVE- IN
REGARDS TO- BUSINESSES I WOULD
SAY THAT THE FEE RELIEF IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD
PARTICULARLY- CRAFTED AROUND-
GIVING SOME OF THE BUSINESSES.
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED-
SOME SOME RELIEF AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE- RESTAURANTS AND BARS
AS WELL AS- LICENSEES UNDER-
BARBARA BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY
SAID. TO BE- TO INTO IN
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION I
THINK THAT PROPOSAL IS IN
PARTICULARLY VERY TARGETED ON
THE BUSINESS GRANT ALSO WILL
BE- APPLICATIONS WILL BE COMING
IN AND WILL BE- LOOKED AT BASED
ON NEED AND IMPACT- IN REGARDS
TO- KOBE AS WELL. SO I CAN GET
YOU SOME MORE DETAILS IN
REGARDS TO THE- FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IF THAT'S
THE- THE QUESTION IN PARTICULAR
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT BUT YES WE
ARE. TRYING TO TARGET ANTI- MY
OF THOSE THIS THAT HAVE THE
MOST AND. WITH THE AND REALLY
IT'S THE AT THE LOOK LEVEL IT'S
A SALES REVENUE THIS GUY CHEN
THE GENERAL. AT THE LAW LEVEL.
SO IF WE START. HAVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING. IS BEING. SO
THOSE. IN WE CAN REACH OUT TO
OUR- AREAS TO DARKEN. THAT ARE
HAVING TO GO IN. TO START THAT
RICK. TO HAPPEN IN THE AREAS
THAT WE DRASTICALLY NEED. UP
NEXT I LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
SCHOOLS NOTHING. THANK YOU FOR
IDENTIFYING THE SCHOOLS IN THE
NEEDS THAT ARE THERE- BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT. DURING THIS
TIME IT'S NOT JUST THE ADULTS
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH SEVERE.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IT'S OUR
STUDENTS THAT ALSO CONTINUE TO
GO THROUGH. MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES DEPRESSION ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS. THAT WE'VE
SEEN- UNSEEN HAPPENED PLAY OUT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
IN THE DISTRICT OF THE ASSEMBLY
FORTIETH. IN UP AND SO WHAT
RESOURCES ARE THERE FOR THAT
MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT. BUT
ALSO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOMELESS YOU. THE HOMELESS
YOUTH POPULATION ASSEMBLY NO
COUNTY WAS OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND- STUDENTS PRIOR TO
COALBED NINETEEN NOW WE HAVE TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT HAS
INCREASED. BUT YET WHAT
RESOURCES ARE WE GIVING THEIR
FOR THE HOMELESS YOU. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DURING THIS
TIME AND FOR THOSE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT ARE THERE.
THAT MANY TIMES MANY TIMES
DRIVES IT YOUNG INDIVIDUAL TO
START TO CONTEMPLATE. LIFE OR
OR DEATH ON THOSE ISSUES AND
IT'S  MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GET AWAY
FROM THAT STIGMA. AND REALLY
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY NEED
THE RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEM. SO IN THE
MONEY THAT'S MOVING FORWARD IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THERE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES. TO
THOSE THAT ARE GREATLY IMPACTED
BY. YES YOU FOR THAT. AND I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE- FOR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
PROPOSAL MATH HEALTH- FOR
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR. AND THE
DAHLE GET THE- FUNDING AND THE
PROPOSAL WILL EVENTUALLY HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. WORKING WITH LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OFFICES. AND
SCHOOLS TO CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
SO THAT. CHILDREN WHO ARE
HAVING ISSUES CAN BE IDENTIFIED
AT SCHOOL AND THEN THEY CAN-
RECEIVE PREVENTATIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTIONS WHICH ARE VERY
IMPORTANT. AND- IF ANYTHING
THAT BUDGET- DOES HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE IMPACT. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON THE
STUDENTS HAVE HAD BOTH IN
SCHOOL- INSTRUCTION SCHOOL
INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS IN
MENTAL HEALTH. SO AT BACK TO
THE ONE ONE- LARGE PROPOSAL I
WOULD POINT OUT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH FOR STUDENTS. THE THIRTY
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE WERE
SO. IN GETTING ON OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION SIGNED INTO
LAW BUT WE HAVE TO MAKESURE
THAT WHEN WE START TO TOPPLE
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES LIKE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW AND
DOLLARS GOING BACK INTO THE
SCHOOLS. THAT WE START TO
UTILIZE THAT COMPONENT THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
MOVING FORWARD. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT IT IN THE IN THE ECONOMY
AND RECOVERY THAT IS NOT JUST
DOLLARS AND CENTS THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THE MENTAL HALTH
COMPONENT. OF ALL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS AT THE
FOREFRONT- JUST- ONE MORE
QUESTION- MISTER CHAIR. IN THIS
DEALS WITH THE VACCINATIONS AND
THE DISBURSEMENT OF THE
VACCINATIONS THAT ARE IS COMING
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
KNOW THAT THE- THE DELIVERY AND
WE SEE IT- MOVIE FORWARD MANY
TIMES ON MY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES. I SEE FIRSTHAND
READING ABOUT IT IN THE PAPER
OR DIFFERENT THINGS ABOUT THE
NUMBERS OF VACCINES MOVING
FORWARD. BUT STILL- WHEN I ASK
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND OUR
SENIOR POPULATION ARE CALLING
MY OFFICE TO FIND OUT WHERE CAN
THEY GO TO GET THIS
VACCINATION. IS NOW THE MONEY
IS BEING PUT INTO THE
VACCINATION THE DISBURSEMENT IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
OVERSEEN BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WILL TRICKLE DOWN TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. TO
DEVELOP A PLAN FOR DISBURSEMENT
WHAT IS THAT RESPONSIBILITY LIE
SO WE'RE CLEAR ON RESPONDING TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. SURE AND IT
HAS THE GOVERNOR HIGHLIGHTED ON
FRIDAY ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ISN'T IN RECEIPT OF
THE VACCINES- THEY ARE GOING TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WE ARE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH A LOCAL HOME
OFFICES AND- LOCAL PROVIDERS-
AND THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE.
ULTIMATELY PROVIDING THOSE
VACCINES- I WOULD SAY THAT THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET- THE OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILLION. IS AN ESTIMATE
IS BASED ON- THE THOUGHT OF YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED AT THE TIME FOR
VACCINATION DISTRIBUTION-
HOWEVER. THAT IS JUST AN
ESTIMATE THOSE ARE EMERGENCY
DOLLARS. AND BUDGET WILL
PROVIDE WHAT. TO GET THE
VACCINE OUT. UNDER THE IMPORT
OF ANY MEDIA OF THE VACCINATION.
SERVER I'M HERE IN A IT WILL BE
A LOCAL WHERE THE JUST FOR PLAN
WILL BE- PLANNED OUT AT. YES
AND- IT IN TERMS OF FURTHER
DETAILS I'M HAPPY TO SET UP A
MEETING WITH THE APPROPRIATE
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN THOSE MEETINGS-
TO GIVE YOU MORE DETAIL ON ON
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT BUT ALSO
IN THE COMPONENT IF IT'S DONE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF GETTING
THE VACCINATIONS OUT. TO ALL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS AN
EMPHASIS ON MAKING SURE THAT
VACCINATIONS REACH. THE- TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT FOR MANY YEARS
HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
NOT OVERLOOKED ANYMORE IN THOSE
VACCINATIONS IN THE DISCUSSION
THAT TAKES PLACE. REACHES MANY
TIMES WITH WHAT'S THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S OUR
TRIBAL CALIFORNIA INDIAN
COMMUNITIES I'D LIKE TO- GET
MORE FOLLOW UP ON THAT MISTER
CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR- JUST
ONE MORE- WITH THE SURPLUS
COMING THROUGH- THERE WAS
EMPLOYEES MANY THAT HAD TO TAKE
A 10% CUT. IS THERE ANY- ANY TO
DELIBERATION OR ANY DISCUSSION
OF MAKING THOSE EMPLOYEES HOLES
SINCE WE DO SEE THAT SURPLUS
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHEST MY LAST QUESTION
YES THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT PLAN UP I
THINK WITH THE IMPROVED
REVENUES. IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO
REVISIT THAT AND I THINK AS-
THE SPRING COMES- AS WE LOOK AT
REVENUES IN THE SPRING- WILL
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE. AND CAN
APPROACH- ARE BARGAINING UNIT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WHEN GOING TO GO
TO MISTER IN THE MISC. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE BEGINNING
OF ANOTHER- BUDGET YEAR AND-
ONE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
BE VERY VERY BUSY AND I WANT
TO- WELCOME OUR NEW VICE CHAIR
AT THE POINT OF PERSONAL PRIDE
FOR ME THAT- IT SEEMS THAT
BUDGET SUB THREE IS THE
TRAINING GROUND FOR ALL OF THE
GREAT. BUDGET COMMITTEE OF VICE
CHAIRS WHO. WELCOME ABOARD-
WHERE THIS IS A VERY VERY
CHALLENGING HERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE- INCREASE NEEDS AND
DECREASED FUNDING ALBEIT WE
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND THE PANDEMIC IS
CLEARLY THE- MOST CURRENT ISSUE
THAT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED IN
REAL TIME RIGHT NOW BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE DON'T HAVE
OTHER CRISES THAT HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. IS ONGOING HAS BEEN FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND WE CAN'T
FORGET NIGHT OF PRESHEAF THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION- AROUND
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUNDING
AUTOMOBILE EXHAUST REMAINS THE
SINGLE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
CARBON EMISSIONS SO WE HAVE TO
TRANSITION OUT OF THIS CARBON
ECONOMY AND ONE OF THE MAIN
WAYS WE DO IT IS TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE MOVING TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. HELLO THE BEAR THAT
IN MIND AS WE AS WE HAVE- THIS
DISCUSSION THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS CONTINUES. RIGHT NOW
UNABATED AND AFFECTS MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS AND
THE GOVERNOR THE ADMINISTRATION
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
THEIR CREDIT HAVE PUT TO BED
TOGETHER A PACKAGE. THAT
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BUT- ARE
JUST BE FRANK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT IT'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY AND IT'S NOT ON GOING UP
WE NEED A PREDICTABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WE REALLY NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
TO COME UP. WITH THAT AND
FINALLY AND I DON'T MEAN TO SAY
THAT THIS IS AN EXHAUSTIVE LIST
OF ALL THE CRISIS THAT WE FACE
IN THE STATE BECAUSE THERE ARE
OTHERS- BUT- NONE OF US SHOULD
FORGET. THAT LAST YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO
AND IT'S BEEN MENTIONED- IN
THIS AREA- WAS THE WORST FIRE
SEASON WE'VE EVER SEEN AND
THAT'S AFTER A SERIES OF.
WORSENING SEASONS YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR. UPSELL
WILDFIRE PREVENTION WHICH TIES
INTO CLIMATE CHANGE- NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO ADDRESS AND
AGAIN AND I THINK- MY FRIEND
FROM NICHOLS AND I WILL FIND
SOME COMMON GROUND ON THIS- WE
NEED. A RELIABLE- AND
SUFFICIENT ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THAT CRISIS
I'LL LEAVE IT THERE I'M JUST
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING DOWN
TO WORK IN THE IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS TO COME AND- A PLEASED
TO BE JOINED HERE. BY ALL MY
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS WE GOT A
LOT OF WORK TO DO AND- LET'S
GET TO IT. THANK YOU MISTER
BLUMENTHAL GLUTINOUS ARE
CARILLO AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO A RESTAURANT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT
I'M- SO HONORED TO BE WITH YOU
ALL HERE'S MY FIRST DAY OF THE
BUDGET HEARING AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO BE THE NEW CHAIR
BUDGETS OF FOREIGN TO SEE SO
MANY INTO SO MUCH INTEREST. IN
THREE OF THE MAJOR ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO TACKLE THAT BEING
EDT HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
SO I WILL ADDRESS TWO QUESTIONS
RELATING TO THOSE ISSUES AN
UPSTART WITH EDT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES THE
STIMULUS PACKAGE TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES HAD BY THE PANDEMIC
AND LOW INCOME WORKERS WITH. AN
ADDITIONAL STIMULUS. A PAYMENT
HOWEVER UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
REMAINS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES IN MY DISTRICT OVER THE
BREAK. MY STAFF AS WELL AS MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES TOOK HUNDREDS
IF NOT THOUSANDS OF CALLS.
RELATING TO CONSTITUENTS TYING
TO NAVIGATE. THE SYSTEM AND
ACCESS THEIR BENEFITS. WHAT
RESOURCES ARE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
THE BACKLOG PREPARE FOR THE
EXTENDED THE U. I. BENEFITS IN
THE SECOND. FEDERAL STIMULUS
AND WHAT STEPS IS THE
DEPARTMENT TAKING TO ADDRESS
FRAUD SO THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION ON THE ISSUE. THE
SECOND QUESTION RELATING TO
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE SECTION ON
HOMELESSNESS. ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- IT READS ON PAGE. FOR
TOO LONG THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HAVE PROVIDED ONLY
SHORT TERM MITIGATION
STRATEGIES AND HAVE NOT
DEVELOPED A COMPREHENSIVE
FRAMEWORK FOR ADDRESSING
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS. HOW DOES
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUTLINED.
A LONG TERM STRATEGY TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. MY CONCERN AS HAS
BEEN SHARED BY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. IS THAT WE ARE
PUTTING ON A VERY EXPENSIVE.
BANDAID ON A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE
WITHOUT ACTUALLY ADDRESSING THE
WOUND. A WOUND SO DEEP. THAT
REQUIRES US TO THINK ABOUT LONG
TERM EFFECTS. TO CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE. AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO TREAT THE WOUNDS OF
DRUG ADDICTION. MENTAL HEALTH
AFFLICTIONS. AND ADDRESS THE RE
INTEGRATION FACT SOCIETY. AND
THE REALITY IN NEED THE WORK
FORCE NATIONAL. FOR LONG TERM.
THAT HAS THE SKILLS VERSUS AND
COMPASSION NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THIS WON'T. HOW DOES THE STATE
PLAN TO MAINTAIN THE INVESTMENT
MADE IN HOME KEY WITH A ONE
TIME FUNDING. IS THE ADDITIONAL
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR HOME KEY LIMITED TO
ACQUISITION OF SITE OR WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR ONGOING OPERATING
SUBSIDIES THANK YOU. OKAY I'LL
TRY TO GET ALL YOUR QUESTIONS
LET ME KNOW IF I MISSED
ANYTHING- LET'S START WITH-
ACTUALLY WE'RE ALL HARD ONE SO
LET'S LET'S START WITH EDT- I
THINK I MENTIONED EARLIER AT
SOME OF THE THINGS. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ATTEMPTED TO DO TO
GET MORE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE U. I. CLAIMS SO I'LL JUST
ADD THAT THE BUDGET INCREASES
THE RESOURCES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE U. I.
PROGRAM. BY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION AND SIX THOUSAND
POSITIONS IN THE CURRENT YEAR-
WHICH TOTALS ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION AND 1-000-010-0009
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
POSITIONS- AND SOME OF THOSE. I
DON'T BELIEVE IT- ALL OF THEM
ARE WORKING ON THE U. S. CLAIMS
BUT THERE ARE THERE'S NOT THERE
THERE IS A RESOURCE FAIR JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU SOME OF
THOSE NUMBERS- PROVIDE ONE
POINT ONE BILLION EIGHT
THOUSAND POSITIONS IN THE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- AND THESE
POSITIONS ARE THERE TO SUPPORT
YOU I CLAIMS PROCESSING AND-
AND FRAUD PREVENTION SO YOU
ASKED ABOUT FRAUD- A COUPLE
THINGS I WOULD SAY IS. WHEN- B.
THE LARGE THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FRAUD WAS. FOUND IN
PROBABLY IN JULY JUNE OR JULY
OF THIS PAST YEAR ET IMPLEMENT
ETV IMPLEMENTED A FRONT END
APPLICATION CALLED ID ME TO
BASICALLY- HAVE BETTER TAX AT
THE FRONT END AND VERIFICATION
SO THE- PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM A FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT WAS. CREATED TO
HELP- NONTRADITIONAL- WORKERS
FILE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT. OF
ALLOWED FOR. SOME THE PROJECT
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T A THING
KIND OF ERROR. OR SO INPUT IDEA
WITH- THE SECOND THEY HAVE
DOING WORK CHECK SO THAT THE U.
S. THAT COME IN. CAN BE CROSS
CHECKED AGAINST OTHER LIST. OF
INELIGIBLE- INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS
PRISONERS AND MADE SOME. OF
THAT LEARNING FROM SOME OF THE-
THE FRAUD THAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST. AND LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY
THAT- FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN PROVIDED FOR THE D. A.'S.
TO INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
SOME OF THESE ROSTER SO THAT'S
ON THE BACK END ON THE FRONT
AND I THINK THEY'VE BEEN DOING
MORE BECAUSE IT'S BETTER TO
CATCH IT BEFORE IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS. SO THAT'S- AT. I THINK
I HIT YOUR ATV QUESTION BUT LET
ME KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY FOR THE
ONES ON THAT ONE. I THINK THERE
IS THAT THERE IS DEFINITELY AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK LOAD. AND THAT- WE
WANT TO PROCESS THOSE YOU AYE
CLAIMS THAT WE HAVE TO BALANCE
THAT WITH. THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING IN REGARDS TO
FRAUD. I'M IN TERMS OF THE LONG
TERM. STRATEGY FOR HOMELESSNESS
I WOULD SAY THAT. IT'S A MULTI
LAYERED WE- PROPOSE CAL. WHICH
IS REALLY LOOKING AT. THE
SERVICE SIDE OF- A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO- ARE HOMELESS HAVE.
OTHER ISSUES AND IT'S TRYING TO
COUPLE LOOK AT WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE TO REALLY GET AT THE ROOT
CAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS- BUT WE
DO HAVE THE ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION IN HOMELESSNESS AS
WELL- AND THAT IS FOR THE MORE
TRADITIONAL. OF HOME KEY
EFFORTS WHICH HAPPENED AT H. T.
T. AND IF THEY DID. OUR SYSTEM
A PROGRAM IN SEVERAL MONTHS AND
WERE ABLE TO- CONNECT WITH
LOCALS AND HAVE OVER SIX
THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
AVAILABLE FOR HOMELESS OR THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE VERGE OF
HOMELESSNESS. NOW THE H. C. S.
SIDE OF IT IS ANOTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT REALLY IS LOOKING TO
ACQUIRE- UNITS THAT ARE ALONG
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE SO
UNDERSTANDING THAT A LOT OF
HOMELESS- INDIVIDUALS NEED.
SOMETHING MORE INTENSE THAN
JUST A ROOM AND- SHELTER OVER
THEIR HEADS THAT PROVIDED THAT
THE SERVICES PROVIDED WITH CAL
AIM ALONG WITH- A FIFTH PLACE
TO STAY. IS REALLY TRYING TO
GET AT THAT LONG TERM SOLUTION
VERSUS JUST A SHELTER WHERE YOU
HAVE- INDIVIDUAL FLIPPING FOR
THE EVENING- AND SO I WOULD SAY
THAT IN REGARDS TO THE LONG
TERM- INVESTMENT. IN THOUGH IT
IS ONE TIME IT IS ONE TIME TO
ACQUIRE HOTELS MOTELS- A REHAB.
SENIOR US. SENIOR LIVING SUCH
AS R. C. AFTER- AIR AIR OFF
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES-
SO THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE YOUR
INCREASING OUR OUR HOUSING
SUPPLY- FOR LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE ALONG THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE SO- YES I
AGREE THAT IN THE PAST- THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF SHORT TERM-
FIXES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AT THE STATE
LEVEL IS TO INTEGRATE. THE
SERVICES WITH- WITH WITH
SHELTER SO THAT THIS COULD BE
MORE OF A LONG TERM. SOLUTION.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSES ALTHOUGH I. I DO HAVE
TO SHARE A SENTIMENT THAT A LOT
OF OUR THAT A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES SHARE. IN THAT- THE
RESPONSE BY EDT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY INADEQUATE- TO.
REALLY COMPREHEND HOW
CHALLENGING THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN TO WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE- IN ADDITION TO JUST.
THE FEAR THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE ABOUT LOSING THEIR HOME
LOSING WHERE THEIR THEIR SAFETY
NET AND THEIR TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT. AT THE ADDITION OF
A RESPONSE TO A HOMELESSNESS IS
ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
BATTLE WITH AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
PIECE OF WHAT THE STATE DOES
NOT WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DO. AND HOW IS THE LEGISLATURE
INVOLVED IN ENSURING THAT THE
MONEY THAT WE PUT ASIDE FOR
CERTAIN PROGRAMS IT'S ACTUALLY
USED TO WISELY SO I WOULD I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT ALTHOUGH I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS IN THIS HEARING. AT
LEAST IN SUB FOR WHEN WE HAVE
OUR UPCOMING EDT HEARING AN ARC
OUR UP COMING HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING- HEARING THAT WE THIS
BODY IS PREPARED TO INSURE THAT
WE HOLD THE DEPARTMENTS
NECESSARY ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE ARE
PROVIDING SOLUTIONS SO THE
PEOPLE CAN LIVE IN DIGNITY
PEOPLE CAN STAY IN THEIR HOMES
PEOPLE CAN TRUST OUR GOVERNMENT
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY BE
ABLE TO TRUST AND EIGHTY
DEPARTMENT THAT IS FUNDAMENTAL.
IN ENSURING THAT PEOPLE JUST.
HELLO THEIR LIVES AND I'M
LOOKING FOR TO THAT TASK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OUR OUR VICE CHAIR AND INTO
A DOCTORATE. I THINK IT WAS A
CARE I JUST WANT TO KIND OF
DELVE INTO THAT YOUR WINDOWS ME
INTO SOME MORE SPECIFICS OF THE
BUDGET- SO FIRST OF THE L. A.
O- YOU CAN HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT ANY
QUESTIONS YET SO I FIGURED I'D
START- IS CERTAINLY IN READING
YOUR REVIEW YOUR ANALYSIS IN
THE OUTLOOK YEAH CLEARLY OUR
BUDGET HEALTH LONG TERM IS TIED
TO OUR ECONOMIC HEALTH. AND IN
TERMS OF SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ALTERNATIVES THAT- THE ONLY A
WOULD SUGGEST OR RECOMMEND TO
REVITALIZE THE CALIFORNIA
KANEMI. I WOULD MENTION
POSSIBLY MAY BE STATE
CONFORMITY TO WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID IN REGARDS TO
ALLOWING PPP EXPENDITURES TO BE
TAX DEDUCTIBLE- AND MAYBE APPLE
LIVING DAILY ON MAYBE THE
DEPARTMENT PLANETS CAN. CAN CAN
CHIME IN AND WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS OPEN TO THAT
IDEA. YES MR VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION WE ARE. WE
DID HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE EFFICACY OF- WHETHER SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS COULD BE MADE
MORE IMPACTFUL- THEN THEY ARE
CURRENTLY PROPOSED IN TERMS OF-
PROVIDING SIMPLY- YOU KNOW
CENTURY- MORE DIRECT GRANTED
AWAY TO SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE- ON THE
MARGIN I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE OFFICE IS
AVAILABLE TO. JOIN IN ALL- YES
RAINBOW. YEAH CAN YOU CAN YOU
ALL HEAR ME. YES YES GREAT.
YEAH I MEAN LET ME SPEAK I
GUESS DIRECTLY TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT. THE POTENTIAL MERITS OF.
MAKING THE WE'LL START. MAKING
THE PDP FONG THE DOCTOR BALL-
ONE OF THE KEY PRINCIPLES THAT
WE DISCUSSED IN OUR REVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS. I'M
SORRY. I WAS- THAT THE FUNDS TO
GO SMALL BUSINESSES SHOULD BE
TARGETED TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC- ONE OF THE MAIN
CRITIQUES ESPECIALLY OF THE
FIRST ROUND OF PDP WAS THAT IT
WAS NOT PARTICULARLY WELL
TARGETED TO BUSINESSES THAT
WERE MOST IMPACTED- AND SO
THERE THERE COULD BE YOU KNOW
RAISE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT IF
WE WERE TO MAKE THOSE EXPENSES
DEDUCTIBLE- AT THE STATE LEVEL
WHETHER OR NOT THAT THAT WOULD
REALLY BE A- A MOVE THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDING. THE MOST TARGETED
ASSISTANCE TO BUSINESSES THAT
NEED IT THE MOST. WITH THE
LIMITED FOLLOW UP WITH THAT-
BEFORE THE BAR OF FINANCE AT
TIMES IN A THEIR PERSPECTIVE
BUT- THOSE TWO AS AS MUCH ABOUT
WHEN MY COLLEAGUES. ON A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES REGARDLESS OF
INDUSTRIES BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO IS SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED
BUT BROADLY- ARE SUFFERING
DURING THIS DAY THIS PANDEMIC
ESPECIALLY WITH A PANDEMIC IN
DUE PROCESSION THAT HAS
IMPACTED ALL INDUSTRIES. AND SO
TO SAY THAT A HOSPITAL FOR
EXAMPLE WHO GOT A PPP LOAN TO
STAY AFLOAT. NOW IS NOW
EXPECTED TO PAY TAXES STATE
STATE TAXES ON THAT OR A
RESTAURANT OR A- A BARBER OR A
HOTEL- IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF
THE IF THE- DISCUSSION IS TO
MAKE. SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF AND
NONPROFIT ASSISTANCE RELEASED
MORE ROBUST. OF A WOULD YOU
WOULD THINK THAT WE WOULD NEED
TO PROVIDE. MORE ASSISTANCE
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE ASKING.
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO GOT RELIEF
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO SURVIVE
NOW HAVING. TO PAY TAXES ON
THAT RELIEF. YES SORRY I MEAN I
THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY IS- YOU
KNOW I THINK IT IT COULD BE A
POLICY THAT'S WORTH- THE
LEGISLATURE DELIBERATION
HOWEVER- ANY. FUNDING THAT
WE'RE PUTTING. FOR ASSISTANCE
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES- THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING WE CAN PROVIDE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THAT'S
GONNA. REQUIRE NOT TRADE UP
TRADE OFF NOT ONLY WITHIN-
SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE IN
TERMS OF THE VARIOUS PRIORITIES
THE FUNDING GO TO BUT ALSO JUST
MORE BROADLY TO ALL OF THE
THINGS THE STATE. COULD BE
DOING TO TRY TO- COMBAT THE
PANDEMIC AND HELP THE ECONOMY
RECOVER- SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT. FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEDUCTIBILITY OF THE PPP
EXPENSES AGAINST. ALL THE OTHER
POTENTIAL PRIORITIES THE MY ONE
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES A SYNDROME AS WELL
AS- THINGS THE STATE COULD BE
DOING MORE BROADLY TO HELP THE
ECONOMY. RECOVER AND TO GET THE
PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL. ARE
THERE ARE THERE. ALTERNATIVES
RECOMMENDATIONS. BESIDES THE
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED IN THE BUDGET HE WOULD
RECOMMEND. I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC PROPOSALS FOR
YOU AT THIS TIME BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN- DELIBERATING ON AND
SOMETHING WE PLAN TO OFFER THE
LEGISLATURE SUGGESTIONS ON THAT
WHEN WITH THE PROCESS. OKAY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHAT
IS YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON- STATE
CONFORMITY. REGARDED AS THE
TECH FIVE BILLION PPP. SURE.
THAT PACKAGE WAS PASSED LATE
DECEMBER SO WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO REALLY DIVE INTO THAT
BUT- IN REGARDS TO ANY P. P. P.
OF CONFORMITY. PPP CONFORMITY
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE IMPACTS TO
OUT- TO THE REGION IN TERMS OF
REVENUES. AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME SURPLUS THAT
WE'RE FORECASTING AND BEING-
VERY PRUDENT IN TRYING TO SPEND
THAT I ONE TIME. DOLLARS A ONE
TIME INVESTMENT- SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE THAT IS
NOT CONSIDERED IT'S NOT PART
OBVIOUSLY OF OUR BUDGET BECAUSE
OF THAT THE TIMING TIMING OF
THIS- BUT WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE- POTENTIAL IMPACTS
TO THE BOTTOM LINE. I THANK
YOU. ARE MOVING ON EDUCATION-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WHAT
CAN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT EXPECT
FROM THE STATE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN AS OUTLINED. IN
THE COST OF. THAT INCREASE I
THINK THAT- FREQUENCY. THERE
HASN'T BEEN A LOT OF DETAILS IN
REGARDS TO THIS ENTIRE
PROPOSAL- WITH. DISTRICT NOW
WANTING TO REOPEN AND I KNOW
THE CHAIR IS BEEN VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS. WHAT IS
THE STATE'S FULL COMMITMENT TO
HELPING SCHOOLS REOPEN. WELL
THE STATE COVER FOR EXAMPLE ALL
THE TESTS ASSOCIATED WITH
TESTING- ANDDOES THE STATE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO PROCESS
THESE TESTS. SURE AND I WOULD
JUST ADD TO MY COLLEAGUE-
JESSICA HOLMES COMMENT EARLIER
ABOUT. COMMUNICATION AND I
THINK THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
ATTEMPTING TO BE AS OPEN AS
POSSIBLE WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN REGARDS TO LISTENING TO
THEIR NEEDS AND- DISCUSSING OUR
OWN THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF.
ADDRESSING EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF
STUDENTS- IN REGARDS TO THE DAY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS AS WELL AS
THERE'S A FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE. ALL SORT OF OUT
THERE TO ASSIST SCHOOLS AND-
DEALING WITH THE IMPACT OF. THE
DOCUMENT EDUCATION FOR OUR
CHILDREN- BUT TESTING IS ONE OF
THE- ELIGIBLE- EFFORTS UNDER
THE TWO BILLION AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW
TESTING IS GOING TO BE ONE WAY
THAT WE- ARE AT THAT BOOK STILL
COMFORTABLE RETURNING BACK TO
IN SCHOOL INSTRUCTION. AND I
THINK THAT THERE IS A DESIRE TO
LOOK INTO- PROPORTION OF THE
STUDENTS WHO WOULD HAVE-
ELIGIBLE FOR. MEDICARE AND SO
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
FEDERAL DOLLARS INVOLVED IN
HELPING WITH THE TESTING COUGH
AS WELL. OKAY I MEAN I THINK
THAT THAT'S IT YOU KNOW I THINK
HE SAID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS I
BASIC THE CONCERN I THINK FROM
JUST THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION IS THAT THERE ARE
REAL CONCERNS AMONGST OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WHO
QUESTIONED THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE WHAT NEEDS
TO BE ACHIEVED TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW.
THAT OUR ECONOMY OUR HEALTH
CARE CAPACITY. AND JUST- OUR
SOCIETY AT LARGE ISN'T GOING TO
BE FUNCTIONING PROPERLY IF WE
DON'T REOPEN THE SCHOOLS
SAFELY- IN TERMS OF DEFERRALS
AND I THINK MAYBE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE CAN. ANSWER THIS FIRST
AND THEN I'LL GET THE
PERSPECTIVE OF ELIO. WHY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT FULLY ADDRESSING
THAT ARE TAKING CARE OF THE
DEFERRALS COMPLETELY- I KNOW
THAT THAT THAT. THE L. A. O. AS
OUTLINED CONCERNS WITH
OPERATING DEFICITS MOVING. BY
MOVING FORWARD AND OTHER BUDGET
YEARS THAT WILL GET LARGER. AND
WE HAVE. THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING
PAYING DOWN TWO THIRDS OF THE
DEFERRALS. BUT THEN PROPOSING
ONGOING- COSTS OF LIVING
INCREASES WILL- THAT WOULD
EXACERBATE THE ONGOING-
DEFICITS IN THE FUTURE. WHAT
ARE THE PROS AND CONS OR MAYBE
WHAT'S THE IT WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
THE THINKING OR THE THOUGHT
PROCESS OF. WHY NOT PAY OFF ALL
THE REFERRALS WE DID LAST YEAR.
WITH GOALS. SURE AND YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I THINK
THE EASY ANSWER THE SIMPLE
ANSWER TO THAT IS TO- PAY OFF
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE THOUGH
THAT- IN REGARDS TO ALL OF. THE
SUPPORTING SCHOOL- ON THOSE
DEFERRALS WITH IT FOR THE
POTENTIALLY A CASH FLOW ISSUE
BUT ALSO LEAVING ROOM FOR OTHER
THINGS- THE NEED TO GET DONE
AND SO. IN TERMS OF- PRIORITIES.
THAT MADE ROOM FOR OTHER PEOPLE-
BUT SAID I WOULD I WOULD SAY
THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
IS THE START OF THE
CONVERSATION AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD AND- TO CONSIDER
OTHER ALTERNATIVES. YES MISTER
ROGERS THANK YOU I THINK OUR
OFFICE. WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT. YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS WOULD
VIEW THE BUDGET REALLY AS- TO
BUDGETS IN ONE BECAUSE THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET IS SEPARATE
NO WAY AND SO. ACTUALLY THE
OPERATING DEFICITS WERE
PROJECTING IN THE FUTURE UNDER
THE NINE NINETY EIGHT SAID AT
THE BUDGET ARE NOT PRESENT ON
THE PROPERTY EIGHT SIDE. THAT
BEING SAID I THINK OUR OFFICE
WOULD VIEW THAT- IT WOULD BE
WORTH YOUR CONSIDERATION TO ADD
MORE TO PAYING DOWN THE
DEFERRALS BECAUSE- WE DO HAVE
MORE RESOURCES THIS YEAR THAN
WE MAY AND SUBSEQUENT YEARS
ITSELF MIGHT BE THE RIGHT TIME
TO PAY DOWN THAT- WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY A ONE TIME DEBT.
SURE AND I AND I SO APPRECIATE
THAT OKAY FOR CATION. IN THE
DEFERRALS I THINK I ADMIT AND
CORRECT IF I'M WRONG IF YOU IF
YOU- IT IS ACCURATE THAT YOU'VE
ASKED THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LAST
YEAR. TO CONTINUE TO SPEND. BY
WITH WITH NOT KNOWING WHEN THE
MONEY GOING TO COME IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE OF THE
REFERRALS. SO IT WOULD. AT
LEAST IN MY OPINION TO BE
PRUDENT. FOR US TO PROVIDE SOME
CERTAINTY THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO TAKE CARE THE
DEFERRALS- MEDIALLY COMPLETELY.
THANK AFTER I THINK WE WOULD WE
WOULD THINK OF IT AS- WE
SHIFTED THE CASH MANAGEMENT
BURDEN TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM THE STATE WITH THE
DEFERRALS. AND SO. I MEAN IN
GENERAL THE IDEA OF PAYING THEM
DOWN AS SOON AS YOU IS IT
POSSIBLE IT IS A GOOD IDEA.
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE BORROWING. THE TO
CONTINUE THE CURRENT PAYMENT
DIRECTLY. TO CASH FLOW NOTES IN
THE MUNICIPAL MARKET. I IN
TERMS OF- ENTERS A HOSPITAL
CAPACITY AND STAFFING I DON'T
THINK THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP
YET TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE THERE PROPOSALS IN
THIS BUDGET- TO. INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF NURSES I KNOW THAT
WITH THE HOSPITALS ARE DEALING
WITH. AND YOU. KNOW TRYING TO
FIND A WAY AROUND THESE THAT.
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THESE NO
RATIO AND- OF COURSE WE HAVE TO
PAY THE TELL. UP DOWN THE STATE
NOW- ARE THERE SPECIFIC
BUDGETARY ITEMS. THAT WOULD.
DEAL WITH HOSPITAL STAFFING-
ESPECIALLY SPECIFICALLY WHEN
NURSES. SURE I WOULD POINT OUT
ON PAGE FORTY SIX- ARE COVERED
NINETEEN DIRECT RESPONSE COST
ESTIMATES WHICH DOES INCLUDE-
COSTS THROUGH THE SALUKIS AND
OPERATING- COSTS- BUT I WOULD
ALSO- HANDED OVER TO ONE OF MY
EIGHTY JUST CALLING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE. THAT
WOULD BE- THE TICKET OUT TO. HI
RYAN MILLER AGAIN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- MMHM.
YEAH IT IN ADDITION TO WILL.
BUT HONESTLY IT'S JUST TO
MENTION AND- YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THE RESPONSES GENERALLY BEEN
THROUGH ACTIONS THAT THE STATE
HAS BEEN TAKING- THE SURGE
ACTIVITY IS- YOU KNOW THE
HOSPITAL DECOMPRESSION EFFORTS-
AND I THINK IT WOULD HIGHLIGHT
IS ON A PERCENT RATE INCREASE
WE PROVIDED IN THE SPRING TO-
SKILLED NURSING NURSING
FACILITIES- AND- YOU KNOW-
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT THROUGH-
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM THAT- WE X.
WITH THE SOON WILL BE IN EFFECT
THROUGH THE END OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR CONSISTENT WITH OUR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT- WHEN THE
FEDERAL. PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WILL AND- I THINK I
GOT A BOTTLE HALF OF WHAT YOU
SAID BUT- BUT IN TERMS OF I
THINK A YOU MENTIONED SKINNER
SOME FACILITIES AND HAVING
STILL HASN'T DISABILITIES AND
HOSPITALS. ALL HAVE PRESSURE.
DID FOR STAFFING- AND I GUESS-
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IS THERE A
LONG TERM PLAN OUTLINED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO MAYBE. EXPANDERS IN
PROGRAMS AT THE UNIVERSITIES OF
THE CS USING THESE KEYS OR
OTHER AVENUES- MAYBE SOME
LICENSE RECIPROCITY TO ALLOW-
INDIVIDUALS ANDERSON WHO ARE
MOVING INTO CALIFORNIA TO
ALLOW- THOSE. ARE LICENSES TO
APPLY HERE AND THEN THEY CAN
THEY CAN WORK IN OUR HOSPITALS.
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
MR FONG I'LL SAY THAT- UNDER
ONE OF OUR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS WE ARE EXPANDING ON
HEALTH CARE- CAPACITY AND I CAN
GET YOU MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT AT THREE FIFTEEN PROGRAM
AND REPLACING IT UP. I JUST
HAVE THE- TWO OR THREE MORE
QUESTIONS IT WILL SIMPLY- I
THINK THE MEMBERS HERE KNOW
ABOUT MY- INTEREST IN
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL HOW
MUCH IS IN IN THIS BUDGET FOR
A- HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. I'M
GONNA HANNAH QUESTION TO STEVE
WEALTH. HELLO STEVE WELLS
BERMAN FINANCE IN HEARING YES
YEAH. ALSO THE- SO THE BUT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL CURRENTLY THE
BUDGET AS PROPOSED- INCLUDES
THEIR OPERATIONAL COSTS ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THEIR- AND THEN
THERE'S THIS THERE'S AN AMOUNT
FOR CAPITAL COSTS. IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO OF ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
REPRESENTS. THE REMAINING
BALANCE OF FOUR ON IT FOR NEXT
YEAR OF AYE CAPTAIN TRADE FUNDS.
THERE'S NO FUNDING CURRENTLY IN
THE BUDGET FOR NEXT YEAR FOR
PROP- AS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
START WORKING ON THE BUSINESS
PLAN THAT THEY EXPECT TO HAVE
RELEASED IN FEBRUARY. OKAY BUT
DO YOU ASK THE MADE THAT WHAT
WAS THAT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL- IN TERMS OF
HOW MUCH MONEY WAS ALLOCATED
THAT. IT WOULDN'T BE IN THE
LOWER RIGHT. CORRECT THE GIVEN
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET YES.
YEAH THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET IT
IS ABOUT- TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN A PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT AND
CAP AND TRADE MONEY AND DO YOU
AS THE PUMP ON. AND YOU AS THE
CAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO
YOU EXPECT THE GOVERNOR TO CUT
HIGH SPEED RAIL FUNDING. WELL
THE FUNDING FOR PROPER. PHOTO
SENDING FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
WILL BE VERY DEPENDED UPON WELL
WHATEVER THE FINAL AGREED UPON
BUSINESS PLAN IS THIS RELEASED
IN FEBRUARY. AND I THINK THAT
IS NOT ENOUGH. YOU DON'T WILL
BE DEPENDENT UPON THE RELEASE
OF PLAN. OKAY WELL I GUESS I'LL
ASK YOU AGAIN WHETHER YOU'VE
GOT HAS DEVELOPMENT IN THE NEXT
TIME YOU TESTIFIED ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE I IN TERMS OF
WILDFIRES- HOW ARE YOU AS THE
DIPLOMA FINANCE HOW ARE YOU
PLANNING TO ACCELERATE FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS THAT THAT I
THINK THAT. THE GOAL AMONG THE
NUMBER MY COLLEAGUES HE SAID
SOME LIGHT ON SOME SPECIFICS.
THANKS TO. MY COLLEAGUE AT
FINANCED. I'LL SEND YOU A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SO- FIRSTLY
WOULD SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
INVESTING I'M SORRY THAT
GOVERNMENT BUDGET REFLECTS AN
INVESTMENT OF ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
IN FOREST RESILIENCE- AND THAT
IS REALLY DESIGNED AS A BROAD
BASED PACKAGE THAT IS A PART OF
THAT PACKAGE THERE'S A THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT THAT
WILL BE A PART OF THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE AND THE GOAL OF.
SPENDING IS TO GET PROJECTS A
CRITICAL FIRE PREVENTION
PROJECTS ON THE GROUND AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE ANOTHER WITH THE
GOAL OF TRYING TO PREPARE THE
STATE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIRE SEASON. OKAY SO THERE'S
BEEN COMPLAINING I THINK IN
THAT AND THAT AND. THAT AND IT
REALLY I CAN'T BUDGET PACKAGE
THAT WILL SEE. THE NUMBER OF
THE THERE'S A NUMBER WAYS THAT
THE PACKAGE ADDRESS IT ON SOME
OF THE DIFFERENT PERMITTING
PROCESS SEASON REVIEWS. OUTSIDE
OF THE BUDGET THERE WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT CALLED
THE CAL THE GPD I'M THAT
STREAMLINES THE SEQUEL REVIEW
PROCESS FOR AND- OVER TWENTY
MILLION ACRES MISSY
RESPONSIBILITY AREA SO THAT
WILL BE A PART OF IT. I'M IN
AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT KIND OF PREFER MEDINA
STATIONS USE ANOTHER FOCUS IT
AS- AS WELL AS SOME CONTRACTING
EXEMPTION. AND TO ENSURE THAT
PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO GET ON THE
GROUND AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AS THAT'S OUR SHARED GOAL.
PROGRAM WILL LOOK FOR TO SEE
ALL THOSE DETAILS I'D I WOULD
BUY. ONE LAST QUESTION I OF
COURSE I DON'T WANT TO- AND YOU
I DON'T KNOW THEY GAVE EDT. YOU
THERE'S NO DOUBT I THINK I
GOING ALL OF US HERE ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THEN OF COURSE
ALL OF US TO SERVE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THE EDT IS FAILING
THAT COULD BE ANSWERS BEING
PROVIDED TODAY ARE VERY BROAD
BASED THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DETAILED PROPOSAL. AND PLANS OF
HOW TO OVERHAUL EDIE- IS
UNACCEPTABLE THIS AND I'LL SAY
THAT YOU JUST NEED MORE MONEY
WHEN MONEY IS NOT THE ISSUE AND
WE'VE LIVED IT I TALKED TO
CHAIRMAN THING ABOUT THIS
BEFORE WE LIVED THROUGH THIS
WITH THE DMV. AND THE DMV WELL
WE GAVE THEM HAD ADDED
RESOURCES IS NOT OPERATING
FUNCTIONALLY. IT'S A LITTLE BIT
BETTER BUT IT'S NOT A MONEY
ISSUE IT'S A LEADERSHIP ISSUE.
AND THAT WE NEEDED WHEN WE
ASKED. FOR VERY DETAILED
PROPOSAL ON THAT IN TERMS OF-
MY LAST QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE ADULTING
ME. MAYBE THE L. A. OKAY AND-
HE TO THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
NEW MEMBERS AND- WE HEAR THE-
THE IDEA OF BEGAN LIMIT. CAN
YOU EXPLAIN. WHAT WE WERE GONNA
EXPECT OVER THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS- IF WE DOWN TO GET UNDER
THE GALA MEADOW WE SOMEHOW
EXCEEDED- AND WHAT. WILL
HAPPEN- IF WE DO. YES MISTER
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU- RIGHT NOW
THE ADMINISTRATION- IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL INDICATED THAT-
YOU KNOW THAT THE STATE WOULD
BE SLIGHTLY ABOVE THE LIMIT-
BY- THIS COMING YEAR AND THE
RULES ARE THAT HALF OF THE
AMOUNT OF LEVERAGE WOULD GO
BACK TO THE TAXPAYERS AND HALF
WOULD. GO TO SCHOOLS BUT REALLY
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
CONVERSATION FOR THE MAY
REVISION BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THE
NUMBERS WILL LIKELY SHIFT AND-
SO I THINK YOU KNOW I ALTHOUGH
ALTHOUGH IT WAS- YOU KNOW NOTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S- UP PRESS
BRIEFING IN IN IN THE DOCUMENT.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA KNOW MORE
IN THE COMING MONTHS ABOUT IT
SO- YEAH. I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT THE MISTER. THANK YOU MUCH
BYE SURE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO A DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND THEN
MISTER MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
WANTED TO WELCOME THE VICE
CHAIR AS WELL. ALSO WANTED TO
EXTEND AN APPRECIATION AND
INDULGENCE FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR ANSWERING OUR
QUESTIONS. WELL FOR MANY OF US
THIS IS OUR FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL
I AT LEAST CAME UP ON FRIDAY
WHICH WAS BUDGET DAY OUT OF
EXCITEMENT AND STILL A
WILLINGNESS. TO GRAB AN OLD
SCHOOL COPY OF THE BUDGET AND
READ IT COVER TO COVER AND SO.
WHILE I WILL CONTAIN MY
QUESTIONS TODAY SOLELY TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. I DO
WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH MY
OFFICE ABOUT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE. SO
FIRST IF I CAN TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS TO HELP
MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE. AND A SYSTEM THAT
BETTER USES HEALTH DATA TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. SOME
OF THESE INCLUDE ESTABLISHING
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THE OFFICE OF
MEDICARE INNOVATION AND
INTEGRATION THE CENTER CENTER
FOR DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION. AND THE RECASTING
OF AWESOME HEAD UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE NEW
OFFICES AND PROGRAMS. HOW CAN
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH I FEEL
OBLIGED TO REMIND IS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT. BEST
COLLABORATE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT MORE DETAILS ON THESE
PROPOSALS. HI I'M HANNAH
QUESTION OVER TO ONE OF MY AGE
OF COLLEAGUES FOR THE FOR MORE
DETAILS. HI RANKBRAIN MILLER
AGAIN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I TRIED KEEPING MY
VIDEO OFF OF IT. APOLOGIZE FOR
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES-
WELL- WE ACTUALLY RELEASED-
LANGUAGE JOHN ON THE OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY PROPOSAL JUST
BEFORE. AND THEN IT STARTED
LAST YEAR IN AND WHILE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
CHANGES THIS TIME AROUND- YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT WE'VE WE'VE
COVERED THAT ISSUE I THINK
PRETTY. PRETTY THOROUGHLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND CLEARLY- YOU
KNOW SITUATIONS CHANGED QUITE A
BIT- SO WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO YOU KNOW HEARING- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT FEEDBACK WE GET. FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND OF COURSE FROM
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE- BUT
I THINK IN TO IN TERMS OF THE
TIMING- WE WOULD BE PLANNING TO
RELEASE THE DETAILS OF THE OF
THE- OFFICE OF AFFORDABILITY
PROPOSAL- ON THE FEBRUARY FIRST
TO STATUTORY DEADLINE. FRAME-
THAT THAT WE HAVE FOR TRAILER
BILLING. I WOULD ENCOURAGE AS
STRONGLY AS I COULD- HE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO PLAY AN ACTIVE ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
AND WHILE MANY OF THEM WERE
REFERENCED IN BEING RELEASED IN
THE SPRING I WOULD WANT THESE
RELEASED MUCH EARLIER SO WE CAN
AGENDA IS THEM DISCUSS THEM
AND- FRANKLY TO VETS MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS. WHICH ARE
NEEDED AND NEED TO BE DISCUSSED.
THIS PANDEMIC THOUGH HAS TRULY
BROUGHT TO THE FOREFRONT THE
DISPARITY GAPS THAT WE HAVE NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF GEOGRAPHY BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF DEMOGRAPHICS.
HOW CAN WE ENSURE AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDING FOR ONE
TIME PROGRAM PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE AND I
WILL GIVE YOU SOME SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES. THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU
REFERENCE REGARDING THE ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN REAL ESTATE ASSETS
NEEDED TO ESTABLISH THE FULL
CONTINUUM OF. MENTAL HEALTH
CARE HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTE THESE
FUNDS IN A WAY THAT PRESERVES
AND EXPANDS HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME SENIORS. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
MITIGATES HOMELESSNESS BOTH IN
OUR RURAL AND MUNICIPAL AREAS
OF OUR STATE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION I THINK EQUITY IS
ALSO ANOTHER THREAD- THAT GOES
THROUGHOUT MANY OF OUR BUDGET
PROPOSALS IN THIS. YEAR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND- IT'S AND
IT'S AS IMPORTANT TO- THE
MINISTRATION TO GET THAT RIGHT
AS WELL AND SO I WOULD SAY- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
YOU ON THAT TO GET IDEAS- IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS GREATER
EQUITY. IN THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THOSE DOLLARS ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT NOT ALL ARE
KERN COUNTIES ARE THE SAME AND
MANY OF OUR COUNTY STRUGGLE
WITH THE RESOURCES FOR MATCHING
FUNDS AND- JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR. ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES. NOW SOME ARE. L. A.
APPROPRIATELY DISCUSSED IN A
APOLOGIES FOR NOT ASKING
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK YOUR HAND
OUT WAS THREE PAGES IN THE
BUDGET WAS A COUPLE HUNDRED
PAGES AND SO. BUT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT I
BELIEVE YOUR CASELOAD
PROJECTIONS WERE MUCH CLOSER TO
REALITY AS IT PANNED OUT.
DURING THIS LAST YEAR. AND SO I
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT IF I
CAN. ABOUT SOME OF THE SAFETY
NET CASELOAD INCREASES WE
PREVIOUSLY ANTICIPATED. HAVE
NOT MATERIALIZED. AND YET OUR
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS NEED
ASSISTANCE IN THE AREAS OF
HOUSING. FOOD SECURITY HEALTH
CARE AND MORE. WHAT CAN WE DO.
TO BE ABLE TO SIMPLIFY ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE. INCLUDING CAL WORKS
AND MEDICAL. HOW CAN WE BEST
WORK WITH OUR IMMIGRANT SERVICE
PROGRAMS NETWORKS OF CBO'S TO
REACH OUT TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. WHO
HAVE BORNE THE BRUNT OF THE
CHILLING EFFECT A PUBLIC CHARGE.
THE QUESTION IS FOR FINANCE I'M
REALLY TRYING TO GET TO WE HAVE
CASELOAD PROJECTIONS. THE
PRODUCTION IN THE BUDGET IS
FIFTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
PEOPLE WILL BE ENROLLED INTO
MEDIC CAL. WHERE THESE
PROJECTIONS BORN OUT AND HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT- WE AS A STATE
ARE REACHING OUT TO OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES TO BE
INCLUSIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ONCE AGAIN- I AM GOING
TO HAND THAT OVER TO ONE OF MY
EIGHTY JUST COLLEAGUES FOR SOME
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHICH. HI THIS
IS- ADAM DORSEY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- YES- CERTAINLY I THINK
WE ARE SEEING SOME SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES PARTICULARLY WITH THE
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ON THE MEDICAID
SIDE. AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY-
ARE ARE THE COUNTY PARTNERS ARE
ARE CONTINUING TO TAKE CASES
IN. AND IT REALLY DOES KIND OF
DEPEND ON THE ON THE INDIVIDUAL
SORT OF RULES RUN THE PROGRAM
IN THE PAST WE HAVE- PROVIDED
FUNDING IS THE STATE TO
NONPROFITS TO- TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE CONNECTING TO IT
TO SERVICES AND THAT SORT OF
THING AND SO- CERTAINLY WANT TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU ALL AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
AROUND- YOU KNOW HOW WE MIGHT-
YOU KNOW CONTINUE THOSE EFFORTS
IN THE FUTURE. HOW TO RESPECT
MY COLLEAGUES I WILL LIMIT
MYSELF TO TWO MORE QUESTIONS
AND JUST. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE. COVERED
NINETEEN AS HIGHLIGHTED MANY OF
THE DEFICIENCIES IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALSO
COMPOUNDED OUR POPULATION
HEALTH CHALLENGES. HOW DOES THE
BUDGET HELP TO BUILD A MORE
ROBUST PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE CAN
EXPECT TO BE MORE PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT PANDEMIC. WHILE ALSO
HELPING US TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF EXISTING AND
ONGOING HEALTH. EPIDEMICS SUCH
AS THE OPIOID CRISIS HABSI AND
STDS JUST TO NAME A FEW. I CAN
EFFORT ADAM DORSEY OR RYAN
MILLER COULD ADD TO THAT. HI
RYAN MILLER AGAIN FROM FINANCE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
YEAH I WOULD SAY THAT. ASSEMBLY
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL I'M NOT REALLY ARE
FOCUSED AT THE MOMENT ON- YOU
KNOW THE SURGERY FOR ITS WE
WERE DISCUSSING EARLIER- IN
INCREASING TESTING- AND
CERTAINLY ALSO- YOU KNOW- BUT
YOU KNOW THE ESTIMATED FUNDING
THAT E HAVE SET ASIDE FOR THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION EFFORTS- I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT A PROPOSAL THAT
IS THROUGH THE HHS AGENCY. TO
DO A LOOK BACK ANNA ANNA
RETROACTIVE RETROSPECTIVE
ANALYSIS OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN- PANDEMIC OF THROUGH
AN EQUITY LINES. AND AS I THINK
THE APPROACH THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY FOR THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT. YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAD
GOING INTO THIS- YEAH I THINK
THAT- CLEARLY- BOTH OF THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL- YEAH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE LOCALHOST
JURISDICTIONS- TO SAY THEIR
STRAINED I THINK WOULD BE YOU
KNOW QUITE AN UNDERSTATEMENT I
DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO HOW TO
QUITE. BUT IT- BUT I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE THE SORT OF
THING THAT WE WANT TO LOOK AT
AND THAT PROPOSAL- AND SO YOU
KNOW AGAIN I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO BE WORKING WITH
YOU AND OTHERS TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD. I
FEEL OBLIGATED TO REMIND US
THAT WE HAVEN'T TURNED OUR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND THE
FOLDER DEPARTMENT PEOPLE STILL
HAVE HEART ATTACKS THEY STILL
HAVE STROKES PEOPLE STILL HAVE
ISSUES WITH OPIOIDS AND STDS
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BY
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IT'S
INCUMBENT ON US TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES IF I CAN BECAUSE STRESS
ANXIETY EXTREME EXHAUSTION AND
BURNOUT ARE THE MOST COMMON
CONDITIONS REPORTED BY OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. WHAT
MENTAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT THE WELL BEING OF THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS PANDEMIC. AND IN ADDITION
AS A BY PRODUCT OF OUR CURRENT
REALITY MORE AND MORE STUDENTS
HAVE A NEW FOUND INTEREST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH HOW IS THE STATE
ENSURING WE HAVE A PIPELINE OF
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. FOR THE
DURATION OF THE PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION I WOULD AGAIN POINT TO
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION- IN.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH FOR STUDENTS
THAT I I'VE I BROUGHT UP
EARLIER- AND YOU BRING UP A
VERY GOOD POINTS I THINK THAT-
B. THERE ARE THERE IS A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION-
ALLOCATION. FOR HIGHER ED THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT- PROPOSALS
RIGHT NOW- IN REGARDS TO
LINKAGES TO WHAT STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING IN SCHOOL AND WHAT IS
ACTUALLY NEEDED IN THE
WORKFORCE. AND I THINK IT MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE TO VISIT-
HEALTHCARE SHOPPING FOR THAT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN- THE DEARTH
THAT MEANS THAT THAT THAT. THE-NEED FOR MORE OF THEM- IN
REGARDS TO- INVESTMENTS. NOW
THAT ARE IN THE BUDGET FOR
FRONTLINE WORKERS I WOULD HAVE
TO TURN TO ONE OF MY-
COLLEAGUES AT FINANCE. ADAM
DORSEY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO- I THINK THIS IS- AN AREA
WHERE THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE A YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS AND WORKFORCE- AND
I THINK AS WE GET OUTSIDE OF
THIS PANDEMIC WILL WILL HAVE TO
LOOK. TOWARDS THE FUTURE AND
KIND OF SEE- YOU KNOW WHERE
THIS LEAVES US AND WE AND KIND
OF WHAT KIND OF PLANS WE NEED
TO MAKE IN THE FUTURE BUT- YOU
KNOW IT THAT AT THE TIME AND
COST PAID YOU KNOW THERE'S A
THERE'S A NUMBER OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS MINISTRATIONS MADE A
PERMANENT. OR ERIN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT IN
ADDITION TO THE SPECIAL FUNDS
THERE FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
FIRST PROGRAMS- UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS AND
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD WORK IN THIS AREA
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND- AGAIN WE
LOOK REALLY FORWARD YOU KNOW WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS- WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES- OVER
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS. I
DO WANT TO APPRECIATE MUCH OF
THE HARD WORK THAT HAS GONE
INTO OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
OVER THE LAST YEAR. AND YET
THERE ARE STILL REGIONS OF OUR
STATE THAT STRUGGLE. TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE PROVIDERS TO DEAL
WITH THIS PANDEMIC. AND IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT OUR
FRONTLINE PROVIDERS ARE. IN
NEED OF RESILIENCY I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT ON US AS A STATES TO
DO ALL WE CAN TO. HELP BUILD
THAT PIPELINE AND- ALLOW THE
STUDENTS TO. START THINKING
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN HELP WITH
THE NEXT PANDEMIC. HAVING GONE
THROUGH AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. WHERE I'VE SEEN MY
FAIR SHARE OF DRAMA. I KNOW
THAT. THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES NEED SUPPORT. AND I
WILL WANT TO CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE AND FIGUREOUT HOW WE
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THEM. SO
THAT THEY WILL HAVE RESILIENCY
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND THE
NEXT THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS ARE REALLY IN A IN
THE AREA OF A PUBLIC SAFETY-
AND WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
JUST GO THROUGH LIKE THE FOUR
AREAS THAT I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. AND IN. OFFICE FINANCE
DECIDED THEY WANTED TO DELVE
RIGHT INTO IT OR EVEN TO GET
BACK TO ME. WE CAN DISCUSS IT
IN SOME FIVE. WHICH I USED TO
BE TERRIBLE. AND WHEN I WAS THE
CHAIR PASS BUDGETS OF FIVE- SO
THE AREAS ARE COURTS. PROBATE
CDCR- OUR POPULATION AND
CAMERAS. SO THAT'S COURTS
PROBATE CDCR POPULATION AND
CAMPUS. ON THE COURTS OF THE
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
TRIGGER CUTS TO DID YOU DO
THIS- BRANCH HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
RESTORED TO THE COURTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OF WHAT
REMAINING RESOURCE CHALLENGES
REMAINS FOR TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS AND UNDERSTAND I'M
SAYING THIS IN THE CONTEXT WHEN
I WAS ELECTED TWENTY TWELVE IS
LIKE A ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. DEFICIT MONEY IS EVER
TAKEN OUT OF THE COURT BUDGET I
WORKED REALLY REALLY HARD TO
RESTORE THAT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION I WOULD HATE TO SEE
THAT WE'RE REGRESSING. BACK AND
CONTINUE TO TAKE MONEY OUT OF
COURT IN ADDITION TO THAT COURT
QUESTION. ADMINISTRATION ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL ONGOING
RESOURCES FOR SELF HELP CENTERS
IN THE COURTS. CAN YOU DESCRIBE
IN WHAT WAYS THE SELF HELP
CENTERS OPERATE VIRTUALLY ARE
HAVE VIRTUAL COMPONENTS THAT
CAN PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
LITIGANTS DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
SECOND COBIT. WITH FEWER THAN
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND PRISONERS
IN STATE PRISON. NOT THAT ONE
HOW MUCH AT CDC ARE.
ENCOURAGING COSTS FOR NINETY
RELATE X. INCLUDING PEOPLE
TESTS AND HOPEFUL AS WE MOVE
FOR THAT. IMAGE BOB IS THE
MINISTER CONSIDER. AT THIS
RELIEF. OF BY VULNERABLE P. IN
THE STATE'S PRISONS THAT ARE
SET FOR RELEASE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
JUST DON'T JUST LET PEOPLE OUT
THERE WE HAVE A PLAN FOR WHEN
THEY GET OUT SO THEY DON'T.
RECIDIVISTS OR CAUSE MORE HARM
TO THE COMMUNITIES- YES I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR THEIR
MEDICAL WELL BEING BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
DO RELEASE THEM THAT THEY DON'T
CREATE PROBLEMS DOWN IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. BUT AS
COVERT CDCR COPULATION WITH
FEWER THAN NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
PRISONERS IN STATE PRISON. WHEN
IT WAS OVER CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND HOW MUCH IS CDC
ARE SAVED. AS A RESULT OF THESE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS. WHERE
THE SAVINGS RE DIRECTED TO
OTHER AREAS OF THE OPERATION
BEING CDC OUR OPERATIONS IF SO
WHAT AREAS. IN ADDITION. IS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERING
ADDITIONAL PRISON CLOSURES
BASED ON THE L. A. L.'S
POPULATION PROJECTIONS THAT
INDICATE FIVE PRISONS CAN BE
SAFELY CLOSE BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE SAVING THE STATE TAXPAYERS
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION ANNUALLY
M. BILLIONS AND AVOID IT
CAPITAL MAINTENANCE INVESTMENTS
NOT ONLY DOES SAVINGS BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE SAME QUESTION ISN'T
RELEASING PEOPLE WOULD CLOVER
PROBLEM DO WE HAVE A WRAPAROUND
SERVICE PLAN ON THE OUTSIDE.
SHE WOULD DIVERT AT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DON'T
RECIDIVISTS SHOULD WE PUT IN
ALL THE SERVICES MAYBE EVEN TO
COMMUNITY GROUPS SO THAT TYPE
OF GOING TO A COMMUNITY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
FORMALLY INCARCERATED WHO CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN DON'T BECOME
A PROBLEM WHEN THEY GET OUT.
AND THEN FINALLY. CAMERAS
THERE'S A TOTAL OF THIRTY
MILLION OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS FOR CAMERAS BOTH
STATIONARY. AND BODY CAMERAS R.
J. DONOVAN DUE TO THE LAWSUIT
WHICH INCIDENTLY. THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION CDC R. B. P. H.
IS APPEALING. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WOULD NOT BE
PUTTING BODY CAMERAS ON
EVERYONE. IN CDC ARE SPECIALLY
TO PRISON GUARD IT PROTECTS
THEM FROM FRIVOLOUS COMPLAINTS
BY INMATES BUT ALSO LET US KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN PRISON
GUARDS AND INMATES IT WORKS
BOTH WAYS BOTH ENTITIES CAN DO
THAT. SO I DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY
SAY WE'RE APPEALING. BEING ABLE
TO PUT BODY CAMERAS ON EVERYONE
IN CDC ARE I DON'T KNOW ONE WHY
THAT IS A PROBLEM TO WHICH
ADMINISTRATION- TO TALKING
ABOUT THIS ONE APPEALING THE
DECISION. BY THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION BUT MORE
IMPORTANT WHY. ARE WE PROVIDING
BODY CAMERAS DISAGREED START AT
ONE FACILITY BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS IT
AND SO IF THERE IS A PROBLEM IF
THERE'S A THERE'S A LOGICAL
REASON. HOPEFULLY BETTER THAN
ONE THAT I WAS GIVEN THAT SHE
PRISON GUARDS CAN JUST TURN THE
CAMERAS OFF. MY ANSWER WAS. YOU
DO KNOW THEY MAKE. CAMERAS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN'T TURN OFF
SO. LET ME KNOW WHAT WHAT'S
GOING ON BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR BOTH
SIDES IN THE INSTABILITY. SOB
LEAVE IT UP TO YOU WHETHER YOU
WANT TO COME TO MY OFFICE WE
WANNA DO IT AND- END UP BUT
JUST A FIVE. MINUTE PENALTY
HOURS LATE. SO YEAH I THINK
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS-
I THINK I CAN ANSWER ONE RIGHT
NOW AND THAT IS THE- YEAH THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
TRIGGER CUTS FOR THE COURTS.
AND WE HAVE A THREE POINT 7%
INCREASE IN THE CURRENT.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT BRINGS
IT UP TO ABOUT SEVENTY MILLION
SO JUST THAT'S- THAT THE COURTS
ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
EFFICIENCIES TO PREFER SAVINGS-
AND ARE THE OTHER QUESTIONS WE
WILL GET BACK TO YOU. WE CAN
HAVE- STAFF REPUBLICAN REJECT
YOUR STAFF AND SET UP. MEETINGS
FOR FOLLOW UP. AND SO IN ON THE
COURT THE ONE YOU DID ANSWER IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE YOU'LL MAKE
THEM WHOLE BLOOD TO RUN INTO MY
OFFICE AFTER I GET OUT OF HERE.
AND SAY THEY'RE NOT BEING MADE
WHOLE BUTTE. WELL I THINK WE'RE
I THINK WE'RE NOT REVISITING
THE TRIGGER CUTS AND THAT WAY I
THINK. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN- PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INCREASES SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
TRIAL COURT AS WELL AS YOU SEE
AND SEE IF YOU WERE PROVIDED.
ADDITIONAL A FUNDING- BOTH ONE
TIME AND ONGOING- DOESN'T
EXACTLY MATCH UP TO THOSE
TRIGGER CUTS- BUT BUT THERE
ARE. THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP AND SUPPORT
THOSE- ENTITIES. BLACKROCK I'M
OKAY WITH THAT BECAUSE THE
MONEY THAT THEY WANTED BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE. I MADE SURE THEY
GOT IT BACK BUT IT MAY REFLECT
JUVENILE COURTS- TEEN COURTS
ARE DRUG COURT VETERANS COURTS
HOMELESS COURTS. AND THAT'S HOW
WE GAVE THE MONEY BACK SO IT.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE KIND OF
DOING IT THE SAME WAY. SO THE
I'M GOOD WITH THAT. THANK YOU
THANK. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO
TO MISTER LEE AND THEN MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IT IS A GREAT PRIVILEGE WILL
SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE DURING
A VERY CHALLENGING TIME I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
EMPHASIS ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY THOSE
THE TOPICS THAT W HOPE TO DEL
I HOPE TO DELVIN IN FUTURE
HEARINGS. OF WHAT I WANT TO ASK
AND RESPECT MY COLLEAGUES IS
ONLY ONE QUESTION AND IT IS
ABOUT THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR SAY FREE OPENING DURING
SCHOOLS I'M GONNA PREFERENCE AS
TO WHY I ASK THIS QUESTION BUT
ANSWER FIRST OR I'LL ASK IT
FIRST AND ELABORATE ON IT. HE'S
IN THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL THE INCENTIVE GRANTS
THERE IS THE DATES OF FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH AND MARCH FIFTEENTH
FOR RESPECTIVE GRADES TO MEET
THESE PLANS. NOW I AM CONCERNED
THAT IT CREATES AN ARTIFICIAL
PRESSURE POINT AN ARTIFICIAL
DEADLINE FOR SCHOOLS TO BE
MEETING THESE PLANS AS A
LABORATORY A LAB RATED BY MANY
MY COLLEAGUES SAFETY OPENING IS
A HUGE PRIORITY NOT OFFER
CONSTITUENTS. ARE EDUCATORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BUT I AM VERY
WORRIED THAT WE ARE. MOTIVATING
A PLAN BY THE CALENDAR AND NOT
BY THE SCIENCE OR DATA SHOWING
WE ARE CURRENTLY APPROACHING
THE THIRTY THOUSAND DEATHS IN
THE STATE. WE ARE IN WHAT SOME
OF THE DARKEST PERIOD OF THIS
CRISIS OF THIS PANDEMIC.
WITHOUT AND PERHAPS HOPEFULLY
WILL GET BETTER EVEN THOUGH THE
VACCINE IS ROLLING OUT RIGHT
NOW. AND JUST AS AN
ILLUSTRATION IN MY HOME COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY. IT USED
TO BE THAT WHEN YOU HIT READ
HERE YOU CAN MAKE A PLAN FOR
TWO WEEKS AND THEN REOPEN THE
SCHOOLS. WELL THE ENTIRE STATE
IS ESSENTIALLY IN SUCH A DEEP
PURPLE THAT WE HAVE RUN OUT OF
COLORS. THAT WE ARE IN SUCH A
DEEP STATE. THAT I AM REALLY
AFRAID THAT WE ARE MOVING. THAT
WE'RE MOVING INTO A STATE
WHERE- ARE MOTIVATED BY THE
DATE RATHER THAN WHAT THE
SCIENCE IS AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING. SO IT IS PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE TO ALL OUR
CONSTITUENCIES AND TO US. THAT
THE SAFETY OF THE EDUCATORS OF
THE STUDENTS AND THE FAMILIES
ARE PRIORITIZE WHEN WE ARE
REOPENING THE SCHOOLS. SO
THAT'S REALLY MY QUESTION IS.
WHY ARE WE PUTTING THE PRESSURE
DATE OF FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH AND
MARCH. AS I FAVOR SIXTEENTH AND
MARCH FIFTEENTH. TO PRESSURE
THE SCHOOLS TO MAKE THESE PLANS
WHEN IN FACT WE'VE HEARD THAT
THERE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT
CONSULTATION. IS IT. BY FEDERAL
LAW IS THERE SOMETHING
DICTATING THAT WORRIES THAT A
PERIOD. IN WHICH WE CAN
NEGOTIATE AND FIGURE OUT SO
LET'S NOT ARTIFICIAL PRESSURE
POINT. THANK YOU FOR THE- THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I'M I
THINK THE DATE- ILLUSTRATES THE
URGENCY OF THE MATTER- AND HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION SEES IT-
THAT SAID AGAIN- I THINK THIS
IS A POINT OF CONVERSATION. AND
WE HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN WITH-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND TRADE
TRYING TO INFORM THE PLAN BASED
ON WHAT WE HEAR. THE FEEDBACK
AND SO I THINK THAT MORE
CONVERSATIONS NEED TO HAPPEN.
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL AS A
WHOLE. I THANK YOU FOR BEING OF
THE FEEDBACK AND REALLY HOPE
THEY'LL KEEP CONSULTING THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE. IN MAKING
DECISIONS BECAUSE THE LAST
THING YOU WANT IS TO FEEL THAT
THE SCHOOLS MUST MAKE AN
IMPROPER INAPPROPRIATE PLAN TO
GET THE MONEY BECAUSE- SCHOOL
REOPENING SAFELY IS A HUGE
PRIORITY RIGHT NOW. SO OFTEN
THE FEEDBACK AND WORKING WITH
YOU. THANK YOU WERE GONNA GO
MISSED MCCARTY IN THE MISS
RUBIO. THANK YOU JUST SOME
OVERALL COMMENTS AND LATE IN
THE DAY- ON THE BUDGET IN
EDUCATION BUT BEFORE I GET
THERE I WANTED TO. JUST ADD ON
TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
MONICA CHAIR OF STEP THREE
TALKED ABOUT. THE MONIES FOR
OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT IS A
FABULOUS USE OF ONE TIME MONEY-
THE GOVERNOR IS BEING LAUDED BY
USING ONE TIME MONEY- WITH
THIS. SURPLUS FOR ONE TIME
PURPOSES WE KNOW THAT IF WE
WANT TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
LOOK AT THE WILD FIRES WE LOOK
AT THE NUMBER ONE. ISSUE AS HE
SAID IT'S MOBILE SOURCES AND
CARS WE KNOW WE WANT TO GET
MORE. ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD WHAT DO YOU NEED ME MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO. I'D LIKE TO
USE THAT MONEY TO DRESS ARE
ISSUES LIKE ADDICTION
HOMELESSNESS AND SO FORTH BUT
THOSE REQUIRE. LONG UNDERGOING
EXPENDITURES AND THIS IS A ONE
TIME POT SO THIS IS A OF A
PEACE OF MIND IT. IS AN
APPROPRIATE- ALLOCATION THE
BUDGET I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE MR RAMA SAYS
OF COURSE SACRAMENTO OUR
INDUSTRY HERE IS STATE CAPITOL
STATE GOVERNMENT SO OUR STATE
WORKERS I TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF
A HAIR CUT LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
WE TAKE A LOOK AT REVISITING
THAT ON THE EDUCATION BUDGET
WE'LL GET AT THIS IN GREATER
DETAIL SB TO IN THE COMING
MONTHS BUT- OVERALL IT'S A
REALLY POSITIVE BUDGET FOR
PUBLIC EDUCATION. THAT'S ALWAYS
OUR TOP PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY OUR TOP PER DURING
KOBE TO GET OUR STUDENTS BACK
TO SCHOOL IN A SAFE MANNER. I
DO WANT TO NOTE TWO COMMENTS
BRIEFLY ON THE- THE PROPOSAL- I
KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES TALK ABOUT THAT AT SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THING IT'S
NOT. NECESSARILY DOABLE WE
DON'T WANT THIS MONEY JUST TO
GO AS A WINDFALL TO THE WEALTHY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN THE APPROPRIATE
COLORS WE WANT US TO BE
UTILIZED TO MAKE SURE. IT WORKS
AND YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE IF TO
BILLIONS RIGHT NUMBER IF YOU
LOOK AT A BUDGET FOR SCHOOLS
IT'S YOU KNOW WITH ALL THE
LOCAL AND- FEDERAL STATE MONEY
NOR NEARLY A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IS TWO BILLION GONNA
MAKE SOMEBODY ACTOR NOT. I AM
ALSO CONCERNED TOO. THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT DO NOTHING- WHEN THEY GET
TO THE APPROPRIATE COLOR. NOT
PURPLE BUT EITHER RED. OR
ORANGE- I'D LIKE TO REVISIT
MAYBE SOME TYPE OF REQUIREMENT.
THAT IF THEY'RE IN THE
APPROPRIATE SMALLER COHORTS
LIKE WE HEAR FROM. THE
EDUCATORS THAT WE HAVE SOMETIME
A REQUIREMENT THAT WE DO GET
SOME- INSTRUCTION OTHERWISE.
THIS THAT THEY'RE LEARNING LAS
BRIDGET WILL JUST EXASPERATED
SPECIALLY SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WERE STUDENTS
ALREADY. I LEFT BEHIND- SOME
SOME SOME UNFINISHED BUSINESS
THAT WE WENT TO ADDRESS IN THE
EARLY EDUCATION SPACE AND OF.
MY COLLEAGUE WHO LEFT ALREADY
MISS REYES MENTION THIS. THE
ADDITIONAL SLOTS ARE POSITIVE
WITH THE PROP SIXTY FOUR-
MARIJUANA TAX MONEY WE
APPRECIATE THAT FORTY SEVEN
HUNDRED BUT THERE'S STILL. A
GREAT NEED AS WELL AS THE RATE
REFORM. THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN- FINANCIALLY ON THE
BUBBLE. EVEN MORE SO IT BECAUSE
OF IT AND SO HAVING- WORKERS
THAT CAN CERTAINLY LEAVING
GETTING MAKE MORE IN N. OUT
BURGER COSCO- WHY WOULD THEY
STAY WORKING IN THE- IN THE
CHILD CARE FIELD WE GET. SO
MUCH OF THIS TURN OVER WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- ADDRESS
THAT AND TAKE CARE OF OUR THEY
DID THE WORK FORCE THERE WHO
OBVIOUSLY WE NOW. ARE
PROFOUNDLY WOMEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR- LASTLY I JUST WENT ON
THE U. C. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
I'M VERY EXCITED THE GOVERNOR-
PRIORITIZE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WHICH IS A BILL
THAT I'M WORKING ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. THIS COULD BE
THE FINALLY THE YEAR THAT WE
HAVE UNIVERSAL ACCESS FOR ALL
THREE FOUR YEAR OLDS. PRE K. IN
CALIFORNIA. WE THINK IT'S GOOD
FOR A PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND
ALLOWS US TO. UTILIZE OTHER
MONIES TO. BOOST OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ZERO THREE THREE AS WELL SO
WE THINK IT'S A WIN WIN WIN
LOOKING AT. AS THE GOVERNOR
ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT THE WHOLE
CHILD- OVER ALSO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE CERTAINLY POSITIVE
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THE HIGHER
END. PIECES AS WELL- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK
AT IS. THE UC AND CSU. ARE
SAYING THAT THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
THE- ADDRESS FOR THE CUTS TOOK
LAW YEAR- WE DON'T KNOW IF THE
FEDERAL MONEY COMING IN IS.
THAT CAN BACK FILL THAT TO MAKE
THOSE SYSTEMS HOLE BUT WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO LOOK AT THE
HIGHER RATE NEEDS. WE ARE VERY
PLEASED THAT THE GOVERNOR
FOCUSES ON FINANCIAL AID
SIGNIFICANTLY. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE STUDENTS ARE HURTING.
ONE ISSUE THAT WE REALLY WANTED
TO GET IN HIS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS. OLDER MANY TIMES WITH
FAMILIES. THOSE ARE THE
STUDENTS WE THOUGHT TAKE TAKE A
STEP BACK FROM GOING TO COLLEGE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. WHEN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEM HELP THEM. GET
BACK TO THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
A STUDY SO. WILL CERTAINLY
ENGAGE OF THIS IN THE SUB TO
PROCESS IN THE COMING MONTHS
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO. MISS
RUBIO AND INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO
SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE TOUGH WORK
AHEAD- BUT I DID HAVE A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION REGARDING- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IS OUR EARLIER.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
INFORMATION GIVEN TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS I
HAVE THREE QUESTIONS NUMBER
ONE- YOU STATED THAT- THEIR
WORDS CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW LONG THE CONVERSATIONS
WERE- WHEN YOU HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. HI I'M
GONNA TURN THAT TOO DIFFICULT.
HI JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO I CAN SPEAK TO
THOSE MEETINGS THAT I'VE BEEN A
PART OF AND WE SPEAK WITH MANY
SUPERINTENDENTS- AS PART OF
LARGER CONVENING- I KNOW THAT
MANY THE SUPERINTENDENTS IN THE
STATE ALSO SPEAK WITH OUR-
STAFF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THOSE MEETINGS SPECIFICALLY BUT
I'M IN MANY OF THE VENUES THAT
I'VE BEEN IN THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S IT'S BEEN AN
HOUR TWO HOURS- DEPENDING ON
WHAT THE VENUE IS. NO I'M
SPECIFICALLY ASKING ABOUT THE
PROPOSALS- THAT YOU STATED
EARLIER YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT'S PRIOR
TO RELEASING THE- THE PROJECT
OR THE INFORMATION ON- FOR THE
SCHOOLS. I CAN'T SPEAK TO ANY
SPECIFIC MEETINGS I'VE BEEN HAD
THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN A PART OF I
KNOW THAT THERE WERE MANY
MEETINGS WITH GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
STAFF AS WELL STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION STUFF. RIGHT WILL BUT
THAT'S HE QUESTION WITH- WHEN
MY OUR COLLEAGUE- STATED THAT
WE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THEY STATED
THAT THEY HAD NOT HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS. YOU SAID YES BUT
NOW YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU
DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONVERSATIONS.
THAT THERE WERE MORE WOMEN.
THAT THERE WERE MULTIPLE
RESERVATIONS BUT YOU WERE NOT
PART OF ANY OF THEM. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SPOKEN WITH
THE SUPERINTENDENTS AND- WORK
WITH THEM PRIOR TO PUTTING OUT
THE PROPOSAL. I PERSONALLY WAS
NOT INVOLVED IN ANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUAL CONVERSATIONS I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THOSE. OKAY WELL
THEN AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS WHAT KIND OF INPUT
DID YOU GET FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S. SO THE
SUPERINTENDENTS DISCUSSED AND
SOME OF THE BARRIERS THAT
THEY'RE FACING IN TERMS OF RE
OPENING AND CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAD AROUND- SAFETY AND WHAT
SOME OF THEIR NEEDS FOR. BUT
IT'S NOT THE INPUT THATWAS- UP
WORKED INTO THE PROPOSAL. YES
THOSE FOR A LONG TIME WE'VE
WE'VE RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM
MANY NOT JUST SUPERINTENDENTS
THE OTHER FOLKS- IN THE
EDUCATION FIELD AROUND I'M
NEEDING MORE CLARITY AROUND
TESTING- NEEDING MORE SUPPORT
AROUND TESTING WHICH THE
PROPOSAL ALSO PROVIDES- AND
ADDITIONALLY NEEDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO MEET SOME OF THE
NEEDS- AROUND HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OKAY WELL THEN THE THIRD
QUESTION IS- DID YOU PROVIDE
THE PROPOSAL A DRAFT OF THE
PROPOSAL PRIOR TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SO THAT THEY
COULD- LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
PRIOR TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU. ARE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. YES SO AGAIN
I'M I WAS NOT PART OF THOSE
SPECIFIC CONVERSATION SO I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT- I KNOW
THAT- AT THE VERY LEAST- THE
PROPOSALS WERE DISCUSSED AND
OVERS DOOMBEN CALLS I DON'T
KNOW IF PAPER WAS. RIGHT IN THE
REASONS ACT- WE BRING THIS UP
IS BECAUSE WE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH SUPERINTENDENTS THAT WERE
FRUSTRATED I. ONLY HAVE ELEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT
AND THEY'RE NOT THE BIG. OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE LAUSD BUT
WE DID HAVE A CONVERSATION AS
PART O THE L. A. COUNTY
CAUCUS- SPECIFICALLY WITH THAT-
SUPERINTENDENT PETER AND HE
SAID THAT THERE WERE NO
CONVERSATIONS. ON THAT THEY HAD
A CALL A FIFTEEN MINUTE CALL
AND THAT THERE WAS NO NOTHING
PROVIDED TO THEM- IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE INPUT. AND
THE REASON THAT I'M I'M YOU
KNOW BRING THESE ISSUES UP IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SAY THAT
YOU'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THESE FOLKS IT JUST SEEMS LIKE-
THEY WERE PART OF THE PROCESS
AND THE REALITY IS THAT THEY
WEREN'T. I'M NOT HEARING ANY.
KIND OF INFORMATION FROM THE
RESPONSES AS TO THEM BEING PART
OF THIS WHOLE ENTIRE PROCESS- I
CAN TELL YOU AS A FORMER
TEACHER AND A FULL FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER WHEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS DON'T HAPPEN-
WHAT HAPPENS IS. THE
STAKEHOLDERS IF YOU WILL ARE
NOT- PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AND THEREFORE CANNOT YOU KNOW
PROPERLY IMPLEMENT ANY
PROPOSALS OR ANY KIND OF-
POLICIES THAT WE PUT FORWARD TO
THEM SO. I'M MY FRUSTRATION IS
THAT WE GET GENERAL- RESPONSES
AND IN REALITY I'M SITTING HERE
TRYING TO HERE AND TRY TO BE.
HELPFUL TO THE PROCESS BY WHEN
WE DON'T HEAR ACTUAL FACTS AS
TO WHAT WAS HAPPENING IT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR ME BECAUSE I
JUST FEEL LIKE I'M WASTING MY
TIME I DON'T WANT TO WASTE MY
TIME I WANT TO BE AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT. OF THIS BOB WITH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND IF WE
DON'T GET CORRECT INFORMATION
THEN YOU'RE JUST THEN YOU MIGHT
AS WELL EMAIL ME THE
INFORMATION. I AM HEARING FROM
MY SUPERINTENDENTS-
SPECIFICALLY MY DISTRICT WIDE
ALLEY UST OF NOT IN MY DISTRICT
HOWEVER I AM PART OF THE ALLEY-
DELEGATION AND WHEN THEY'RE
FRUSTRATED I CAN ONLY ASSUME.
THAT THE OTHER SUPERINTENDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE I AGAIN I
CAN SPEAK FROM MY OWN
SUPERINTENDENTS AND THEY'RE ALL
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE
GETTING IS NOT SUFFICIENT FOR
THEM TO- ACTUALLY HAVE A PLAN
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN. AND THE I
FEEL LIKE EVERY SINGLE DAY OR
EVERY. WEEK THEY'RE HAVING TO
YOU KNOW REINVENT SOMETHING WAS-
SENT OVER BY THE-
ADMINISTRATION AND- SO I ASK. I
AM PLEASED THAT WHEN WE ASK
QUESTIONS PLEASE HAVE SPECIFIC
ANSWERS NOT GENERAL ANSWERS AS
TO YOU KNOW THERE WERE MANY
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING. THAT'S
NOT HELPFUL WHEN WE HAVE TO
RETURN TO OUR DISTRICTS. AND
REPORT BACK AS TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING- AS PART OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- FOR EXAMPLE TODAY- I
DON'T HAVE ANY REAL TANGIBLE
INFORMATION I CAN BE TRYING TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S ALL I CAN
SAY IS PLEASE READ THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO US. MY JOB AS AS I SEE IT IS
TO BE AN ADVOCATE FOR. NOT JUST
MIGHT THE SUPERINTENDENT OR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY AREA BY
TWO FOR THE WHOLE STATE AND IF
I'M NOT. GETTING THAT
INFORMATION FROM MY BUDGET
PROCESS THEN THEN I CAN JUST
SEND THEM THE BUDGET AND SAY
YOU KNOW HERE READ IT- I
THOUGHT THE PURPOSE OF THESE.
HEARINGS IS TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
DIALOGUE TO WHERE WE CAN TAKE
BACK TO OUR DISTRICT SPECIFIC
INFORMATION. AGAIN I CAN READ
THE YOU KNOW THE BUDGET AND I
CAN HAVE THEM READ IT BUT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THESE HEARINGS. SO I
AM FRUSTRATED OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
I CANNOT RESPOND TO MY
SUPERINTENDENTS. BY MOVING
FORWARD SINCE IS OUR FIRST-
BUDGET HEARING I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU HOW TO BETTER ASK
QUESTIONS TO GET THOSE DIRECT
THEM FROM A- DIRECT. OUT
RESPONSES AS OPPOSED TO SOME
GENERAL COMMENTS THAT DO US- NO
GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE TRAILER BILL IS OUT ON THE
FOR THE TWO BILLION. AND WE
LOOK FOR TO HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND- THAT
THE BACK AND FORTH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. RIGHT NOW I
APPRECIATE THAT HOWEVER THE
FRUSTRATION IS WITH WITHIN THE
ACTUAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE TO- FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO USE THIS- AND SOLD. IT
FOR FUTURE- I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
AGAIN PLEASE DON'T GIVE ME SOME
GENERAL INFORMATION AS TO WE
HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS. I WOULD
LIKE SOME SPECIFICS AS TO YOU
KNOW WHO YOU SPOKE WITH AND
WHEN AND HOW LONG AND- WHAT-
WHAT ROLLED IT. PLAY BEST AS
INPUT INTO THE POLICIES AND THE
BUDGET. TRAILER THAT WE'RE
PUTTING DOWN AND HOW ARE WE
GOING TO SUPPORT THEM SO THAT
THEY CAN BEST. USE THAT MONEY
TO SUPPORT OUR OUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE. AND I DON'T NEED TO SEE IT
AGAIN BUT I WILL ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF OUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
WOULD JUST GET UP BURKE JUST
QUICK COMMENT TO MY COLLEAGUES
WILL BE ALSO THERE'S SOME I
WOULD RECOMMEND THEM TO IF
THERE'S A WAY THAT YOU COULD
PUT THAT IN WRITING IN THE
SYSTEM TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AT THE COULD APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK FROM NOT JUST ON THEIR
END BROADER COMMITTEE BUT ALSO
FOR. SUB TO AS WE DELVE INTO
THIS ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE
TAKING WERE ASK TO BE
CONSIDERING. TAKING EARLY
ACTION THIS MATTER THANK YOU-
WE WILL NOW GO TO THIS- BY
THEIR FIRST NAME TO THE LIST TO
BETTER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS VERY CRITICAL
BUDGET DURING WHAT IS PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT TIME THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING
RIGHT NOW- THIS IS OUR BUDGET.
THIS IS MASSIVE. THERE IS NO
NETFLIX FOR ME THIS PAST
WEEKEND. NOW WHAT I'M FEARFUL
OF IS THAT WE ARE OF NOT
PRIORITIZING SOME KEY ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY IN THE
THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. MY
KEY QUESTIONS AROUND PRIORITIES
ARE AROUND PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFFS THAT THIS HAS THIS
ISSUE HAS COME UP JUST YET.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
CHILD CARE AND THE RESOURCES
THAT WERE PROVIDING TO THE BACK
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS- WHO
HAVE REALLY BEEN HIT HARD THIS
PANDEMIC. SO AROUND PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS. THERE'S
ONE THING THAT IS CLEARLY
MISSING FROM THIS BUDGET AND
NOT HIS PRIDE TO PRIORITIZING
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE BEING AFFECTED AND
REALLY ENDANGERED BY PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS. AND THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET
THERE WERE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED TO COW- THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ADMINISTERING GRANTS TO CITIES
COUNTIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
TRIBES TO HELP PROVIDE RELIEF
RESULTING FROM PUBLIC POWER
SHUT OFF EVENTS. THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY HIT MY
DISTRICT HARD. THERE'S BEEN
DOZENS OF PUBLIC A P. S. P.
ADVANCE SINCE NOVEMBER. ON
THANKSGIVING DAY AND CHRISTMAS
DAY. IN THE WINTER IN MY
DISTRICT AND I WOULD IMAGINE A
MOST DISTRICTS THE SUN GOES
DOWN EARLY. AND WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS IN OUR CITIES I'M
GETTING CALLS FROM OUR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS THAT ARE SAYING
THAT IT'S DARK AND THE POWER
SHUT OFF AND INTERSECTIONS ARE
BLACK WHEN PEOPLE ARE WALKING
THROUGH AND PEOPLE ARE DRIVING
HOME FROM WORK. CAN YOU LET ME
KNOW GIVEN THAT P. S. P. S.
EVENTS ARE HAPPENING MORE
FREQUENTLY WHY DOES THIS BUDGET
NOT INCLUDE BETTER FUNDING TO
EQUIP OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH THE NECESSITIES AND THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED. AND THEY
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FOR
YOU AS WELL. SURE SO I THINK
THAT THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF GOOD THINGS THAT COULD BE IN
THIS BUDGET AND- AS I SAID
BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
A. COMING TO- A MUTUAL
AGREEMENT ON WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES ARE SO THAT'S
GENERALLY FOR THE THINGS THAT
YOU DON'T SEE IN THERE I'M NOT
BECAUSE THEY WERE IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK- WE NEED
TO HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON
THAT RIGHT SO WHY WAS THE
DECISION MADE TO CUT THE
FUNDING AS WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCE
MORE SHORT OFFICE THAN WE HAVE
IN PREVIOUS YEARS. AND I DON'T
KNOW THE SPECIFICS ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR- FUNDING STREAM- OR
ITEM SO I CAN HELP TO GET BACK
TO YOU GREAT THANK YOU SO THE
NEXT QUESTION IS AROUND EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND THE
BUDGET I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR THE BUDGET DOES HAVE
I'M SO REALLY GOOD PROVISIONS
THERE'S FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ABOUT FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROGRAMS TO HELP DEVELOP
EARLY EDUCATOR PROFESSIONALS
QUALITY IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT. WELL THESE ARE ALL
GREAT PROGRAMS IT'S MY
IMPRESSION THAT THE PAROLE
PROPOSAL PROVIDES TOO LITTLE
AND THE FORM OF IMMEDIATE
RELIEF FOR PROVIDERS AND FOR
PARENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING NOW
TO OPERATE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE. WHAT IT NEARLY I COME
FROM A CHILD CARE- INDUSTRY
BACKGROUND. AND THIS PANDEMIC
WERE EXPECTED TO LOSE A THIRD
IF NOT HALF OF THE INDUSTRY
THREE THOUSAND LICENSED CHILD
CARE. FAMILY PROVIDERS AND
CENTERS HAVE PERMANENTLY CLOSED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AN EARLIER
YOU SAID THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS LASER FOCUSED ON
CREATING JOBS. AND WE CANNOT
MISS THE STEP OF MAKING SURE
THAT OUR WORK FORCE HAS ACCESS
TO QUALITY EDUCATION. AT THAT
IS TRULY A PRIORITY SO CAN YOU
TELL ME WHERE IN THE BUDGET ARE
THERE PROVISIONS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF. FOR ESSENTIAL CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. AND
SPECIFICALLY. WHAT ALLOCATIONS
ARE MADE. FOR MIDDLE CLASS
WORKING FAMILIES THERE ARE LOTS
OF FUNDING AND RESOURCES- BUT
TYPICALLY NOT FOR MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES WHO DON'T QUALIFY SO
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WILL MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES. QUALIFY FOR IN
TERMS OF CHILD CARE. THANK YOU
THE ONE THING I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT FIRST IS THAT WE ARE
EXPECTING ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON CHILD CARE- WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK AT BECAUSE- THAT
INFORMATION ISN'T AVAILABLE YET
BUT I THINK TO YOUR POINT. THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
TO COME UP WITH APLAN ON HOW
TO GET ALLOCATED TO MEET SOME
OF THOSE NEEDS- I WILL HAVE TO
TURN OVER THE REST OF YOUR
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE
DETAILS OF WHAT'S INCLUDED- IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE SPECIFICS SO
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO FROM ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES. THE FINANCE.
YEAH YEAH YOU PROBABLY. HI
JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO I CAN SPEAK TO-
SOME OF THE INVESTMENTS BOTH ON
THE EDUCATION SIDE AS WELL AS
THE US DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES SIDE AND HAVE WON MY
COLLEAGUES PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION IF NECESSARY ON THE
PERMISSIBLE SERVICES SIDE. FOR
CHILD CARE THE DE IN ADDITION
TO THE- THE FUNDING FOR THE
SLOTS IS AS YOU MENTIONED I'M
WITH THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOUR AND-
PROVIDER M. KOPA NINETEEN.
SUPPORT AND- WE ARE STILL
WORKING ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- AROUND FOR HOW THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE ALLOCATED- IN
ADDITION WE HAVE- SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES ON THE T. CASE SIDE-
WHICH PROVIDES AND PRESCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF INCOME- SO THE
FIFTY FIVE MILLION WOULD BE A
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE PROVIDER
SIDE OF THINGS. AND THEN THE
TEACHING LESSONS WOULD REALLY
BE FOCUSED ON- THE PRESCHOOL
ACCESS- FOR A BROAD RANGE OF
FEELINGS FOR A BROAD RANGE OF
INCOME LEVELS. GREAT THANK YOU
AND ZERO TO FOUR ZERO TO THREE.
CHILD CARE ESERVER RESOURCES
WELL THERE. SO THE RESOURCES
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE FAMILIES WOULD BE
SPECIFIC TO THAT THE FUNDS
PROVIDED- FOR INCREASED LOTS OF
THE CANNABIS FUNDS- THOSE ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANY AGE- FORWARD
THAT TO CASE PFIZER MAJORITY
FOR AND FOCUS ON FOUR YEAR OLD-
AND THEN THE FUNDS FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS- WOULD BE AT YOU
KNOW GETTING. TV DION ON THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY FOR
THOSE ONE THING I'D ALSO LIKE
TO POINT OUT IS THAT IN OCTOBER
THE LEGISLATURE- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE FORM OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- TO BACK FILLED
THE REDUCTION OF- FAMILY FEES
FOR PROVIDERS THAT THAT WE
WAVE. AND THEN IN ADDITION
ANOTHER EIGHTY MILLION TO
FURTHER FUND- THE INCREASED
COST OF CARE ASSOCIATED- WITH
SERVING SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AS
WELL AS EXTEND- THE TEMPORARY
SLOTS PROVIDED FOR SOCIAL
WORKER FAMILIES. GREAT THANK
YOU AND MY LAST QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH THE RESOURCES AND THE
BUDGET- I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
RESOURCES IN THE BUDGETS ARE
BEING ALLOCATED. IN PREVIOUS
YEARS THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND RAPE CRISIS
CENTERS NOW WE KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED THE
PERFECT STORM IN WHICH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND CHILD ABUSE IS
ONLY INCREASING. SO IT IS VITAL
AND IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE RE OPEN
BECAUSE WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RETURN TRUE
NUMBER OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
CHILD ABUSE CASES THAT ARE
HAPPENING SO. IN THE BUDGET
WHAT RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED.
CAN I TURN THAT OVER TO ONE OF
MY EIGHTY JUST. THIS IS ADAM
DORSEY DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO-
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES THAT
IS- THERE ARE TWO- HELP RESPOND
TO URGENT AND CRITICAL NEED TO
BE GOT OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM- OPERATED BY THE
COUNTIES- THAT YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW CAN RESPOND- YOU KNOW IN
IN CASES OF CRISIS- AND- IN THE
HOMES PER IN THE- COVERAGE
PROGRAM WE HAVE- YOU KNOW
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE FOR
EMERGENCY NEEDS. AND SO THERE'S
A NUMBER OF AREAS- AND THEN YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION TO THOSE ARE
THOSE OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND THEN. WE'VE MADE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BUDGET- YOU
KNOW IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
FEW TIMES NOW- THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROPOSAL- TO TRY TO. YOU
KNOW MAKE THOSE SYSTEMS MORE
ROBUST AND SO- THOSE ARE SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE KIND OF
CORE PROGRAMS IN IN RECENT
INVESTMENTS IN IN THAT AREA. SO
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR DOMESTIC. VIOLENCE AND RAPE
CENTER SPECIFICALLY. I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT- AT THAT PARTICULAR
POINT BUT I THINK THAT- UNLESS
THERE'S SOMEONE HERE THAT CAN
ANSWER IT WE WILL HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT. GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GONNA GO
MISTER BENNETT. AND THEN I GOT
A COUPLE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. I
WELCOME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE ON THE OF BUDGET
COMMITTEE DURING THESE TRYING-
IN CHALLENGING TIMES- AND
SUBSEQUENT TO VI<c.cyan> INDICATING</c>
TO CHAIRMAN KIDDING THAT I HAD
A QUESTION ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
MY QUESTION WAS ASKED BY ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES SO I HAVE NO
QUESTION FOR THE L. L. A. STAFF
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
STAFF. BUT I WILL JUST MAKE ONE
BRIEF COMMENT AND THAT IS THAT.
THE WINDOW TO TAKE EFFECTIVE
ACTION ON CLIMATE CHANGE IS
FAST CLOSING. AND AS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM STATED WE NEED TO
MAKE A STEADY COMMITMENT TO
REDUCING CARBON EMISSIONS. AND
TO ADDRESSING WILDFIRES. AND I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR- FOR TO BUILD THE
POLITICAL SUPPORT THAT WE NEED.
SO THAT WE HAVE A MORE STEADY
AND SUSTAINABLE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING SOURCE AND OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES. IN THE BUDGET
SO WE CAN MAKE THAT STEADY
COMMITMENT THAT WE REALLY DID
IT BUT WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
AN THAT IS ESSENTIAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GREAT THANK YOU SIR-
COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANTED TO
START WITH. HELLO ON IN JUSTIFY
YOU COULD EXPAND AND FEEL FREE
TO HAVE YOUR STAFF EXPAND. AT
THE UC SAID IN YOUR HIGHLIGHTS
AROUND THE SCHOOL OPENING
PROPOSAL YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE- TIME LINES THAT WERE SENT
AND THEN ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR ON YOU OR YOUR STAFF
COMMENTS AROUND THE TAX REFUND
PROPOSAL HOW THAT COULD BE. A
MORE TARGETED AND ALSO- DID
WANT TO HEAR WHETHER THE STAFF
DID LOOK AT THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE AND WHETHER THERE
COULD BE A FURTHER TARGETING OF
THOSE- PROPOSAL THAT PROPOSAL
AS WELL. YES MISTER THANK YOU-
ON THE- SCHOOL RE OPENING I
THINK- I WILL ASK MY COLLEAGUE
EDGAR CABRAL HE'S ON TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON OUR
THINKING AROUND THAT. RALPH IN
THE STUDIO WITH OFFICE FROM
EMPLOYMENT. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
BERKELEY TALKING YOU SHOULD ON
THE SCREEN. OKAY GREAT-I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO START BURBANK
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT'S- IF CONVICTED PROPOSAL
HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN I COMPLETED
AND- COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH OUR UNIONS BY.
FEBRUARY FIRST- AND- THAT WOULD
BE BASED ON SOME ADDITIONAL
ITEMS THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
IT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED
UNDERSTANDING IT SHOULD BE
RELEASED- AND THINGS. LIKE IT'S
VERY VERY SHORT WINDOW FOR A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO BE ABLE TO
REVIEW THAT BOB THOSE PLANS AND
THEN BEGINNING WITHIN TWO WEEKS
FILE TO BE OPENED SCHOOLS BUT
THE BIGGEST THING THAT WE'VE
HEARD IT AGAIN THIS GRANT IS
NOT AVAILABLE YET SO WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE LISTING
CADENCES. BUT THE TESTING AT
THE BIGGEST CHANGE THAT MAYBE-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MIGHT NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE READY TO
PUT THAT ON THE MOST OF IT BUT
THEY COULD BRING STUDENTS BACK
A LEVEL THAT IS EXPECTED IN THE
PROPOSAL. SO THAT'S OUR OUR
MAIN CONCERN WE REYES- ONE
ALTERNATIVE IN OUR OLD REWARDS
TO- SLOW DOWN THAT EVEN A
LITTLE BIT SO THAT MAYBE A
MISSILE REQUIREMENTS IT'S NOT
ALL TO GIVE TO STUDENTS BUT
BROKE UP OF A HIGHER NEED
STUDENTS COMING FIRST. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN GET UP AND
RUNNING- DON'T LOOK AROUND CITY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THOSE
STUDENTS- AND THEN I WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER FOR RAMPING UP AND I
THINK ALSO SIMILARLY I THINK WE
HAVE SOME. CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CAPACITY FOR BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE KIND OF
SUPPORT MIGHT NOT MIGHT BE
NECESSARY IF- HUNDREDS OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE TRYING TO
DO THIS ALL THE TIME. TO
DEVELOP PLANS TO GET UP AND
RUNNING RIGHT AWAY. THANK YOU
JUST A IT'S THE BY HAVE YOU A
FOLLOW UP WHAT IT WHAT DID YOU.
OF THAT WERE SENT OVER BY THE
LARGE DISTRICT- OUTLINING FOR
OF THEIR- THERE CAN. YEAH SURE
WE DID REGULAR. CLARITY UNDER
OF HOW THE WORK I THINK THAT
LED DID THAT- SCHOOL DISTRICT
WERE IN ARAB GOING DEEPER
WOULDN'T ABLE TO FOR GOING I
THINK MY UNDERSTAND OF DIMINISH
PROPOSAL THAT ARE THOSE
DISTRICTS ONE BE ABLE TO FOR
ONE THEY WOULD BE TO BE MADE
THOSE- AGAIN. AND THEY WERE
RECEIVE FUNDING AND YEAH IS
THAT THEY WOULDN'T BEGIN TO
OPEN UP TO OBEY THE CASES IN
THOSE COUNTIES WERE AT LEVELS
THAT WOULD GIVE YOU THE
PROGRAM- SO THAT'S ONE THING I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT I THINK REGULAR
THOSE CONCERNS A LOOK I THINK
IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING SIDE I
THINK WITHOUT KNOWING THE EXACT
TESTING REQUIREMENTS I THINK
THERE'S A BIG- I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE CHANCES AND TRYING TO
ASSESS THE FISCAL COSTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL. IF IT'S FOR EXAMPLE
ALMOST EVERYBODY BECAUSE ONCE A
WEEK I CAN BE A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL COST- BUT I
REMEMBER THERE WAS SIX BILLION
IN ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDING
PROVIDED- IN THIS LAST BUDGET
IN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL. ABOUT
SIX BILLION COMING- SO WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE BE SOME
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE
AVAILABLE WITHOUT I THINK OUR
CONCERNS. HELLO OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE NOT REALLY JUST BECAUSE
HAWKINS TO JUST GREAT KID-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. YOUR HONOR
CAN ENSURE THE THEY CAN GET. ON
THAT MEAN TIMES DONE IN TIME
IT'S- ARE YOU JUST CONCERNS BY
COST- I JUST JUMPED. THE IN A
PLACE THAT THE BIG- THAT I WE
SHOULD MOST CONCERN. THAT. I AM
YOU HAVE TO DO THIS VERY VERY
QUICKLY SO WE CAN START YOUR
REQUEST ONLINE AND THEN THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO RE OPEN FOR
AWHILE UNTIL- CASES COME DOWN
TO THE LEVEL THAT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE SO. ANOTHER REASON
TO. A GIVEN. HOW MUCH CAPACITY
YOU'RE STRANGE RIGHT NOW-
PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
MAKE MAKE IT MORE FEASIBLE FOR
EVERYONE. OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
AND THEN- TAKE YOUR SECOND
QUESTION WAS ON THE- GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS CHECKS AND ONE
OF THE THOUGHTS THAT WE HAD
ABOUT THAT IS THAT YOU KNOW
EARLIER IN THE SPRING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR CHECKS TO
MOST TAXPAYERS MORE RECENTLY
THERE'S ANOTHER ROUND OF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR CHECKS WHICH IS
THE SAME AMOUNT THAT'S GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PROPOSAL. ONE
GROUP OF TAXPAYERS THAT HAS
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THOSE- THOSE
FEDERAL BENEFITS HAVE BEEN TO
THOSE FOLKS THAT FILE THEIR
TAXES WITH I TEN- YOU KNOW-
UNDER THE I. TEN PROCESS. AND
SO- YOU KNOW ONE TIME WE HAD AS
AN ALTERNATIVE FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER WOULD BE TO- PROVIDE
THE STIMULUS- THE GOLDEN STATE
PAYMENTS TARGETED MORE AT THOSE
TAXPAYERS THAT HAVE NOT- SO FAR
BENEFITTED FROM THOSE FEDERAL
PAYMENTS AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY
EXPANDED THE EITC PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE THOSE
TAXPAYERS WHO HAPPENED TO BE-
SOME OF OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS
AND SO I THINK. IT'S JUST
SOMETHING WE PUT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON THE- SMALL
BUSINESS- QUESTION I'M GOING TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUE. BRIAN YOU ARE
COULD- HELP WITH THAT ONE. YES
THANK YOU BRING YOU ARE AGAIN
WITH THE L. A. O. YOU KNOW I
THINK WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC ALTERNATIVES- THE
MOMENT WERE WERE STARTING TO I
JUST GETTING STARTED ANALYZING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS- WE
ARE COGNIZANT OF THE OF THE
SHORT TIMELINE THAT THEY
PROPOSE THESE GRANTS FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION SO WE DO. WELL
TO BE WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF
OVER THE COMING DAYS AND WEEKS-
HELP- IMPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND OFFER SOME
ALTERNATIVES I THINK ONE THING
THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT IS.
GETTING THAT THE FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR'S COMPOSING IS
BUILDING ON THE FIRST ROUND OF
GRANTS IT WAS ALREADY. APPROVED
TO GO OUT- LAST FALL WILL BE
YOU SEE WE CAN GET SOME
PRELIMINARY DATA ON THAT- AND
HOW THE ROLLOUT IS GOING AND
WHO'S RECEIVING THAT MONEY- TO
GAUGE WHETHER OR NOT IT COULD
BE BETTER TARGETED IN THE FIRST
ROUND. OKAY THANK YOU- SO JUST
GOING BACK TO- GOING TO
MISLEAD- I JUST WANT TO. GO
BACK TO THE SCHOOL RE OPENING
PROPOSAL- HEY CAN YOU TALK OF
MAKING THIS HOMES COULD TALK
ABOUT- THE MINDSET OF DOING AN
INCENTIVE- GRANT BASED PROGRAM-
HI I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TIME IT WOULD TAKE FOR
DISTRICTS TO APPLY. FOR THE
GRANTS AND I AM CONCERNED THAT
DISTRICTS THAT AREN'T. OPENED
WILL NOT GET THE GRANTS OR BOMB
WILL NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
GRANT SO COULD YOU. COULD YOU
WALK US THROUGH- WHY YOU
BELIEVE THAT DISTRICTS ARE
CURRENTLY CLOSE WOULD ACTUALLY
BE- PERSUADED TO APPLY AND THEN
ALSO TO OPEN UP BECAUSE OF
THIS. FUNDING SURE I'LL JUST
START AND I WILL PROBABLY PUT
THIS ONE TO JESSICA HOME- BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE IMPORTANT.
ASPECT OF THIS WHOLE THING IS
TO HAVE THAT OPEN CONVERSATION
TO UNDERSTAND THE TIMING THAT
IS REQUIRED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS- LIKE OTHER THINGS THE
NEGOTIATION AND- WE ARE
LISTENING AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE. THOSE
NEEDS ARE AND- I THINK IT MAY
BE VERY DIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT%
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS YOU SAY. SO
JESSICA IF YOU COULD PROVIDE
SOME DETAILS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CERTAINLY- SO I WOULD I
WOULD I GUESS START OF MY
COMMENTS BY GENOCIDE JUST
COMPOUNDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I WOULD SORT OF MY
COMMENTS BY JUST. PICKING UP I
THINK WHERE MISLI LEFT OFF WHEN
SHE SAYS THAT IT'S GOING TO
LOOK DIFFERENT FOR EVERY ALLEY
I THINK THAT THAT- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE'S IN A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT POSITION- AT
THIS POINT. I THINK FOR FOLKS
WHO- WHO ARE ALREADY OPEN FOR
AN- IN PERSON INSTRUCTION-
CERTAINLY THIS IS GOING TO BE
HELPFUL FOR THEM- BUT FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN INDONESIA
THE MAJORITY OF THESE FOLKS ARE
ARE IN. COUNTIES THAT HAVE
RATES THAT ARE ABOVE TWENTY
EIGHT PER HUNDRED THOUSAND-
THERE'S ALSO OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEM TO PARTICIPATE AS AS MR
CABRAL MENTIONED. AND PART OF
THIS IS- PROVIDING A SET OF
GUIDANCE AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE
MORE COME OUT PUBLICLY
TOMORROW- IN LATER IN THE WEEK-
ABOUT HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDANCE BUT- I'M PART. OF THE
ROLLOUT OF THIS NEW GUIDANCE-
IS TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT SCHOOLS UNDERSTAND AND
COMMUNITY UNDERSTAND THAT
SCHOOLS KNOW HOW TO BE SAFE.
EVEN WHEN WE HAVE YOU KNOW
RELATIVELY HIGH TRANSMISSION
RATES. I'M PART OF THE REASON
WHY AND YOU SEE THE GROUND
STRUCTURE AROUND AND THE
YOUNGER CHILDREN IN THE COHORTS
IS BECAUSE WE KNOW TAT THERE
ARE LOWER TRANSMISSION RATES
WITH THOSE STUDENTS. WE THINK
THAT- THE TIMING- IS ACTUALLY A
DOABLE FOR MANY L. A.'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT STARTING FROM ZERO
GOING INTO THIS PROCESS MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN WORKING ON RE
OPENING. SINCE LAST MARCH- AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
THINGS LIKE TESTING CADENCES
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
HEALTH AND SAFETY- AND HAVE
BEEN- YOU KNOW. CONTINUES
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT COMING BACK-
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT APPLICATION DATES
A FEBRUARY FIRST ST IN THE
MARCH FIRST AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT FOR SOME
ONLY IF IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT. TO MEET THAT
FEBRUARY FIRST DEADLINE- SO
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A MARCH
DEADLINE. ONCE YOU GET OUT
PASSED THOSE DEADLINES I'M IT
GETS MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT-
ED TO PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION PROGRAM
BECAUSE YOU'RE GETTING REALLY
CLOSE TO THE END OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR. AND SO WE REALLY FOCUSED
ON- YOU KNOW TRYING TO UTILIZE
AS MUCH OF THE REMAINING PART
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR THAT WE HAVE
THIS YEAR. AND REALLY TRYING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
THOSE WHO- AND WHO CAN GET. YOU
KNOW MAKE IT OVER THAT THAT
HURDLE- TO GET TO THAT POINT.
I'M TO GO BACK TO YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT EQUITY AND HOW
WE ARE TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE MOST HEAVILY
IMPACTED. BY THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CAN STILL BENEFIT FROM
THESE FUNDS. YOU KNOW AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE IF YOU WERE
ABOVE- THE TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND THRESHOLD YOU CAN
PARTICIPATE AND YOU CAN RECEIVE
FUNDING. AND WE KNOW THAT- EVEN
IF. YOU CANNOT OPEN FOR IN
PERSON BECAUSE YOUR RATES DON'T
GO DOWN BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR. THIS IS A REALLY
EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY AND
RESOURCES TO BEGIN PREPARING
FOR THE SUMMER AND FALL BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION- HOPEFULLY WITHIN
THIS YEAR WERE WERE PLANNING ON
IN THE FALL TO BE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AGAIN. YOU KNOW
THIS IS A FLUID SITUATION WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR IT FOR
CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO MAKE.
BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
PREPARED TO PROVIDE THE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WE NEED TO
START NOW. IN THIS CONVERSATION
SEEMED TO BE HAPPENING NOW AND
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE- BUT
REST ASSURED THAT THAT WHAT WE
HAVE OUT- IN TERMS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY GUIDANCE IS GOING TO
KEEP THEIR STUDENTS SAFE. AND
THOSE ARE ALL REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECES FOR MOST HARD HIT
COMMUNITIES AND RESOURCES THAT
THEY CAN USE AS THEY DO GO BACK
TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IN THE
SUMMER AND FALL. SO I EIGHT. WE
REALLY FEEL STRONGLY THAT THIS
IS A PROPOSAL TO HAVE A LOT OF
POSITIVES FOR EVERYONE. AND
DOES HAVE A REALLY STRONG
EQUITY FOCUS AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT MANY MANY. ELEAZAR CAN
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF. BUT
BUSINESS HOMES COULD YOU ANSWER.
IS WHAT'S THE COMPELLING PART
OF THE PROPOSAL THAT WALL ON
THIS- ENCOURAGED PEOPLE TO
APPLY AND THEN OPEN UP I DIDN'T
I DIDN'T REALLY HEAR THAT. SO
IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDS THAT
WERE PROPOSING- WHICH AGAIN ARE
A PORTION OF OTHER FEDERAL AND
STATE FUNDS THAT SCHOOLS ARE
GETTING I THINK THE OTHER
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECES OF
THIS- ARE THE NEW HEALTH AND
SAFETY GUIDANCE AGAIN WE KNOW
THAT FOR A LOT OF ELEAZAR THE
BARRIER IS. THERE'S CONCERN
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT- WHEN
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS COME BACK
SCHOOLS KNOW HOW TO BE SAFE IN
THIS NEW GUIDANCE IS REALLY
ABOUT PROVIDING THAT LEVEL OF
COMFORT FOR FOLKS TO KNOW THAT
THEY CAN TRUST THAT THE SCHOOL-
ENVIRONMENT IS A SAFE ONE WE
ALSO HAVE- SELECTION OF AND-
AS- HEALTH AND SAFETY- STUDIES
ON CODED TO GO OUT TO KIND OF.
GIVE OUR BACK UP ON WHAT THE-
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCES TO SUPPORT
A PROPOSAL IN ADDITION WE HAVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
ALLEVIATE- WHO HAVE BARRIERS
AROUND THINGS LIKE TESTING HOW
DO THEY SET UP A TESTING-
PROTOCOL WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE COMING OUT
THERE. SO REALLY WE HAVE
MULTIPLE COLORS BUT RECALLING
THEM TO TRY TO ADDRESS HESE
BARRIERS THAT- ELEAZAR BRYN
TENDANCE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION FOLKS HAVE IDENTIFIED
FOR US IS BEING BARRIERS TO
GOING BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. AND THEN ON. HOW
FOR HAVE THE NEW HOGAN FIFTY
GARDENS GUIDELINES COME OUT.
ARE THEY WILL BE OUT THIS WEEK
THEY WILL BE ON DISPLAY OKAY
YOUR GRIEF YES WE'VE BEEN
HEARING THAT SINCE OUR HEARING
TWO MONTHS AGO SO THEY ARE.
COMING UP THIS WEEK. THEY ARE
COMING OUT THIS WEEK. WHICH IS
WHICH IS GREAT- I THINK THAT IS
I COMPLETELY. AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THAT IS A CRITICAL. PIECE
AND I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM MY
DISTRICT BOTH LARGE AND SMALL.
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING FOR- MORE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE AND IS IT IS
NOT GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE- DIRECTIVES RATHER THAN
SORT OF. THE CURRENT GUIDANCE
WHICH IS WHICH I WOULD I WOULD
SORT OF. IS MORE LIKE A MENU OF
OPTIONS. YEAH I'M YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO SPEAK TO
INDIVIDUAL PIECES OF THE
GUIDANCE BUT I WILL SAY THAT
THINGS LIKE TESTING CADENCES
THOSE ARE VERY EXPLICITLY
STATED IN THE GUIDANCE- AND WE
DO REQUIRE THAT IF YOU DO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT THAT YOU MUST
PARTICIPATE IN THIS TESTING
CADENCES- SO THAT THE FUNDING
AND THE AND THE- THE GUIDANCE
WORK TOGETHER- AND THAT AND
SUPPORT EACH OTHER IN IN.
PROVIDING YOU KNOW INCREASED-
SAFETY. THANK THANK YOU AND
THEN JUST JUST DUMB IN TERMS OF
THE GRANTS VERSUS JUST
APPROPRIATIONS WALKED. WATER
WHY MAKE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRAPPED FOR TIME ACTUALLY.
APPLY FOR THIS ONE I JUST GIVEN
THE MONEY IF THEY ACTUALLY
PERFORM ACT YOU KNOW A. B. C.
TASKS. THE APPLICATION PROCESS
IS ACTUALLY VERY SIMPLE- AND
SHOULD NOT BE AN OVERLY
CUMBERSOME- I THINK THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THE BIGGEST CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE HEARD IN THE- NEXT
FEW DAYS THAT WE'VE HAD THE
LANGUAGE OUT IS YOU KNOW.
GETTING AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
CONTRACTS DONE- BUT ALL THAT A
LED HAS TO DO IN ORDER TO APPLY
FOR THE FUNDS IS PROVIDE A COPY
OF THEIR SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN- AS
WELL AS THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT TO THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION- BY
THE DATE SPECIFIED IF THEY DO
THAT THEY'RE DONE THEY'RE
APPLIED TO COUNTY OFFICE WILL
SEND INTO CVD. AND CVD WILL
PROVIDE THEM- WITH THE GRANT
AMOUNT VERY IN IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS SO IT'S A VERY QUICK
PROCESS IN A VERY SIMPLE
PROCESS. WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO RETURN HERE AND FOR
THIS COMMITTEE THAT SOMETHING'S
A SIMPLE PROCESS IT'S- VERY
RARELY ENDS UP BEING THE CASE
SO I THINK- WE OBVIOUSLY WILL
BE. REVISITING THAT AS WE-
DISCUSS- THIS TRAILER BILL. ALL
GOING GOING BACK TO THE COUPLE
OTHER ELEMENTS THAT ARE NOT
SCHOOL RELATED MISLI- CAN YOU
JUST. WALK US THROUGH- THE
SMALL BUSINESS APPROPRIATION
AND TALK ABOUT. OR CAN PROVIDE
SOME GREATER COMMENTING AROUND-
YOU TO WHETHER- WHAT THE
FEEDBACK HAS BEEN THE DATA HAS
BEEN. AROUND THE MONEY THAT HAS
GONE OUT AROUND THE HOLIDAYS.
AND WHETHER THAT IS GOING TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO AUGMENT. THE
PROGRAM AS IS WOULD YOU CAN GO
WITH- THE GUIDELINES- OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAM AND JUST ADD
MORE MONEY TO IT. RIGHT AND AS
YOU IN TERMS OF- THOSE GRANTS I
THINK ARE ONLY. NOW BEING
RELEASED AND SO I THINK THAT IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
AND TAKE YOUR THE FEEDBACK OF
THOSE WHO HAVE APPLIED. INVERT
IN REGARDS THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND- THE GUIDELINES SO
I THINK THAT THERE'S ALWAYS A
DESIRE TO THE INTERVIEW OF
PROCESS TO DO BETTER- I WOULD
HAVE TO TURN IT OVER TO ONE OF
MY- COLLEAGUES FOR THE
SPECIFICS. IN REGARDS TO THE
DETAIL THE QUESTION. THANK YOU.
FROM THE PERMANENT FINANCE- SO
WE'RE IN. AN INITIAL- GRANT-
WE'RE ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS
FOR THE FIRST ROUND OF GRANTS
THAT CLOSES AT THE END OF THE
DAY ON THE THIRTEENTH SO AT
THIS POINT TIME THERE ISN'T ANY
DATA AVAILABLE TO DETERMINE HOW
WE WOULD BE MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS BUT WE- DON'T.
EXPECT TO GET THAT DATA AND IN
THE COMING WEEKS- WE EXPECT THE
FIRST NOTICE OF APPROVAL TO BE
AS SOON AS JANUARY FIFTEENTH
AND WILL USE THAT DATA TO
INFORM- THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE ADDITIONAL.
AUGMENTATION WE'RE ASKING FOR
HERE. GOT I GOT I THINK I WE
ARE AS THE FIRST MANY MY
COLLEAGUES VERY SUPPORTIVE OF.
MONEY GOING TO THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT. I
THINK- IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK I'VE BEEN GETTING FROM
BUSINESSES LOOKING AT- WHICH
BUSINESSES MAY HAVE HAD THE
GREATEST INCOME LOSS- SO
ESPECIALLY FROM DIFFERENT ARTS
AND CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO. OPEN UP
AT ALL- PERHAPS THERE'S A WAY
TO HAVE GREATER TEARING OR
MAYBE A BONUS FOR- COMPANIES OR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE HAD-
90% OR MORE WHATEVER THE PROPER
PERCENTAGE. OF INCOME LOSS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN BLE
TO OPEN UP. ALSO THERE'S A
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT WILL BE INCREASED-
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS JUST
TO TIDE PEOPLE OVER FOR A MONTH
OR TWO. WHETHER WE WOULD LOOK
AT. DOING SOMETHING. LARGER IN
THEN I KNOW THAT WHEN WE WERE
IN DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE GRANT
PROPOSAL JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THE GRANTS WERE GOING OUT ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. IN THAT THERE
WAS A PROPER EQUITY BETWEEN.
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS AROUND
THE STATE I KNOW THE CDFI THAT
WAS IN CHARGE OF. DISTRIBUTING
THAT WAS VERY SENSITIVE TO IT
WE JUST WANT TO SEE AS WE GET
THE DATA WITH THE DATA ACTUALLY
REFLECTS THERE ARE THERE ARE
GOOD INTENTIONS. I'M JUST
JUMPING INTO. THE CDC ARE FOR A
SECOND-YOU KNOW MISS LEE ONE
OF THE THAT YOU KNOW TO THE
HIGHEST CASES OF. COLD WITH A
VISITATIONS WITH COVETED- THAT
THE STATE HAS SOME. DIRECT
CONTROL OR REGULATORY AUTHORITY
AUTHORITY WORK. AROUND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AS WELL AS
OUR STATE PRISONS. SO- AND ON
MY COLLEAGUES JONES SAWYER SORT
OF TALK ABOUT THIS- BUT CAN YOU
WALK THROUGH. THE PRECAUTIONS
THAT ARE. BEING ADDRESSED TO
LIMIT. ON THE AMOUNT OF COVERT
FROM ENTERING INTO- THE
DIFFERENT PRESENTS- AGAIN. MOST
OF THE CULPRIT APPEARS TO HAVE
BEEN ROUGHT INTO THE FACILITY
EITHER BY TRANSFERS OR BY.
EMPLOYEES SO IF YOU COULD SORT
OF COMMENT ON WHAT PRECAUTIONS
ARE BEING TAKEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO REALLY LIMIT THE-
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE FOR THOSE
FACILITIES. I'M SURE I'LL START
AND THEN I WILL- HEADED OVER TO
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES BUT JUST
AGAIN I'M POINTING TO BE. A
DIRECT RESPONSE COST ESTIMATES
THAT WE HAVE IN THE BUDGET IS
THE RECOGNITION THAT THAT OUT
THE SPREAD IN PRISONS IS IT
SIGNIFICANT AND WE HAVE PUT
FORWARD PART OF IT OF MONEY-
BUT IN TERMS OF THE DETAILS
I'LL I. WILL HAND IT OVER TO
ONE MY COLLEAGUES. HI THIS IS A
COMPOUND AGAIN- ARMENIANS DONE
QUITE A BIT OBVIOUSLY. THE
SAUDIS ARE AT GREATEST RISK FOR
COCONUT SPREAD I'M DAVE
RESTRICTED IN MY MOVEMENTS-
ACTIVATED JIM STATE ROOMS
TEMPERATURE- TEND TO SAUDIS TO
CREATE PHYSICAL DISTANCING-
THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED INMATE
AND STAFF TESTING PROCEDURES-
THERE ARE CURRENTLY CONDUCTING
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
TESTS PER MONTH ON EMPLOYEES
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND TESTS ON
INMATES ONE PLACE- THEY'VE-
WITH THERE'S A NUMBER OF
POPULATION REDUCTION- MEASURES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE. SINCE
THE START OF A PANDEMIC-
INCLUDING CLOSURE INTAKE FOR
MOST THE TIME TO COUNTY JAILS
AND IS CURRENTLY OVER IN EIGHT
THOUSAND MATES INCOMING JAILS
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE IN STATE
PRISON SO ALL THOSE EFFORTS
TAKEN TOGETHER- ARE SORT OF
THERE WERE SPONSORED AND
THERE'S EVEN. MORE THAN I WOULD
DESCRIBE. IT IS ALSO- RESUME-
REQUIRING ALL STAFF AND
CONTRACTORS TO WORKERS. MASK
INSTEAD OF JUST COOPER IN. IT
STAFF AND CONTRACTORS ARE
PROVIDED DOES ON A DAILY BASIS.
THANK YOU IN TERMS OF EMPLOYEES
WORK FOR QUARANTINE PROTOCOLS
OR- TESTING PROTOCOLS ARE BEING
ASKED TO BE EMPLOYEES. SO HIGH
LET ME GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
SPECIFICS THERE- I DON'T RECALL
GIVEN THE RECENT OUTBREAK I
BELIEVE. THEIR. TESTING
PROCEDURES EVERYONE AGREES
SEVEN DAYS I LOOK LET LET ME
GET BACK TO YOU JUST TO BE
SURE. AND IF AN EMPLOYEE
TRAVELS OUT. OF KERRIER ARE
THEY BEING ASKED TO QUARANTINE.
AFTER THEY WERE TRYING TO. I
DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY ON THAT
ON HOW TO GET BACK TO YOU. I
DON'T KNOW THE SECRETARY HAD IN
OUR LAST HEARING- EMAILED OUT-
GUIDELINES- THE BIT AT LEAST AT
RO LAST YEAR I DIDN'T HEAR THE
GUIDELINES WERE BEING. FOLLOWED
DO WE- SEE THAT THERE'S GREATER
ADHERENCE TO THE GUIDELINES
THAT HAVE BEEN. AND I THOUGHT I
THINK I WAS LIKE THE SECOND OR
THIRD OR FOURTH TIME THOSE
GUIDELINES HAVE BEEN EMAILED
OUT. OF ARE WE- WITNESSING ANY
GREATER ADHERENCE TO GUIDELINES.
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT IT HEARINGS TO- MASKEY
STAGE GREAT- AND THEN IN TERMS
OF- THE- THE SPREAD HOW HOW IS
THE CONTAINMENT GOING WITHIN
THE FACILITIES. HOW ARE THE
NUMBERS LOOKING IN THE
FACILITIES WELL I THINK THE
NUMBERS ARE UP. FROM WHERE THEY
WERE IT'S SORT OF THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC I THINK THEY
GOT AS HIGH AS NINE THOUSAND
FOR INMATES- IN LOOKING AT OUR
WEBSITE TODAY I THINK I MEMBERS
CLOSER TO SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED-
BUT I THINK. THAT THERE ARE
GOOD GIANT THERE AND REALIZE
THERE'S STILL AN EMERGENCY
STATE- GIVEN HOW HIGH THE
NUMBERS ARE SO I'M JUST
CONTINUING TO MONITOR AND DO
THEIR BEST TO PREVENT FURTHER
SPREAD. THANK YOU AND THIS IS A
MATTER BEFORE THE STRONG
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES- CAN
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A STRIKE
TEAM THAT THE PAYMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS. ON HOW HOW'S THAT
STRIKE TEAM. DOING IN A THE TO.
AGAIN SORT OF LIMIT THE SPREAD
WITHIN THE OF NURSING
FACILITIES A SEEMS
UNFORTUNATELY LIKE ONCE YOU
HAVE ONE INCIDENT SIMILAR TO
PRISONS YOU JUST END UP HAVING
A MASSIVE SPREAD WITHIN A
PARTICULAR. FACILITY SO JUST
ONE UNDERSTAND- HOW THE DPH THE
STRIKE TEAM IS DOING AS WELL AS
WHAT ADDITIONAL PROTOCOLS WILL
BE PUT IN PLACE TO SORT OF
LIMIT THE SPREAD AND THE
DIFFERENT- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THE QUESTION TO
FINANCE ALL YES CAN I. OKAY
SORRY I WAS WONDERING IF ADAM
TO RECEIVE IT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO THAT.
RIGHT YEP THIS IS THE ADAM TO
RECEIVE FINANCES YES THE THAT
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH CDC ARE ANOTHER
OTHER DEPARTMENTS- YOU KNOW
WHEN THESE ISSUES ARISE BUT- I
DON'T HAVE ANY YOU KNOW DETAILS
ABOUT SORT OF OUTCOMES AT THIS
POINT YOU WILL HAVE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU ON THAT. THE TAR
SORRY THIS IS ON TRANSIT OR SO
WE THOUGHT IT SWITCHED TOPICS
TO SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
SON OF YOU'RE THE APPROPRIATE
PERSON. YEAH I GUESS IT'S A
VERY SIMILAR ANSWER I MEAN AS
MUCH LIKE THAT WITH CCR AND I
AND OTHERS THAT YOU KNOW- LOVE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
DETAILS AROUND. YOU KNOW THOSE
KIND OF SPECIFICS OKAY HASTA
LAS CARPENTER TEAM TO. FALL ON.
IT AND THEN JUST LASTLY I KNOW
THE NUMBER OF MEMBERS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE TV I THINK IT
JUST GOES TO UNDERSCORE THAT.
IN ALL EIGHTY OF OUR OFFICES
HAVE BEEN INUNDATED WITH PHONE
CALLS. ON WE'VE JUST GOT-
ANOTHER. MAY ORG I GUESS
COMMUNICATION THAT WENT OUT ON
TOP OF THE- THREE TO FOUR WEEKS
IT WILL TAKE FOR THE NEW
IDENTIFICATION SOFTWARE TO
VERIFY. IDENTIFICATIONS JUST
SEEMS- SORT OF MIND BLOWING
GIVEN THAT MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
JUST HAD THEIR IDENTITIES
VERIFIED- I BELIEVE NOW THERE
ARE- SOME. NEW ISSUES WITH
SOFTWARE THAT WILL- THAT WE
WERE JUST I THINK JUST HOLD. ON
FOR LIKE A DAY A DAY AGO THAT
ARE NOW FROM BEING. JUST JUST
COMMUNICATED IS I MEAN. OUR OUR
OUR FRUSTRATION IS THE- WE'RE
TRYING TO WE ARE SORT OF
EXTENSIONS OF THE EDT CALL
CENTER WE WANT TO BE GIVING.
OUR CONSTITUENTS AS MUCH REAL
TIME INFORMATION AS WE CAN
HOWEVER IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DO THAT IF HE DID HE'S NOT
GIVING US OF THAT REAL TIME
INFORMATION AND- IT IS-
DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE GET
INUNDATED. WITH PHONE CALLS
WHEN SORT OF SOMETHING HAPPENS
WITH EDT SO HOW HOW DO WE SORT
OF RECTIFY THIS COMMUNICATION
ISSUE. THE N. FROST WELL WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE. CONSTITUENT
PHONE CALLS WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT D. D. SHOULD BE HANDLING
THESE. CASES DIRECTLY SO HOW
HOW DO WE- SORT OF- PASS THESE
CASES ON TV TO- MANAGE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE.
AS THESE ISSUES ARISE- FRANKLY
WEREN'T WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ANSWERS AND ALL IN ALL WE
COULD YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE-
WE'RE DOING ON. YOU KNOW MY
STUFF GIVEN THE LATEST SNAFU IS
ACTUALLY SENDING OUT US
SOMETHING THAT WE NEVER DO
WHICH IS SORT OF A PUB MORE
BOILERPLATE. EMAIL JUST TO
DRESSING THE ISSUE JUST BECAUSE
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE. ANY
INFORMATION. UP YES- MISTER
CHAIR UNDERSTAND YOUR
FRUSTRATION AND THAT MANY
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
FRUSTRATED AT THIS- I WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE- ISSUE WITH THE
IDENTIFICATION APPLICATION- BUT
IN REGARDS TO- COMMUNICATION
GENERALLY AGREE THAT. MORE
NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND- IT'S NOT A
AN EXCUSE BUT THERE ARE OTHERS-
A LOT OF WORK GOING ON EASY AND
IT AND I UNDERSTAND SOMETIMES.
THINGS GET DROPPED- BUT OUT OF
I COMMIT TO MAINTAIN THAT
CONVERSATION- WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM OFTEN-
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT GETS OUT
BUT I- I BELIEVE THAT. JUST AS
WITH THE EDUCATION ISSUE WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS. FIGURE FOUR ONE
HERE STAFF WILLING TO. GIVE US
A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION. I'M
DANIEL BRANDON DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER INFORMATION TO PROVIDE IN
REGARDS TO EDITH. THANK YOU
DANIELLE BRANDON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST ECHOING MISLEADS
COMMENTS THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU FOLKS AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH EDT THANK
YOUNG. NO THANK YOU AND I KNOW
THAT- LOOK WE WHAT WE WANNA. I
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT IS
STRUGGLING THEY HAVE BEEN ENDED
INUNDATED WITH CLAIMS JUST LIKE
WE ALL HAVE BUT WE NEED TO BE
IN A SITUATION WERE ACTUALLY
STARTING. TO- MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WALL I KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE TAKEN- SOME INITIAL
FEEDBACK ESPECIALLY FROM EARLY
ON IN THE PANDEMIC FROM YOU
KNOW MARCH APRIL MAY AND HAVE
MADE IMPROVEMENTS. IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING. TO CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THEM. AT A TIME
WHEN- ISSUES CONSTANTLY ARRIVE
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
WITH NEW. SOFTWARE THEY'RE
ALWAYS GLITCHES AND THERE IS-
SORT OF ISSUES BUT AGAIN- IT IS
IT IS VERY CHALLENGING TO
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. TO
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO ADDRESS. THE
LATEST C. D. D. ISSUE WHETHER
IT'S GOING FROM THE BANK. DEBIT
CARD- FREEZING AND AGAIN I HAVE
A STANDING REQUEST FOR THREE
WEEKS FROM THIS TO THE
SECRETARY. ASKING FOR A MEETING
BETWEEN BANK AMERICA AB DE D.
BECAUSE I'M TIRED OF. HEARING
BOTH. THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
CORPORATION BLAME EACH OTHER SO
I WANT THEM IN A ROOM TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
FIX IT- WHETHER IT'S THE YOU
KNOW THE ID IDENTIFICATION OR
WHETHER IT IS THE- THE MOST
RECENT ISSUE AROUND NEW CLAIMS
AND THE- LATEST I BELIEVE MY
UNDERSTAND IS THE LATEST
FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGE. SO
AGAIN- COMMITTEE WE AS A STATE
HAVE COMPLETE CONTROL OF THIS
AGENCY AND NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO WRITE
THAT SHIP I KNOW THAT- WE WANT
TO BE SUPPORT OF I KNOW THAT MY
STAFF HAS. IS ON ALL THE WEEKLY
CALLS COSTLY GIVING FEEDBACK IN
TERMS OF WHAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE TELLING US I'M SURE- ALMOST
ALL THESE OTHER MEMBERS AND
THEIR STAFFS ARE DOING THE
SAME. I THINK WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO SEE IS- SIGNIFICANT
CORRECTION FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
IN ORDER TO RELIEVE HEALED AT
THE RISK TRUST AND- YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BETTER A BETTER
WORKING WITH. BETWEEN THE
BETWEEN OUR ARMED LEGISLATURE
AND THAT THE PART. SO ON THAT
NOTE I'M NOT SEEING ANY OTHER.
HANDS OR ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
FROM INDIVIDUALS SO WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO. PUBLIC COMMENT
I WOULD JUST- YOU WERE GOING TO
GOAL ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO MAKE
UP A MINUTE. MINUTE COMMENT
EACH I JUST DO WANT TO
REITERATE REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE PUBLIC WHO HAD BEEN HERE
LISTENING FOR QUITE A LONG
HEARING AND APPRECIATE THEIR
PATIENCE AND ALSO JUST REMIND
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM. THAT THIS IS THE FIRST OF
MANY MANY HEARINGS- WE PLAN TO
HAVE OVER THIRTY SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS OVER THE NEXT TEN
WEEKS TO FULLY ANALYZE EVERY
PIECE OF THE BUDGET AND AGAIN
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE THEIR
CHANCE TO COMMENT EACH OF ONE
OF THOSE TIMES- ALSO WANT TO
REPEAT THE PHONE NUMBER WHICH
IS ONE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
WITH AN ACCESS CODE OF TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. IF
YOU'RE WATCHING ME ONLINE I
ASSUME IT'S BEING SHOWN ON THE
ON THE SCREEN SO YOU CAN.
HOPEFULLY SEE IT BUT- LET'S GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT SIR. BARCELON
MEDIA. WE HAVE A BIG BUDGETS
BIG STATES MY NAME IS A MY NAME
IS RICHARD I CAME HERE I'M GLAD
I DID- ARM I'M SEEING SOMETHING
THIS KIND OF COMMON WITH A LOT
OF LEADERS- THERE. THINKING
THEY HAVE TO MAKE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
US THAT WE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
OURSELVES. I'M SEEING PEOPLE
RESPONDING OUT OF FEAR FEAR TOO
MANY THINGS. FEAR OF TOO MANY
THINGS. AND THE BIGGEST FEAR I
SEE RESPONDING TO THE FEAR OF
COAL. NOW I HAVE A BIG PROBLEM
WITH FOUR BILLION DOLLARS BEING
SPENT. ON VACCINES ON. LOW
TRACING IN ON ON TESTING WENT
ZERO DOLLARS IS BEING SPENT ON
PROVEN THERAPEUTICS HE ALSO IN
THIS CHAMBER YOU HEAR A LOT OF
PEOPLE THEY'RE MANIPULATING
INFORMATION AND I CAN TELL THE
MOST OF YOU WATCH MAINSTREAM
MEDIA. WILL TELL YOU THE TRUTH
RIGHT NOW WOULD BE AND DUKE IN
A BAD WAY AND TO SAVE THE WORLD
FROM GLOBAL WARMING TO SAVE THE
WORLD FROM KOBE. YEAH DON'T
HURT OUR COUNTRY GET DON'T
IGNORE CONSTITUTION AND YET
DON'T HURT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND MOST OF ALL
DON'T PUT DOCTORS IN CHARGE OF
THE WALL. YOU STAND UP TO THIS
GUY. THIS OVERSEAS HIS
AUTHORITY PLEASE PEOPLE ARE
HURTING. I WISH I COULD SPEAK
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE HERE IN THE
HOMELESS OUTSIDE BUT WE ARE
HURTING WE DON'T NEED TO STAY
SHUT DOWN ANOTHER DAY
ESPECIALLY OUR SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO KEEP HIM SHUT DOWN
WITH THE BAT INDOCTRINATION
THAT OUR KIDS ARE DOING GOING
THROUGH GREAT. BECAUSE OF HOME
SCHOOLING TEACHERS DOING A LOT
BETTER RIGHT NOW. BIRDS ARE
HARDLY GOT A JOB IN FROM YOU
BUT OUT OF THE FEAR. TURN OFF
THE TV NEWS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE- WE CAN HAVE THE FIRST
CALLER. YES MIGHT BE AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER ONE
THEN THEY'RE FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT LOCAL TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THE TERM MEMBERS WHO
SHALL GIVE US WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF MY LIFE URGENT FUNDING
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OTHER
CRITICAL PARTNERS INTERSTATE
COMPANY IN RESPONSE THERE THE
PANDEMIC LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT LOOK LIKE
BRANDED PACKING FIGHT HIRED
MULTITUDE OF CONTACT RATE
THERE'S A DISEASE
INVESTIGATORS. ARE PROVIDED
SUPPORT TO VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS FOR QUARANTINE AND
ISOLATION CURRENTLY LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING TO RAMP UP VACCINATION
SITE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
PORT THE QUICK ADMINISTRATION
OF ACTING AND WHILE THE STATE A
COUPLE MINOR EFFORT. IT IS NOT
ELIMINATED THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE ACTIVITIES FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE RISK
LOSING SOME OF THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION IN THE CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR TO PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING-
TED. GET A FEW THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS. MILLION PRIORITIZE-
HOLDEN NINETY BACKING. AND THEN
A- TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOR
CO TECH. AT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
NINE FOR CON THREE DISEASE
INVESTING. AND SUPPORT FOR THE
MOST. IN IT'S ALSO CRITICAL
THAT CAN. REINVESTING
REPUBLICAN YEAH FOR SURE.
BEYOND JUST THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DO SO BY PROVIDING
FIFTY NINE. ON THE GENERAL. THE
COMPANY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
EQUITY WHICH WILL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO REBUILD OUR
STAFFING. AND ALSO IN BAD THREE
POINT MILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR
A STUDY ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TO EVALUATE
WORKFORCE NEEDS STAFFING AND
OTHER NEEDS TO ENSURE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
ADEQUATELY REFERS TO CARRY OUT
THEIR DUTIES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. MEXICO
ALL TIME THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND JUST SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN THE QUEUE.
THE STATION AND TOWNIES- I
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
MICHELLE GIVEN JUST MADE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BRAG BUDGET AND THE
TYPICALLY THE ONE BILLION FOR
WILD. PREVENTION AND THE ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR ON
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AS THE
CALTRAIN INVESTMENT. WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH IS THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH MICHELLE JUST WENT
THROUGH. AND IN ADDITION
BROADBAND- BOTH ARE CRITICAL.
TO LIVING THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
AND ALSO GETTING OUT OF IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAXALT
ONLINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT IN LINE OUT
THERE WELL MOST OF MY FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. EATING
THIS IS ANDREA SAN MIGUEL ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA- I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SEVEN
AFFILIATES THAT SERVE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- THROUGH OVER A HUNDRED
HEALTH CENTERS- JUST TWO QUICK
POINTS WE ARE RELIEVED TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
MAINTAINS. THE INVESTMENT IN
THINKING THAT PROVIDERS THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE- BY ALL OF
YOU WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
FORM OF PAYMENTS FUNDED BY
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX- MORE
OFTEN ENCOURAGE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET NOTE
STATE NEED FOR ONGOING
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITIES IN
MEDIC CAL- THAT SOME OF YOU ARE
AWARE PLAN PARENTS SEVEN AND-
AFFILIATES IN THE STATE HAVE
BEEN. IMPLEMENTING TELEHEALTH
ANOTHER INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER CARE
WHILE MAINTAINING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING SO THAT PATIENTS CAN
BE NOT WHERE THEY ARE WHICH IS-
YOU KNOW NOT JUST ONLINE OR IN
PERSON AT ALL SO OFTEN BY
TELEPHONE SO WE ARE EAGER O
SEE WHICH OF THE FLEXIBILITIES
ARE INCLUDED. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN AND THE
FORTHCOMING DETAILS WHICH WERE
EXPECTING- I THINK WE HEARD ON
OR BY FEBRUARY ONE SPECIFICALLY
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU ALL KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE
INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. ON
THROUGH THOSE TELEPHONE VISIT
REMOTE ENROLLMENT FOR LIMITED
CO PROGRAMS AS WELL AS PAYMENT
PARITY- SO THANK YOU FOR-
HOSTING THIS VENUE CAN WE COULD
SHARE THAT. AND FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK. THANK YOU. MAXIM DON'T
FIFTY ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS
REGINA AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND I WANT TO
FIRST ECHO DE SUPPORT FOR THE
COMPANY'S BUDGET THAT CONCERNS
THE SAFETY NET AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. I DO WANT TO URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER THAT THE NEEDS OF
DISABLED PEOPLE AND BLIND
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR. THOSE
LOSING THEIR VISION OR LIVING
WITH VISION LOSS CURRENTLY I
HAPPEN NOT CONSIDERED WHEN.
SETTING UP EMERGENCY PROGRAMS.
LIKE ROOM OPERATION ROOM KEY
AND- THE STIMULUS AND ALL THAT
THE COVERAGES STATE THAT MEANS
A BLIND PEOPLE WHO DO NOT DRIVE
OR CANNOT READ PRINT THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE IN WHEELCHAIRS THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING.
THAT PEOPLE WHO WALKED TO. ARE
BEING OVER FIFTY. AND ACROSS
THE BOARD AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED NOW IT'S VERY
CONCERNING TO ME AND TO ALL OF
US IN OUR COMMUNITY SAID LAST
THING IS THAT THE STIMULUS IS
FOR THE LOWEST. INCOME THAT
THOSE MAKING UNDER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT ARE
CALLED THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THOSE OF US THAT
ARE HONEST AND FINANCES- D. I.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AMONG US
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WAS 50% OR
MORE. IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY IT
WAS 70% IT IS WASTE WAY ABOVE
THEIR TO ANYWHERE FROM. 6585%
NOW. THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY
ARE GREAT AND I'M AFRAID
BECAUSE OF THE EMERGENCY
PANDEMIC THERE BEING OVERLOOKED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT
DOOR TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I WANT TO
ECHO THE LAST SPEAKER THAT WE
WANT AT THAT BY AT THAT HE
COULD BE AND BE INCLUDED IN THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULANT- AS YOU
KNOW EFFORT BY THE AT THE BY IT
THAT HE PROGRAM. IS THE ONE
PROGRAM THAT NEVER RECOVERED
AFTER THE CUTS IN THE GREAT
RECESSION- AND EVERY YEAR WE
ARE LOOKING FOR PARITY FOR- DID
POPULATION. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. MAXIMO
TIMELINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING REBEKAH
MARKETS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST WE APPRECIATE
THE EARLY SUPPORT FOR
REINSTATING FUNDING TO CRITICAL
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAM AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
CRAFT FUNDING SOLUTIONS THAT
WORK TO ADVANCE FARMLAND
PROTECTION ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MAXED ALMOST ONLINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ARAMBULA KIDS REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE BUDGET CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BLUEPRINT FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET WHICH
INCLUDES RETAIN SCHOOL
CONTROLS. WITH RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ELIMINATING ALL
REMAINING DEFERRAL TO ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO MEET PRE COATED
NINETEEN TEN DEMOCRATS
POSSIBILITIES AND SERVICES TO
OUR STUDENTS EDUCATORS AND
FAMILIES. AND TO PREPARE. FOR
THE IMPACT FUTURE BUDGET
CHALLENGES. WE THE CALL IN THE
STATE SCHOOL FOR ALL GRANT.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE OF. FOR FUN.
TO SCHOOLS AND WE DIDN'T
CURRENTLY IN THE CARE HAVING HI
KOPEN AND- INCLUDING LAWCENTER
COUNTY. BASED DISTRICT NEED
THIS TO BE PREPARED TO REOPEN
ONE THE INFECTION RATE
REQUIREMENTS ARE MET. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND OUR MUTUAL PRIORITIES THANK
YOU AND. TAKE CARE. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A THREE MORNINGS AS
A MIND ONE THEN ZERO FOR ANY
COMMENTS NEXT DOOR TO LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS RANDOM
MARTIN FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
ON A HEALTH CARE WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RELATIVE TO THE PROP FIFTY SIX.
DELAY OF THE SUSPENSION- AND
LOOK FOR THE LEGISLATURE ON
APPROVING THAT AS YOU AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD- ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR OF
PASSING THROUGH THE MONEY THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS-
APPROPRIATED FOR PURPOSE OF
RENTAL RENT RELIEF ASSISTANCE-
BUT WE DO SUBMIT THAT THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY IS FAR LESS
THAN IS ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE
NECESSARY. THERE ARE
PROJECTIONS THAT RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS ARE CURRENTLY
INDEBTED TO THE TUNE OF FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE AND
THAT AMOUNT IS ONLY GOING TO
INCREASE- THE EXTENT TO WHICH
WE EXTEND. THE- EVICTION
MORATORIUM AS AS AS PROPOSED SO
WE NEED TO BE PREPARED TO STEP
UP WITH SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
OTHERWISE THERE'S A TIDAL WAVE.
OF EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES
COMING THAT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THE MORE TIME
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
THE FERODO DS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER MY COMMENT IS SPECIFIC
TO THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE NOT EXPLICITLY
CALLED OUT AS A GROUP OF
STUDENTS TO BE PROVIDED IN IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. ENGLISH
LEARNERS HAVE NOT BEEN PROVIDED
CONSISTENT INSTRUCTION EITHER
BOB THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING
OUR IN PERSON IN CLASS
INSTRUCTION THEY HAVE HAD- LACK
OF ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS-
I NEED FOR- CONSISTENT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT WE BELIEVE
THAT ENGLISH LEARNERS. ARE ALL
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ALONG WITH
THE OTHER STUDENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED FOR THE FUNDS
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT ENGLISH LEARNERS BE
INCLUDED IN THE IDENTIFIED
GROUPS OF STUDENTS TO BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAXO TIME
SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
IS JUST RATHER ON OF WORKERS
OWNED OR K. OR WORK- WE ARE A
COALITION FORMED BY STATE AND
NATIONAL EXPERTS WORKER OWNED
COMPANIES AND LABOR UNIONS
WORKING FOR YEARS TO ADVANCE
WORKER OWNERSHIP IN COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED. BY SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES WE
APPRECIATE CHECKING IN YOUR
FELLOW COLLEAGUES I'M ASKING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE QUESTIONS
AROUND YOU KNOW WHETHER IT THE
ADDITIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF WILL BE TARGETED WITH-
WHETHER THERE WILL BE YOU KNOW
EQUITY CRITERIA- TO ENSURE THAT
THESE DOLLARS GO TO THOSE BEEN
WITHIN. WE NEED IT THE MOST AND
WE JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
PROMOTE WORKER OWNERSHIP
PERSPECTIVE THAT EVEN BEFORE
COBIT WITH THE THREAT OF A WAVE
OF BUSINESS CLOSURES TO
DISCOVER TSUNAMI AND RETHINK-
WORKER OWNERSHIP WHERE THE
WORKERS BY OUT THE OWNER- WHEN
THE OWNER MAY STILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THAT THIS IS A VIABLE
OPTION THAT RATHER THAN OUR
SMALL BOAT BUSINESSES CLOSING
FOR GOOD OR SELLING TO LARGE
OUT OF STATE. BUYERS THESE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS CAN FIND
WILLING BUYERS IN THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK ALONGSIDE THEM EVERY
DAY THEIR WORKERS SO WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME WILL BE
CIRCULATING A LETTER- WITH YOUR
STAFF. ACTUALLY THANK YOU. MAX
TIME FORTY FIVE GO AHEAD. HI
MISTER CARE NUMBER THIS IS
ANDREW CHANGED DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL SUPPORT THAT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THE
BANK- PURCHASE ONE ONLINE MY
PHONES MY COMMENT WITH- THE
COMMENTS BY- REGINA AND BY
RESIDENT OLATUNDE WE MUST MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO RUN AT THE
SINUSES P. ARE NOT EXCLUDED
FROM THE STATE IN NORTH AND WE
CAN DO THAT. EFFECTIVELY BY
INCREASING THAT THIS P. ON A
ONE TIME BASIS TO ENSURE PARITY
WITH GOLDEN STATE THE NEW YORK-
AND THEN IN TERMS OF FOOD
SECURITY- WE ARE OF COURSE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE IF THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EMERGENCY FOOD AT
TWELVE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE BANK. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WITH HUNGER AT RECORD
LEVELS THAT COULD NOT BE WHERE-THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
STOP WE HAVE TO BE MORE WE WITH
A SECONDARY PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS FROM HUNGER AND. COULD
REALLY BE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND ON MY MIND OR IF YOU WISH
TO COMMON PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO NOW COME. WE DO
HAVE A FEW QUEUING UP IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. AND AS A
REMINDER ONE THEN ZERO FOR ANY
COMMENT. NEXT CALL TIELINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO IS GOING THROUGH THIS IS
JEFF. HELLO HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU- THANK YOU ARE YOU HAVE NOT
LITTLE CONFIRMATION EVERYWHERE
THIS IS JUST TURNED A YEAR
ARMENIA ADVOCATE BY
PARTICIPATED NEAR MASTER PLAN
BY PARTICIPATING IN YOUR HEALTH
CARE- SHOULD WE SAY A
COMMISSION THERE ARE
PARTICIPATED IN YOUR- TWO WEEKS
A YEAR- DEALING WITH THE A FOR-
THESE THINGS ALL NEED. BUTTON
BUT ALSO YOU PLEASE NEED TO
JUST CANCER THE WHAT WORKS WITH.
HUNDRED STIMULUS BUT ALSO THOSE
THAT ARE UNDER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THAT IS MOSTLY THE
SSR. THERE BUT- S. T. E. JERRY
WAS SO SECURITY- YOUR KNOCKING
THOSE IN. MARKET FOR. I AM A
NATIVE CAL HERE'S- MOSTLY
PARTNER STUFF FROM POINT IN
TRYING. SO ALL OF THESE THINGS
IN TO. AND YOU NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A SOLUTION THAN WHAT YOU'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND HEALTH
SERVICES NEED TO BE DESCRIBED
OF TURN DEMONSTRATED. THE
PROBLEMS THAT YOU NEED TO DO
BETTER- ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS AND I WILL BE
LISTENING TO YOU COMMENTING
FURTHER ABOUT YOUR EFFORTS AND
WHAT IS LACKING- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HEY ONLY IF YOU
ABOUT FOUR MORE THANK NEXT BOOK
ONLINE FOR PLEASE LOG. HI GOOD
EVENING- THIS IS MANUEL ONE
GIRL I DON'T ALTEA. CALIFORNIA
TOGETHER- I'M CALLING TO
REQUIRE- THAT ENGLISH LEARNERS
BE INCLUDED IN THE LIST OF
STUDENTS. THAT MUST BE
PRIORITIZED OR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. I PROPOSED THAT
TWO BILLION IN ONE TIME GRANTS
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION DOES
NOT CURRENT CURRENTLY
EXPLICITLY CALLED OUT THE WHICH
LEARNERS. HE DIDN'T HAVE A DOOR
CHALLENGE OF DEVELOPING ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY. AND
ACADEMIC CONTENT IN
MECHANICALLY. LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IT'S CRITICAL
STUDENTS LEARN BY TAKING
LANGUAGE MODEL BY BOTH THEIR
TEACHERS AND THEIR PEERS. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE AND REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO THE TRACKING OF
ATTENDANCE AND ENGAGEMENT. WE
DO REQUIRE THAT THE DATA ON
ATTENDANCE AND ENGAGEMENT THE
DISAGGREGATED AND RECORDED BY
STUDENT GROUPS THAT WE BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF THIS
CRISIS ON OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. THANK YOU AND PLEASE
DO WHAT DO WHAT WE CAMPUS
PARKING WESTERNERS THANK. THANK
YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ERIC CALLING
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP WE CAN
RUN THE GOVERNOR FOR
PRIORITIZING IMMEDIATE
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES THAT CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS AND ECONOMIC LIKE
THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER AND WE
ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
FLEXIBILITIES IN TELEHEALTH
IMPORTANT MEETING CHILDREN'S
NEEDS FOR DENTAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH FACTORS AMONG OTHER
SERVICES. WE OFFER WHICH ALSO
LEADS ME TO THINK THE GOVERNOR
FOR THE EARLY SUPPORTERS-
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
BUT THE ONE TIME FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENT IN
PREVENTATIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES BY
SCHOOL. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR SUPPORTING
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT NEW
FIFTY FIVE MILLION COVERED
RELATE RELATED SUPPORT FOR THE
STRENGTHENING EARLY EDUCATION
AND CHILD CARE TO HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES NEED TO
HAVE ARISEN AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
MEET THE HOLISTIC NEEDS OF
CHILDREN IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
THRIVE TODAY AND IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
MAXIM MOTEL SIX FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS RAW LANE
ON TOP OF THE COUNCIL- OF CAN
MEET BAY GIRL HOW AGENT. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE SPOKE ON
ASPECTS THE HEALTH SECTOR AND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IN PARTICULAR
WE AT THE VHA LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OTHERS
THAT THEY CRAFTED BUDGET THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE NEEDS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
CLIENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAXWELL MOTEL LINE SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS KEVIN AND LET YOU KNOW
WHAT THE COLDEST OF CALIFORNIA
WHAT BOOK MULTIVITAMIN
ADDITION- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT- WE'D
LIKE TO COVER THE BUDGET AND
IT'S VERY WILL BAR HOWEVER IT
HAS ONE MAJOR SHORTCOMING IS
BETTER HAPPENED IN THE CHILDREN
ON CAL WORKS. THEY'VE BEEN LEFT
OUT DO IN DOING POVERTY AND
ACCOUNT WORKS PROGRAM THERE
GRANT WAIT UP BELOW 50%
SPECIALLY BABBAGE GRANT TECH
TRAVEL EXPERIMENTS GET INTO TOP.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET. APPLE'S PROGRAM ARE
GOING TO BE FROM TOP OF.
FAMILIES AND- COULD YOU WILL
DIE THE CAR. TO THE GENERAL
FUND I THINK WE SHOULD IF. GET
THAT MONEY IS THE COMPLEX. AND
HELP TO CHOKE- CALIFORNIA'S
POOR CHILDREN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. UNDER AND CARING THE
CHILDREN. THANK YOU BYE THANK
YOU. AND ALLOW MY MINOR YOU
WISH TIME ONE THERE AGAIN ONE
FAIR NOW. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR ANY
MORE PEOPLE UP IN THE GALLERY.
SOON NO PEOPLE IN THE GALLERY
HELLO WE WILL ADJOURN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO STAYED TILL THE END OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DURING THE FIRST
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING OF THE EAR.